this is Jocko podcast number 391 with
Carrie Helton and me Jocko willink good
evening Carrie good evening
we moved out just after zero two hundred
we functioned seamlessly as a unit
pushing through the quiet Pitch Black
Knight toward the compound rising out of
the dusty Iraqi streets our orders were
to capture or kill the target
we had confirmation that the terrorist
was in the building
the assault element including myself
scaled the six foot concrete fence in
perfect silence while the designated
security element circled the walled
compound to make sure the terrorist
Escape was impossible
we hit the ground with barely a rattle
within moments I was shouldered up
against the outer wall of a building
just inside the fence a string of men
with me
with practiced movements I set a
breaching charge on the door and on my
signal my security element and I began
to walk back toward the designated space
around the corner where the rest of the
assault element were ready were already
taking cover
the moment we began to move however
I realized with a sinking feeling that
the reconnaissance images I'd studied
earlier hadn't shown the mound of rubble
in the same Corner between the wall and
fence
there was barely enough space left to
cover most of the assault element
I wasn't going to fit
and there was no time to scale the
concrete fence and take cover
it was a split second decision I backed
myself as far from the door as possible
and then dropped to my knees I covered
my face with my M4 curling up to protect
as much of my body as possible
based on the careful calculations for
safe standoff I knew I would still be
relatively safe as far as the shock wave
was concerned
I learned early on from my previous
direct action missions to calculate the
safe distance from breaching charges in
two ways one normally per the manual and
one for situations like this
for me
the second calculation was important for
times when I may not make it to cover
but needed to have an absolute minimum
safe distance
it was a distance from the breaching
charge that could cause injury but
should not be incapacitating
I was hoping to never use it
once I knew everyone else had cover
I quietly passed the call over the radio
turning steel turning steel turning
Steel
and I detonated the charge on the door
the blast blew fragments of the door out
right over my head with a thunderous
sound that rattled my skull a shock wave
that felt like it lifted me off my knees
slammed me back onto the ground I yelled
open open open even as I tried to regain
my footing only to fall back on my hands
and knees bleeding from my nose and one
ear
the breach blew the door wide open and
the rest of the assault element was
forced to shove me out of their way as
they rushed in the building through the
smoke
I don't remember pain in the moment Kane
is the last thing on your mind when
you're in the middle of an operation
I rallied quickly enough to join my team
to clear the building going room to room
on autopilot ears ringing
we caught our suspect without much
struggle and we returned to base
on the high of a successful Mission
before the sun was even up
and that right there is an excerpt
from a new book that is out right now
just came out it's called The Pledge to
America it's written by Thomas Drago
Zaron
and that
is actually a little bit of an excerpt
from my life as well
because I had the honor to be on
missions like that with Drago
in 2003 2004 in Baghdad and throughout
Iraq I also served in a platoon with
Drago at Seal Team two a strike platoon
where we served
on the USS John F Kennedy and went over
to the Persian Gulf during the
millennium
and it was an awesome time
that we had and it was awesome to get to
know Drago and he has one of the most
unique stories in the world
and I know that's a bold statement but
he when you hear it you you'll agree
with me it's one of the most unique
stories in the world
and he's sharing this complete story in
that new book that's out the pledge to
America
and
it's an honor to have Drago my brother
once again he was here podcast 276. have
him back again to talk through this book
Drago welcome back bro it's good to see
you man thank you for inviting me thank
you so much
um it's nice to be back absolutely well
even when you when you read this event
it just uh uh yeah I just
I remember those times they were they
were great times uh I miss those times
yeah uh you sent me some videos and just
seeing it was like one of the ones you
sent me was just us where kind of the
vehicles are lined up guys are getting
in and out of vehicles we're kind of
having a pow-wow about the finite or the
final details of an operation
and you know that's what we're doing
almost on a daily basis and you could
see that everyone was in that mode
everyone just knew what was going on
everyone was confident we were so
engaged in those missions all the time
and what a little uh what a little like
window into the past to see what it
looked like because now you know I'm
sitting there watching a video of it and
you're like man that really happened and
that happened over and over and over
again
um
dude the book is incredible the book is
it there's so much detail in it and
you know it's weird
but when you would tell me stories like
this
about your past we would kind of like
laugh about them and you know what I
mean like it's just basic Team guys it
was curiosity and it was kind of like
what that's weird that's that's funny
you know I was like how the hell did you
end up in prison and stuff like this but
you know we're all because we're Mission
oriented we're focused and that was just
like funny story to say maybe to just to
take us away take over the edge a little
bit between missions and stuff and the
and but you know I think and I was the
same way I didn't think much of it
people were always telling me you need
to write this in the book into writing
the book and I was like uh well maybe
yeah one day
uh but I think it is important uh to
read it I think today because our
country I think needs unit I think we
need to go back to basics
and then look at America again how great
country it is how great country we have
I want this book
to be a prism to be a lens
that you can see even closer and better
the virtues of America how special
country it is and that's just that was
my goal that after reading
this knowing about the communism and
socialism and other cruel political
system you will appreciate our country
our America more and
yeah I'm I'm kind of scared that they
start looking slowly more like a mirror
from the place of the place I escaped
from but again we need unite we our
country will not move on for the better
future if we are divided so
I hope it will help people understand
the greatness
and uniqueness of America yeah the
greatness and uniqueness and also the
threat uh it's very sobering to read
your story and hear your story and again
I I had kind of almost like a cartoon
image of what you had grown up what you
know where you'd grown up and what you'd
been through and even the last time
you're on on my podcast I was listening
to it again
and you're saying things like also I was
in prison and you're like think about
that think about that for a second oh
you know we weren't sure if we would
live or die and you know for you and me
as grown seals like okay yeah we were on
deployment we but you were a young
person and you weren't alone there was
thousands and thousands of people that
were arrested that there was people that
were murdered people that were killed
all these things happened and there's a
certain level of Detachment from it when
you when you and I as grown men are kind
of sitting around and we're talking
about something that's in your past and
I just never really like I said even
when you're on the podcast last time
it didn't weigh as heavily on me as it
did when I read it when I read it in
this book uh it's it's very sobering and
the book makes it so real
and the fact that you were able to get
out of there the fact that you were able
to get Asylum the fact that you were
able to escape the Polish People's
Republic
the Polish People's Republic
they just change the name they made a
little change to the flag and there was
rats everywhere yes yes and you never
you never knew what is waiting for you
behind the corner and this is those the
life in the that was the in typical
socialist country because I would like
to make a point here that none of these
countries behind iron Curtin none of
these uh uh not Poland not East Germany
ciao Slovakia or Bulgaria Romania not
even Soviet Union were ever communist
countries we refer to them like this and
even I even in my book say the same
thing uh sometimes refer them to their
Communists but the bottom line the fact
is that they were not communist
countries they were socialist states
there were socialist States run by
Communists like my father high-ranking
Communists and official impulse
government so I know this a little bit
from both sides from behind I had the
chance to pee behind the curtain of the
Socialist State how it works a little
bit more than than most of the polls had
the chance to see
well I want to go through some of the
book here it's it like I said it's a
heavy read you know a lot of parts of it
you're you're well we'll get into it but
I want to start at the beginning
um with with where you started and you
say this my life began in October 1960
15 years after the end of World War II
so that's closer than you and I are
right now from September 11th right yes
so yes World War II was fresh in the
memories when you grow up Poland was
still a place of desolation and despair
people were still trying to rebuild
their lives after the second world war
but this time under the terror and
totalitarian state run by Communists and
marxists like my father
yes that's where I spent the first five
years of my life or the first years of
my life amid the rusting ruins of the
old bombed out Poland and cheap
scaffolding of the new
yes and there was nothing
unusual for me I thought that it was I
thought this is the way the life is I
didn't know any better I didn't know any
different and
I remember playing in those ruined
buildings so sometimes trying to destroy
it to I thought it was fun you know we
didn't have any uh but the supervising
us we'll just cut loose and go so we we
were dirty so many times I came like
almost like like
are painted entire because we're playing
with tar our hands we walk into the
barrel and our legs up above our knees
even all entire so my mom just had a
heart attack every time she saw us
coming up from this excursions but I
thought it was fun you know we're always
we're always dirty too but my mom had to
clean us
uh you say we were with me we're my
parents Stannis law is love yeah send
his love in Florentina yes that's my
mother uh following my arrival my
brother Slavic yes and my sister Justina
yes
thankfully my pronunciation of polishes
it's good actually really good uh
together we lived in a standard
multi-family home a two-floor by the
book communist build in a town called
zilonagora yes it's good translating
it's a green hill it's a beautiful town
you know like it was I think it was
funding like 1200 year so it is uh yeah
it's it's very beautiful has a lot of
trees the only thing what was sticking
out for me was the gray buildings of so
they call it like so socio architecture
socialist architecture that's what they
call it in Poland everything is gray
everything is the same it looked like a
project uh projects uh project houses
maybe in our country but kind of much
worse because again everything is
decrepit and everything is being I mean
you can see it on YouTube with some of
the videos from the Communist times in
Poland
even I'm watching sometimes and I gospel
I was like good God I can't believe I
lived through that but yeah you know
it's I have this distance now living in
prosperity living in a beautiful country
as a free man
this is a little bit different now
perspective than it was then
yeah you didn't know any better you
didn't know any different
we lived downstairs which had two rooms
for us in a third room for an unrelated
single man
single bathroom and one rudimentary
kitchen we all shared on the first floor
upstairs there was a duplication of
downstairs floor plan with another
unrelated family occupied
which is crazy right you're just living
with randoms now it is crazy it's like
somebody moved to your house the
government came and said okay this guy
is going to leave with you right now or
this family we're gonna put into dead
room so that room is no longer yours
they're gonna live you're gonna be sure
to your bathroom and kitchen and
everything that you have up there so for
me it was like what I was born to eat
right it didn't bother me but my mother
she was crying about it say this is not
the way to leave for for people
and my father was of course communist he
was afraid to say anything he was even
afraid to send us to church that guy
still remembered my I was passed like a
football through the window because he
didn't let us go didn't know he won't
ask kids to go to church because he was
afraid he's going to lose his job the
the faith
and that their family values are totally
incompatible with their socialism that
was the the Democratic start that's what
they call it Democratic socialism in
Poland at the time so um they always
talk about democracy about so how
Democratic socialism is great and uh
like we I didn't know any better until I
started eventually growing up and
learning more about what is really going
on in a socialist coming socialist
pollen I call it communist because
everybody
says everybody calls it everywhere I
read it is being referred as a communist
state but again I can say right that
none of them were there were there's a
reason why uh they were not so
communist state that uh then I can we
can dwell a little bit more but so so
unlike in communities they run by a
typical clean communism uh in socialist
State you do have private property you
do have private business you can own but
majority the the the uh the the the the
the key infrastructure is owned by
government is is ruled by government uh
same with the police and and uh military
everything is run by the government but
you can have some small properties of
course you know how it ends up if you if
you are part of the government go along
with with them they will let you exist
and keep your little business but if you
sway a uh away a little bit or you are
not convenient for social estate they
will ruin you they will just take your
business away or they will stop you the
supplies or you won't be able to make
any
to do any business so they they control
everything right and this is what
happened to my family you know people
say well you there was Communist system
you guys didn't have a private property
well we did have a private property but
the government ultimately owned it and
then like in case of my uncle uh who
oh he despised Communists and and he was
the concrete guy right yeah the concrete
guy yeah he so he decided he seen how
totally the the the the Socialist system
operates so he decided to just compete
with them he knew that he was experts so
he started building those brakes and
selling the brakes to to uh to builders
brakes the uh the cinder blocks
and to the point they that some of the
private businesses stop doing stop
buying from government because uh
basically he was competing directly from
with the brick makers and the cedar
block makers run by the government
government stay by the social state so
the the police came in I told him to
scale down because you are competing
with with government here uh and you
need to stop he said I can't you see I
just put the get the loan I bought the
truck I bought this and the and I'm
barely making end with end but just I'm
right this is how I run my company
and uh they they say if you don't scale
down uh your business will not prosper
and he didn't so the uh
anti-fascists that's what they call
themselves in Poland but they were
socialist guns they were just
people who they try to protect the
society from Nazism and Fascism and my
uncle because he had his own business he
was labeled fastest and Nazi so they
came and destroyed his machines they
wrecked his business and then when my
father went to police complain he knew
who it was because they they usually the
the companies say the socially state
use their uh those naive young guys
young people from schools from factories
they organized them in like you know we
need to be Patriots we are patriotic
there is a fastest up there let's let's
you know take care of that and they went
they destroy his business and then when
my uncle went complained about it the
police say they arrested him they beat
him up they tortured him for a night and
sent him home and say we do it again
we'll do it again so
my uncle fixed that fix the machine and
start doing the same thing again and
things repeat that server again I think
it was like three times until he finally
didn't have any resources to rebuild it
and they did during his business but
this is this is nothing unusual what I'm
describing here it was quite common in
Poland if you didn't go along with the
social estate with the ideology with the
party line the Communist Party Line
those socialists run by Communists
mostly and uh then they run your
business they destroy you or if they
couldn't do that they kill you there
there's a lot of there are Graves across
Poland and not only Poland on all
socialist States
right now where a lot of these people
who oppose socialism in Poland uh they
were murdered and that thing didn't
happen just overnight
what happened is after second world war
when socialism was brought on by Russian
bionettes I shouldn't say Russians as
Soviet Union bionettes we need to
distinguish the Russian people and
Soviet Union and Communists but so when
it was brought to Poland
the not everybody who was not even who
was deemed possible not sympathetic
sympathizing with the socialism and
Communist party was was under
observation I mean it was like total
totalitarian system suddenly thrown on
Poland and and this is something that we
need to be careful in America we just
need to make sure that doesn't happen
here because it is very easy to to fall
into that thing so people who came back
from the West who were fighting the
Adolf Hitler and the Hitler socialist
Germany national socialist Germany they
they were arrested most of them were
arrested even the heroes even like
polish Ace with the most of the kills in
the Second World War uh on police side
uh his name is stanislav Skalski
he he returned to Poland after second
world war he was arrested he was
sentenced to death
on Espionage charge so most of those
prominent Heroes of Second World War
were sentenced to death not not every
sentence was carried out but at that
time many of them were sentenced to
death and uh on Espionage charge or
working for the west or sabotaging
something or just being not good citizen
and uh and eventually came to to the
point that if you still have food
you could be sentenced to death and
there was that sentence is carried out
for people uh let's say selling a food
on black market or manipulating uh food
in Poland
yeah so even though there was a facade
that you could have private property and
you could run your own business the
ultimately the the government had full
control and they would impose their
control and make people fall into line
absolutely there was no such thing like
you permanently own anything you may
think you do until that you are approved
Wrong by Communists and this is like my
father said you know because I had I
went for a year to live with him because
my mom couldn't afford to feed all three
of us so
so my father was very adamant about it
he said look the socialism was such a
great system for some reason people do
not like to subscribe to it so we need
to make people aware how great the
system is and when they still don't buy
into it we basically need to cancel them
out of the society we need to just
silence them and say what if that
doesn't work then we need to physically
silence them that's my father's words
and there's nothing unique at the time
that's that's how my father perceived
his role in society building that's
better more Humane socialist state that
everybody gets equal part everybody
contributes equally to it and even that
doesn't work when they realize that does
not work people don't want to vote for
them so the next thing in fraudulent
elections and next thing they came to uh
just counseling people so there's a lot
of authors
poets
painters you know the people who make
statues they were totally removed uh
actors they were canceled they were
removed from they were not allowed to
play in the theaters they were not ever
allowed to play in the movies and their
names were silence even famous people
who were were known in Poland at the
time they were silenced the by through
censorship to the point that like the
next people four or five years later
nobody knew his other name nobody
remembered who they were and they were
very again at one time prominent and
very uh famous people so this is the
what
what we need to understand is that
eventually people realize that this
whole socialism is a hoax it's just the
tool for the government to control
people and people revolved so they don't
vote they don't vote for them
so now the the Socialists they need to
do something about it because if they
give away the power
the the people will eat them alive they
will hang them from the latter posts and
we wanted to hang these companies from
the Latin pose if you could get away
with it uh for the all the the
perversion the private electron or
police Society
but uh but eventually you know there's
they they this is what I have to resolve
to the fraudible election to the terror
and the only saving grace I think for
Poland and other countries is that
Joseph Stalin and polish Communists did
not have access to computers on the
scale we have now they didn't understand
as social science so they resort to
Terror because that's what socialism
eventually has to end up to keep people
in line
they
they missed one thing
if Joseph Stalin flawed flawed Poland
with people with no loyalty to Poland
so he was he would bring people from
different republics
if you would bring people to Poland
other countries uh and Float the
countries with people with no loyal to
these countries there wouldn't be no
Poland there would be noches Slovakia
Romania there will be one big Soviet
Union
yeah
I can't even imagine
like the like your and you so so you get
into this so you your your father he's a
card-carrying communist uh with with uh
with Poland with the Polish government
um and he's working for the Polish
government your mom on the other hand
hates communism hates Marxism hates
socialism uh she uh you you say this uh
she saw the communist regime as nothing
more than occupiers by a different name
like the Nazis during World War II and
the Germans during World War One she was
a devout Catholic too which didn't sit
well with my father who believed per the
party line was necessary for Communists
to be atheists
so so you've got that going on in your
family your father doesn't want to spend
any money on you you you do say this uh
we couldn't afford to buy the state
required school uniforms and our grandma
and accomplished seamstress made them
for us instead the Richer kids were
quick to point out that our uniforms
were not purchased and were homemade
most of the kids at this time were
wearing these homemade uniforms and I
just decided to beat the rich kid who
opened his mouth first about the
uniforms they left me alone and never
heard about my uniform again that's when
I started running the violence works and
at least in Poland at the time they
wouldn't work today today Poland is
different country but at the time it
worked very well but there's some just
out here one thing when you say my
mother was totally opposing the
socialism and socially State because she
understood that she she she understood
very well she knows what happened in
Soviet Union before the second World War
but my my father's mother hate the
socialism and Communists too and I talk
about it I remember the the
she was the one who taught me how to
pray to God and we always pray to God
for no to be good to everybody to us to
help us get through these hard times and
to get the Communists out of the
country as fast as they can so that so
so it is like my father didn't know
until when he heard it he freaked out
you got in here this is this is how you
got to pray with your grandma for health
happiness and Liberation kneeling next
to me my grandmother would say things
like please send the Communists back to
where they came from and please take the
red Satan away from Poland and I would
repeat word for word after her after
repeating words a few times I had to ask
who are these people they are evil they
kill people and keep people in prison
real demons
yeah and I for me for young kid you know
learning about the hell about the demons
I thought that in this case so I had to
actually ask her ask my grandmother so
Grandma they have those hordes and tail
the Pitchfork and stuff she said well I
said not that you can see it but those
are that type of people just what you
describe they just hide but you can
recognize them by their deeds the the
atrocities they commit against other
people you see like this is like my my
mother's family was very
humanitarian Side Humane
my father's family the the part of his
parents my grandparents they were my
father was not he was totally sold out I
can see why but now we can talk about it
but but he was like totally uh sold out
to the the private and pervasion of
socialism
this I I can imagine you got this one
kind of argument they would get they
were getting fight your your father and
grandmother
and you say here he'd demand that she
never talk about communism and socialism
don't talk to my son about that that's
you uh we're building a socialist
Paradise for all of us I am not evil in
response my grandmother would become
very still she would rattle off the
names of people she knew who had been
imprisoned disappeared or murdered from
memory dozens of them years after the
fact yeah yep those names mean nothing
to me at the time as a kid I didn't
understand a lot of that stuff I was
just too young to make to understand it
but I knew there was something wrong and
that that my grandmother my father's
mother was very adamant about it and she
never
she never approved what my father was
doing until until she died so
um yeah that's that's kind of sad this
is how socialism tells the families and
friends and and then the fabric of
society very quickly which is one of
their goals
they have to because this is for them
just to stay at Power it is uh nobody
will vote for them but if you can turn
one citizen against another citizen it's
much easier you cater to one you cater
to another one and you catered actually
to both and both were hoping that yeah
you'll be with them against the other
people and the other side thinks the
same the same and this is how you end up
eventually with uh with uh with being
the broker
between these
group two groups that dislike each other
or they they work against each other so
the Socialists the Communists will place
themselves in the middle and being those
who are the brokering the peace and and
this is how they they and even that
didn't work them to get elected so they
had to resort to fraudulent elections
and then and then once they borrow
themselves in society once they
establish publish the pattern of
fraudulent elections you can get them
out basically it took Poland
five decades
to clean that these parasites out of
Poland and be free and you can see how
Poland immediately after just get rid of
that socialism how Poland flourish I
mean look at the Putin you know this guy
is we tend to call this guy an idiot a
stupid
he's not good guy but his guy is
extremely smart this guy I wouldn't call
idiot somebody who revealed broken
Empire put it back together and is
threatening entire West again so the the
uh we just need to be careful and don't
dismiss the threat from people because
we don't like them
um we might not like Putin but he's
extremely smart and well versed and he
did a lot to bring Russia back into the
picture and start threatening everybody
when you talk about growing up
um in this system in the book you say
this the state infiltrated every aspect
of Our Lives learning the Russian
language for example became mandatory
when I entered fifth grade even at that
young age I was I was precocious I
openly questioned why we had to learn
Russian when there were people who
didn't even know polish fully after all
the Russians were occupiers that didn't
go over well in my school my mother was
no longer teaching in the same school as
me and I was unable and was unable to
provide me the usual first line of
punishment so my teacher immediately
pulled me out of class and marched me
straight to the principal's office once
I was standing in front of him he called
the police yeah on their way to school
the police grabbed my mom out of her
school across town and sat us all down
for a talk in addition to the uniformed
police officers a member of the State
security police in plainclothes joined
the police during the questioning of my
mother if this happens again if we hear
anti-communist and anti-polish
sentiments expressed again they said
he's going to orphanage and you'll be
facing prison time for failing to teach
your children the right way to think
that's correct that's what happened when
uh and it was not even political from my
side at the time I was just a kid and
you're not a kid going I don't want to
freaking learn this other language yeah
you know I have enough problems with
Polish language so what the hell do I do
land with something else and I will
never use in and my mother also tells me
that it's just a language which uh is
used by our the occupies of occupiers of
Poland so it was not that political at
the time I was just being kid and so
yeah it I don't want to learn that
but this is how it end up but also if
you think about a little bit more
this is the the rules and regulation
that allows that were important in
effect allow the state uh the state to
take the kids away for such reasons that
you would never think my mother would
not never think that there are such
regulations that would allow us to be
placed in state government state
orphanage because we don't like because
we are being told not to like Socialism
or just told uh you know that we do not
like socialism and the speed at which
the government gets involved in that
process from classroom to principle to
State Police and uniformed officers
talking to you and your mother you know
same day there was like 40 minutes and
an hour so uh that the teacher took me
out the teacher was she had a Russian
name I think she was a one of those
polish Russians and um and yeah so
that's true to me to depends people's
office they sat me down there they
called police and I didn't know that the
time that's the world police is coming
they're gonna arrest me now they came
with my mother because they arrested my
mother entertained her pull her out of
the breaking the school in the office
and they threaten us I remember my mind
was shaking and uh I was scared too
because I've seen my mom being so scared
yeah and and
that's how they that's how they slowly
get control and break people because
what is your mother she's like okay
listen do I want to lose my son and go
to jail or am I just gonna tell him hey
be quiet and comply so
a lot of people are like hey I don't I
don't have time for this kind of trouble
I don't want this kind of trouble I
don't want to lose my kid I don't want
to go to jail yeah there's a lot of
people like this like we don't need that
just go go and say this go along with it
go along with it but that creates two
different problems then once it teaches
kids to be this genuine it teaches kids
to lie and cover it up and it also
teaches them that you don't stand up for
your rights for what is right you just
do what is safe and how you remember you
know many times going to school and my
mother always to me and my siblings say
do not talk politics at school do not
say do not get provoked don't don't say
anything that could be taken the wrong
way because we may lose our family they
might separate us and the state it was
it did happen I mean that I got away but
there's some people who did
and some people because of something
like this they lose skates and they if
they didn't straight themselves up they
eventually some of them disappeared and
like the kids stay in orphanage forever
until they grew up never seen parents
again so this is the Socialist state is
the control the amount of control that
government has
is so pervasive that even maybe like my
father maybe he was he was an evil man
he just totally believed in the
Socialist system and to implement if at
any price but even so so
so this is just so pervasive it it the V
it creates
people basically allow them to justify
almost any action anything again to
protect their ideology and you know
we've seen this also in Adolf Hitler's
socialist Germany national socialist
Germany where uh you know if you were
just speaking up or you were
inconvenient for the so the the Hitler's
national uh
the Socialist German Workers Party uh if
you are not convenient for them you
couldn't dive in concentration camp and
that eventually uh whether there was
other Hitler socialist National
Socialist Germany or Poland's police
socialists they both end up uh social
respondent they they both end up having
concentration camps and the
concentration comes actually that's not
the German invention by the way about
that this is a it's another socialist
State Invasion a Soviet Union as a
Soviet Union as the union of socialist
republic right not communist republic
the Helicon is party they come in Sparta
run that show just like in Poland but
also for the facade they had many other
political parties in Poland too maybe
two three or four other partners I don't
remember their name because they mean so
nothing they're like nobody even cared
about them but they always say Hey you
know this Coalition we work together to
build a better socialism to build better
uh Poland and you know on the graves of
opponents of socialism
you also see
like for instance in America right now
the the educational system there's
parents that are they're saying hey
teach my kid
how to do Reading Writing and arithmetic
teach them that's what that's what
that's what you should do is teach my
kid and they're teaching them all the
whole slew of other things oh God yeah
that parents that parents say hey
actually I don't I don't really want you
to teach my my kid that when they're in
third grade when they're in second grade
when they're in fourth grade and what
I've heard some of the Educators saying
is Well you don't get you know you don't
get to tell us how we're gonna what
we're going to teach your kids that's
exactly my mother was told that's what
I'm saying it's socialist State like you
you you hey no uh Mrs Iran you can't
tell us what we're going to teach Thomas
Thomas is our kid now so in Poland if
you do that if you still insist they
will Branch you terrorists you you were
actually literally branded terrorists
and so the kids cannot grow up in the
terrorist family
and they didn't tell you that you
because you're opposed social because
you are about socialists we take your
case we say you are you you you pretty
much your views are aligned with the
terrorist totalitarian something and
your kids do not belong to you which we
cannot allow your kids to grow up uh
this way so we as a government the
socialist government will step in it
will provide the education that we need
it's what's best it's what's the best
for the Socialist State what they think
is best right what they think is best
for the best but you know the first
thing that what people to remember in
those socialist States attacks on
families or families values there was
like you don't need a wife and a husband
why would you do that uh all it is we
need to what needs to happen is kids
need to be learning how to be good
citizens
and of course by that they meant
socialist citizens of socialist State
and the kids what they mean is obedient
slaves obedient slaves yes and those
kids from those family that oppose
they never had the chance to go to
college
there was just their end of Education
was uh at the at the high school level
the most
and because to get in college at the
time to Poland it was free but only for
the politically aligned kids so
um and also if you did during the
college if you deviate any
uh you could be removed very quickly if
you divide any from the social Isla
party line so uh they have a special
point for uh being a member of socialist
youth of socialists communist death
there were points for parents being in
the party there were points for having a
a family aligned with the social the
Communist Party in Social estate
socialist Poland so these are the
warning sides this is something that we
were you know I'm I'm seeing some of
these uh something many things that you
just mentioned and it really worries me
we need to be very Vigilant because it
is very easy to fall into the
totalitarian
government that eventually will tell you
what you can what you cannot do with
with yourself with the kids then you
will be eventually forced to do things
take medications don't take medications
or you will not allow be allowed to take
medications though because suppose the
URL is not enough just like happening
with them by describing the book friend
of mine when his mom died basically they
they they they decide not to provide her
with medicine not to treat her because
she was older they need there was very
scarce medicine and they needed for
younger people supposedly I believe more
for black party line people
so that's that's how evil system is is
this not easy it's not very difficult to
implement all it is all is needed just
uh people in different people who are
not who are afraid to stand up for what
is right who are terrorized easily by
the state and um I think there's a good
example for us could be some of these
people I describe in Poland at the end
of my book how they were schooling uh
socialism communist judges
and how they uh uh uh how they stood up
to uh to the totalitarian government and
again what what is happening here kind
of a little bit worries me but we need
to be very careful because the first
thing that that socialist state will
want
is violence violence either way they
need violence well there's many things
they need a villain but every socialist
they will have villain Poland had a
villain a Soviet Union had a villain
German so everybody like in the Soviet
Union there was there were collags first
they have wealthy pageants then there
was doctors Stalin died in during the
poor death Purge and and so didn't
follow through quite well but in Poland
there were Jews then they were educated
people so they were intelligencia what
they called so intelligence is bad we
need to promote people from these
peasants from workers if you were if you
are coming from intelligence
intelligencia family
you'll use versus yours scrutinize very
well in Germany there was of course
Jewish Nation but this is all
by the so-called uh like my mother
called relative morality
so your morality is not based in faith
in something solid
your morality is based in ideology that
can change in politicians view that we
know changes and this is very dangerous
because look what happened in uh Adolf
Hitler's socialist Germany
when he was able to pervert that most
Civilized Nation in Europe at the time
into euthanasia of sick people on
handicapped people into concentration
cup into gazing people eventually they
turn them onto the the Jewish people
they're Exterminating entire nation
trying to do it so that relative
morality is very dangerous if we need to
also make sure that we that we
understand it here not to fall into the
relative morality model and another
thing too like in Poland they were
always saying you need to be tolerant
you need to be tolerant oh this is
intolerant you can't do that this is
intolerant but I say to it
like my mother always say
uneducated tolerance
is as dangerous as intolerance you need
to educate yourself what you're about to
tolerate before you start actually
promoting it in and and
they're tolerating and you know like we
would never tolerate mortars right but
if you subscribe to this relative
Morality In other figures they
deteriorate euthanasia right so you need
to be careful
um
fast forward a little bit in the book
your your father takes a job in 1967
you're seven years old
and he
he basically um abandoned you guys took
off yeah
um
you know it could be a number of things
that he was having a little success in
the Communist Party your mom is still
being Catholic being religious so he
felt like there's some some things going
on that was wasn't going to help his
career
uh you say we moved we moved to a little
apartment across town almost six miles
from where we'd been living before at
that age in that place uh that was a
huge distance especially because he had
to walk or take the bus everywhere
our beds were narrow and mattresses were
thin much like the walls to be able to
sleep on cold nights we shoved our beds
together and slept head to feet and side
by side to say polish Winters are very
cold to be putting it mildly it was bad
enough that we had to stuff our coats
with old newspapers to keep warm the
fact that we couldn't afford to replace
them with coats that could actually keep
us warm was worse
it turned out that my father was
refusing to pay child support so while
we were trying to hide our crinkling
coats from other kids he was buying a
new life for himself the court
eventually forced him to start paying
which he did he was always late
yes uh I was talking about those bets
actually we didn't have it too bad so we
had just one bed and like it was like
single by it but you know we were small
me and my brother so me and my brother
slept in one bed the toast to you know
head to toe and and my sister slept with
my mom but yeah we didn't have two beds
I kind of like I think Miss Miss
squatting that that uh the two that was
just one bed that me and my brothers
left with eventually you know like my
mom was able to procure another bed so
you know we lived in a two-room uh
apartment at the time so it was
here to room you you mean two bedrooms
that was not like that in Poland Poland
it was just two rooms with two rooms so
so me and my brother were sleeping in
one room and my mom with my sister was
sleeping in another room there were
little tiny rooms but you know there was
such a big uh for us it was like we have
our own apartment because there were a
lot of people that did not I have even
dead there were people living with
parents and grandparents in one in the
studio bigger studio just so you and it
didn't have a bathroom you have to go
outside to the common bathroom so this
is you know there was the Desolation
after the second world war and also the
socialism economy that ruined Poland
even deeper and and put people into
slavery
you say on top of the on top of all this
we're often hungry that loaf of bread my
mother got if she was early and lucky
enough you couldn't buy more than one
loaf at a time people could get violent
if you tried this meant we were forced
to learn ways to be less hungry my
brother my brother learned how to make
french fries from potatoes I learned how
to taste it was really good yeah I
learned to spot the school children of
wealthy Communist party members by their
sandwiches yep these were some good
looking sandwiches too while my siblings
were eating thin sandwiches with butter
or margarine if there was no butter only
often only sprinkled with sugar these
rich kids were eating theirs with fresh
meat and all the best fixes dressing
smeared across their smug faces there
were two ways to get your hands on
things in those circumstances money and
violence since we were poor I used
violence well this is where I learned
that violence works if it did if
violence didn't work for you it meant
you didn't apply enough of it I'll be
the first to admit I was a bit of a
bully as a kid
yeah yeah you know this is something
that you just have to help yourself as
much as you can and at that time I was I
envy these younger these kids for
behaving this like a nice tasty
sandwiches you know like when I look at
it I salivate and uh so I figured out
that I was just I would just like to try
at least sandwich like that you know we
never had one so I just woke up I just
grab the sandwich from the guy I bite it
I bet it
and I was hooked I was like okay so this
is what's going to happen next you
tomorrow you will bring two sandwiches
and if you don't you want it because I'm
going to eat your sandwich so one
sandwich is for me one is for you for
parents you can just tell them that you
are growing up because our parents
Department everybody I think every kid
knew hey you are growing up so you need
to eat more you know you treat more like
maybe because our food was very Bland we
didn't have like very tasty food so I
didn't want to eat I didn't eat a lot so
my mama always had to like you need to
eat because you're growing up so I
advise this kid hey you know just tell
them that you're growing you need more
eat and from what I find out these
parents were very happy say yeah our kid
is eating well you know he's having two
sandwiches now everybody didn't know
that he was eating just one I was and I
will share with me so yeah it was
harmful it's funny that the uh or it's
not funny but you know you hear people
that lean towards socialism oh so they
they're they're so anti-rich you know
they they think all the rich people have
all the money and here you are talking
about it was the Communist kids the kids
that were had the Communist Party
connections that parents those are the
rich kids because they just took
everything from everybody else that's
what happens this is how it works I mean
remember the socialist economy is very
inefficient it just does not work and
and
so people are people whether you are
communist no matter how uh how
well-meaning companies you are you're
gonna help yourself you know you can't
help these so you're gonna help yourself
here and you're gonna go bring the uh
so people can eat but at least you can
eat and this is how people start
starving and uh that it just does not
work
um fast forward a little bit again I'm
fast forwarding through the book there's
so many good stories and insightful you
want to know what it was like get the
book so you have something to so you can
understand what what communism does to
to a people into a country
uh fast forward a little bit you say by
the time I was entering eighth grade my
mom couldn't afford to support me by
then almost 13 years old plus two other
children so she did the only thing she
could do and sent me to live with my
father
yeah oh
yeah she didn't have my choice I mean
there was a wheel growing the food was
expensive and uh we have we're living
this little tiny apartment with uh two
rooms so we'll just basically one
bedroom apartment
um so she had to do something and uh she
just she sent me to leave with the
father and that's kind of funny story
because
um he showed up hippie Mac he didn't
like it
already but he didn't even stole his
wife at the The Cure the wife that he
had
uh that he's coming with me so basically
I show up on the doorstep he's just a
little while he's going to leave with us
and Ironman has created what
no way I was like I just wanted to punch
that night
and that's that's crazy to hear when
you're only 13 years old yeah yeah yeah
we don't want you but there I just
remember that my mom
she knows that we need it that needs to
happen so a kind of like swallow my
pride just look at hair and just say
nothing and work past her was your was
your dad's living Arrangement better did
they have like a nicer apartment and
stuff yeah because they have actually
three rooms so here there was one room
the bigger room and two smaller bedrooms
so uh so when I walk into that family
his family uh she had a son already from
previous marriage and so they kind of
let me have one of the rooms and they
both stay in the big room because there
was in Poland there was not the division
between bedrooms there was no bedrooms
there were rooms so we had one room you
have one room and we my father and his
wife had a another room and I thought
this like great that would be awesome
the only thing that you know what would
happen there was not quite awesome
now this is where you start this is
where you started learning to fight for
the first time yeah I I already went
there I started fighting right before I
went to my father so I joined the police
uh Boxing Club that was my boxing was my
first thing and I was really good at it
actually that I was so good and also
what kind of motivated me is because
like I didn't have a father so the the
the the coach at one time when I as I
describe one of the kids who beat up my
younger brother and I broke my hand but
he came to visit me and uh and it kind
of like sit down you know talk to my
mother talk to me and I was like holy
I can I must not disappoint this
man I must just do the best I can so
I'll start beating people start beating
people up with the gloves up there
because I want to do a pink scheme you
know and he really said like you that
how good I was so when I went to Warsaw
I was already pretty good you know I had
a good parents I not quite a few people
out like that guy who beat my brother up
and that's actually a funny story you
know because I was always
um I was not very strong at the
beginning I was just bullied because I
thought then that my mother is a teacher
so who is going to challenge me so I I
never had never hesitate to punch
somebody or beat somebody up and of
course didn't work that way always but
but just from the very beginning I
remember like
when I was being bullied when I was kid
so there's not like I could come to my
mom say Mom can you beat him up or
something and I was like I didn't have
an older brother so I had to figure
something out so I found like a big
steel pipe I put in my book case when I
was going to school from school because
kids used to follow me and just kick my
ass sometimes like in the put on the
blog or she pushed me in the into the
the the entrance of the apartment and
beat me up up there so later the world
starts spreading that those kids who
follow me in my apartment somehow don't
show up the ambulance shows up takes
them out because it was me with my pipe
had it worked you know it was like again
violence works you just need to apply
enough of it so so so that that's where
I started it so I was already Fighting
by this time and then so from the pipe I
move on to boxing gloves and that and
then there's become kind of like well
known because I'm with quite a few guys
and I didn't have to wear the pipe I
don't know did I tell you what some of
these pipes guys who I piped it's like
I I really don't know because they
didn't they didn't move when I left and
this is where they were spread out no
way when they follow me in the in the
into the apartment they don't come out
so kind of they left me alone they got
hyped I know how to say it right away
but you know what I mean
they got piped uh so when you're when
you're in around Warsaw you start you
know you're kind of just like doing some
sort of uh almost like extortion hanging
out with guys getting money making
things happen well because I had no fear
of of kids especially after the boxing
thing I was just like looking for the
challenge and I remember um I think I
started off wrong food because I was
always trying to be like my mom told me
well I beat up the girl in the first
grade and I kick her so strong
and we're just starting first grade and
they just like telling the whole Dragon
this girl is your girlfriend and uh I
was like I don't need no stinking
girlfriend I woke up and I kick her she
just fall they carry her to the uh
emergency to the school to the nurses
room and I was just proud I was like
yeah yeah you know this is like how old
are you like six seven six six going
seven so they told you you had a
girlfriend and you wouldn't yeah
I have no girlfriends I don't need that
and that was happened at my mom worked
at the same school at the same time this
web UI was like a I was a bully I was
like my don't stink but uh so I'm
sitting in the center of my mama house
in the class got quiet
I'm just like looking it's like that
doesn't doesn't seem good it sure
happens to me she looks around the class
she looks at me see who did you hurt
and I just like thinking what to say by
the entire class like that guy him that
I mean that girl right there that girl
so my mother looked at the at this girl
and she's still crying there so she was
all bruised between her legs apparently
she pulled me out by my ear there's a
very common important teachers used to
do it just probably by the ear and pull
you out of the bench she pulled me by my
ear she stand me in front of the class
she pulled my pants down and just
started spanking me and starts packing
me so hard and so long until I broke
down and started crying and say don't
ever you know you want to fight fight
the guys fight people like you don't
ever touch a girl
and uh so that was it I mean the
embarrassment you know my pants down my
butt red from the and the sound you know
being spun in front of the whole class
uh and and there was not enough too
because when I came home that thing
repeat itself but I never touched the
girl after that that was like there was
ingrained in my in my head do not you
cannot do that and that was just that
there
uh
yeah that was that was so embarrassing
and uh yes
I think I learned the lesson forever
from that but anyway so I went to Warsaw
too and so I was like trying to be very
nice guy and so there was some of one of
the guys I didn't know that then
Dynamics were the gangs working as it
works over the time so one of them was
just harassing one of the girls so I
wanted to knock him out turned out to be
he was one of the those those those guys
those guy little gangs so they they came
to me and said look you're gonna this is
what's gonna happen we're gonna buy us
the wine we're gonna store the wine from
these guys but uh and then it will beat
you up everybody from this guy is going
to hit you and then you know would you
be along I say I'm fine with the wine
but if you're gonna hit me I'll hit you
back I'll knock you out and uh so they
kind of led me along by the ventralized
like they were doing the same thing I
did I mean that mentality was the same
so I said like okay so um I bring you
the wine and uh but you know if if you
try to hit me I'll beat you up and
really bad so they they didn't just
drink the wine and say hey let's go
extort this time not the sandwiches
let's get stir the wine from this and
these guys so we'll just start getting
guys and say you bring the wine no well
they will punch the guy a few times then
he brings the wine we punch him again
and then just leave him alone but that
what they told these guys these poor
victims that you know you can be abused
and like if you wanted more wine we just
call the same guy who just beat up who
brought us the wine say more wine and so
he was bringing the wine to us and I was
relaxed what 14 15 years old so we
already drinking is I was smoking and um
I was bad I mean kind of uh not good
person outside that's what I mean I was
not good person
all the time
yeah that's uh you're you're definitely
heading down the wrong path again this
is you you go into these kind of details
in the book
um really
it's it's it's fascinating to read
um I'm gonna fast forward a little bit
here just to touch base again on the on
on what you're dealing with with the
Communist situation is say when the
government executed citizens they were
called Bandits and insurrectionists and
enemies of the state people who are
trying to upend the successful socialist
system societal values had changed and
the thinking became that these people
should be isolated from society in some
cases executed for opposing socialism
and the official Communist party line
show trials were publicly prosecuted a
lot of charges against said
insurrectionists were completely made up
evidence was made up and there was no
opportunity to challenge the charges
people were harassed by State security
police and publicly humiliated they were
isolated from friends and business the
Communist Regime was relentless in
pursuit of dissidents they did not need
to have any evidence they would
manufacture evidence they were there
were countless victims to this day no
one knows how many polls continue to
find secret Graves oh sorry to this day
no one knows how many and polls continue
to find secret Graves of opponents of
socialism and communism in prison
Courtyards forests and other obscure
places to this day polls are searching
for the graves of their World War II
Heroes who disappeared or were outright
murdered by the Communists upon their
return from the war
yes that's something that I mentioned at
the beginning here when we start talking
about it this is how socialist State
persecuted the opponents or the people
who they perceived could be opponents it
could be something that you just you
just came back from the west and you
witnessed too much you witnessed how
prosperous the West is that was enough
to put you on the list and then if you
are still
speaking out and talking about it you
could disappear
I think one of the last Graves that they
that was discovered in Poland was what
might be like I think a year ago I
believe when they found and that's not
all they're still looking for it there's
still so many citizens missing from
socialist times and they never thought
they would be ever found at the time
because there was no there were no
computers there were not the science was
not there to help find these people they
are finding them now and they are still
looking for many of them but this is the
socialism you say earlier too about this
fake charges and the spies yes they were
all were branded none of these people
were sitting there because for political
reasons according to Social estate there
will be disgrace for social estate to
keep political prisoners so they were
all criminals they were I was criminal I
was never like political prisoner in
that political prisoners you broke the
law and what was the law well you can't
bring paint
you can have a free speech basically
they wouldn't safely speak yeah they
would say you violated the the tax code
or you violated the printing law that we
had for the government uh distribution
right whatever so there was always some
low low to to to put you in prison or or
enslave you and this is something that
uh it stays with me today when I see
sometimes uh well I don't want to go
there but this is something that we need
to be very careful because it's very
easy to Brand people's spies brand
people uh uh criminals and then
prosecute them and they will not even
have a support in society if you are if
you are able to Brand them as criminals
just that they were that their crime was
exercising Free Speech where there was
no free speech in Poland at the time but
trying to speak your mind
people didn't know about it that was not
being told why the person was executed
or why the person was in prison they
were thought they were spies they were
told that they violate the law they
violate this violate that and they are
not political prisoners there's there's
they were very adamant the Socialist
regime was very adamant that there are
no political prisoners in Social estate
they all are criminals I was Criminal
foreign
fast forward a little bit after my
father kicked me out and back to my mom
I thought I would be done with the
upheavals for a while upheavals being
getting transferred back and forth the
back and forth had began upsetting and
had been upsetting and stressful and I
was excited to go back with my friends
and classmates in 1975 but I was also
drinking and smoking and I decided to
take up Karate after getting a taste of
boxing in Warsaw I was in a lot of
trouble for with my mom to say the least
um so then you so then you start
training in karate as well there was
something I was so fascinated about that
was the first ever geronagura in this is
created so I said I need to join it I
just was too young for it so I was
really good with my pencil and pan so I
just fake my ID I just take my idea I
changed my date of birth and I signed up
in uh
and kirsukin is Savage karate it's it's
brutal you kind of yeah you have kind of
like I tell you that at least at the
beginning every time I was going to uh
to to training session I was I was a bit
nervous I was I was like on my toes
because I know I will be hurt and you
know that's just like
uh we were hurt you know but even just
the methods that they train us you know
you have to stand up you know take that
you take the sunshine Dashi position and
they kick you in the stomach so hard
that you just fly like some some of us
make it like I was very light guy so
actually I ended up usually making
somersault and falling on my face and my
knees because from the cakes or you know
lay on the floor and the instructors
they run on your stomachs and stuff but
after a while I got used to it you know
it's like I'm tough you know I'm not
going to give up on this and we're
learning and we're actually becoming
very effective I was supplementing my
boxing skills with the now with the
kicks and some sweeps so I was like
uh
unbeatable on the street and I liked it
you uh you're you from everything when I
would watch you fight you have a very
and it might have seemed natural it
might have when I watched you it like
seem natural because you've been doing
it for a long time but you
you clearly have a natural gift for
fighting like when I would watch you
throw punches when I watch you throw
kicks when I'd see you hit people or
kick people I'd be like oh you look like
a really good fighter and you are a
really good fighter but just the the
fact that you were doing this at a time
when really a lot of people weren't
doing this and going out and I know you
you spent a lot of time in the streets
fighting and I have no doubt that you
were unbeatable in the streets at that
time yeah there was no child especially
with these techniques that people didn't
know at the time because it was more
popular in Poland yeah yeah it was
Savage were you how big were you back
then I was fight when I was fighting in
the for the championship of Poland uh
that was in Taekwondo I was fighting 169
pounds I was light but you know I was
beating big people because like you know
small guys they usually don't pick the
fight usually the big ones that was the
one that said I'm going to kick your ass
and especially you small so the the most
of the people that I fought at the time
they were bigger but they were also
easier to you know they were easy to
topple like they were like wobbly more
wobbly and uh I was able to just kick
their ass I was I was beat up too I mean
I was not always I won't ever fight but
eventually we end up like a challenge
how many fights you can go without
losing one and I think I went to like uh
I think like almost close to 100 and uh
but it was like a street fight so so the
others also too that we are picking up
these fights we're not like at that time
we're not the the part that we like
became that kind of competition there
was the we were just picking up the
fight it was not like people were
looking trying to fight us but they
would use that as a training we pick up
these fights not for there was no
cameras at the time so we used like a we
we go and uh four or five of us from the
club that was what I was doing Taekwondo
when I came to a different city switched
from Karate Cushing to taekwondo so
we're going groups and so we're like
okay so we knew where to find people to
beat up like you know just drinking beer
somewhere or you know places where I'm
rough and rough places in Poland were
like ravaraf here even xrf so we go up
there and we just pick the guy and then
you know we beat the guy up and then we
get together have a drink and talk about
it because we didn't have a cameras like
today you can video it and you can say
Okay critique so we critique each other
so we're gonna debrief yeah debrief yes
and so like your cake was kind of good
but you escape the guy on the shoulder
you didn't hit him in the head you
actually kick him uh like there was no
effective so this is the briefing then
and then we're going to reenacting it
too so uh so creating how we were the
fights and we became really good at it
so we came so good to the point that
eventually we stopped beating single
people up we're looking for more at one
time so uh it was like
I remember
and the the new spreading on City too
there's people like well this is like be
careful about these guys if they walk
around just walk away and it happened
that people could recognize nice ass
because we beat a lot of people but
there were some people who didn't
especially if they were two or three of
them so we just woke up to the guy who
just grabbed the beer of his hand
spitting and giving back to him you know
it's going to be fine right especially
if you had two three people around so he
was there but even that you know like
eventually we run out of these people
too so if we found somebody like this we
sometimes that the rule was whose pads
the group who wants to beat beat up then
he's the first one to do it but like
when we start running out of paper we
had to draw that draw the uh Lots straws
yeah who is going to be beat these
people up and this is how we train and
we find that it was very effective which
which a lot of the techniques the later
I I I kind of Master and to help us to
also fight in the in the in the dojo in
the dream because
seems like it was less stressed up there
it was like everything by the rule you
know there's not like you're gonna fight
somebody gonna stab you but on the
street you have to be careful about it
so yeah in in the book you go into some
details you you guys were training like
two three hours a day yes working out
yeah you're doing everything right to to
be ready to scrap in the streets uh
meanwhile you say this As I Grew Older
my understanding of what it meant to
live in communist state grew with me I
started listening to Voice of America
the BBC and radio for Europe years
before without anyone knowing I began
tuning in shortly after my running with
the State security police after I'd
question my teacher about being forced
to learn Russian I had been told about
these radio channels by my mother's
brother and this is where you tell the
story about your uncle yes my uncle Adam
and he's the one that you know showed
you how to listen to these banned radio
stations so this is where you start
seeing sort of the outside perspective
of what's going on in the rest of the
world and what's actually happening to
you all in Poland yes well and again I
didn't have a father at the time so I
was looking up to my uncle and he was a
big guy he was he liked to beat people
up too so raxaula is always analyzing
him and uh and he was like you wouldn't
want to mess with him but he told me
about this because you know we knew the
story he beat up by the police being
kidnapped from the street by the police
so I he taught me how to listen to this
because he says what you hear is is full
of propaganda it is indoctrination it is
censored you don't hear the true you
don't hear everything you need to listen
to outside and thanks God for voice of
America you know that's like you could
go to prison at that time to for
listening to it BBC uh Radio free Europe
and you know what it's actually fun I
just need to the the digress digress a
little bit on that
when I came to America eventually when I
moved to uh to where I live now uh where
I live
there is a
Radio free free Europe radio station
there it doesn't it's not active anymore
but this is where those Transmissions I
was listening to uh it was from and I
was able to actually visit that radio
station it's almost like a museum where
where was the radio station located uh
in Mason Ohio oh really and so I was
able to tour it because you can and see
it so for people they were mostly like a
technical curiosity for me it was much
more
yeah that's amazing uh and this is where
you started getting information and
there's just so much there's you know we
kind of take it for granted
you know the fact that we can get
information then again you got to pay
attention the information that you're
getting because a lot of the information
that you're getting is screened and is
being censored so that stuff is
happening people are getting banned
people get Shadow banned people get
suppressed like all that stuff is going
on right now
and you got to pay attention to it you
you do talk about this uh I wanted to
bring up this one section that you you
talk about in the book you say one of
the greatest examples of socialist
censorship and suppression of
information is found with the story of
Captain Vito am I saying that right yes
in 1940 Captain poletsky one of the
Polish Army resistance leaders
volunteered to allow himself to be
captured by the Gestapo in order to
infiltrate Auschwitz
concentration camp yes
so I'm going to say that again everybody
this guy he's a he's a Polish resistance
leader and he volunteers to be captured
so he can go into voluntarily into the
Auschwitz concentration camp yes it was
there that Captain poletsky
organized the resistance movement which
included hundreds of inmates he created
the report that was smuggled out
detailing the horrors and atrocities
occurring at the camp this report made
it into the Allies hands but it fell on
deaf ears captain boletski
escaped Auschwitz and later fought the
Warsaw Uprising in 1944 he was a great
polish Patriot and a great inconvenience
to the Socialist regime in Poland
in 1947 he was arrested by the communist
state Security Police and charged with
anti-polish activities he was then
subjected to torture and a show trial
Captain poletsky was officially executed
by the sole polish socialist government
in 1948 and was buried in an unmarked
grave somewhere in Poland they still can
find where they are still the poles are
still looking for him he is a national
national hero in Poland and that's he
was
in resistance the the Poland during
Second World War has the largest the the
the big the largest uh uh
partisan Army in entire Europe so he was
part of it and the task was now because
they were already reports coming that
something is going on in these
concentration camps and we need to that
that
it is happen but they need somebody to
witness to write reports and send these
reports smuggle these reports back so
for him chance to escape the Auschwitz
uh were very slim but he so basically he
volunteered for the one-way Mission and
he did he accomplished he sent he sent
the reports he described what is going
on there and of course he tried to
escape he was successful he did Escape
but there was very inconvenience uh for
the Socialist State because he was
fighting on the wrong side he was
fighting on fighting on the Allies side
he was not part of the Soviet Union Army
he was not part of the Soviet Union uh
the Polish military sponsored by Soviet
Union so hero like this especially with
his courage speaking out against the the
the the the the the the socialism was
very inconvenient so he was promptly
arrested and the as many of these Heroes
at the time he was promptly arrested
sentenced to death in the show trial and
executed
and he was fully when Poland became free
he was fully rehabilitated it was
exonerated and actually there today
there are streets places and schools
named after him in Poland
yeah that just shows you how how
horrible and evil this is it is evil you
know just let me just throw something
here too because Ira even I remember
there were a lot of uh monuments
they were totally destroyed because they
were not supporting socialist narrative
uh monuments of freedom from monuments
from previous Poland where Poland was
not socialist that was destroyed the
history was so twerp and so Twisted that
I didn't even know about some of these
heroes or about the police squadrons
police
Fighter squadrons fighting in Battle of
Britain you know there was also they was
suppressed here and there a little bit
show up but it was mostly very very
heavily censored but you know like the
the during Battle of Britain the most
effective Fighter Squadron was polish
303 there were movies made about it now
but at that time being a member of that
Squadron could be could mean that
sentence in Poland
um
I'm going to fast forward a bit by early
1981 after the communist government
raised food and fuel prices and lowered
working wages solidarity had a
membership of about 10 million people
and represented most of the Polish
Workforce this is when my mom became
involved with the Trade union and the
first time in any Warsaw packed country
that an organ organization was formed
independently from the regime with real
elections and everything
through the union strikes began bringing
entire Industries to a halt state-run
companies were losing money and they
were deeply in debt to the West's to
boot desperate the authorities tried to
strike a deal with the unions the
agreement at the end of the day was to
allow the trade unions to exist in
exchange for fewer strikes this was just
a ruse in preparation for martial law to
take down the First Independent Trade
union of the Warsaw Pact at that point I
was more firmly entrenched with the
anti-communist solidarity movement and
at regulars regularly stay late at the
headquarters at loates am I saying that
right Lots yes but a lot yeah that's how
you pronounce it uh not now that I was
in my early 20s I had a lot more
flexibility to do what I wanted within
constraints imposed by the regime of
course
and this is a historic day uh on
December 13 1981 around 10 in the
evening people started coming to tell us
of their parents and other family
members who were being arrested
throughout the city the State security
police had come to their homes and their
family members were gone we knew that
something big was about to happen we
braced ourselves for whatever was going
to happen next people started calling
their friends in other countries outside
of Poland trying to organize routes of
escape and chains of communication in
case things went badly for us
someone at the HQ turned the TV on
mentioning something about a government
message being broadcast
General how do you say his name
[Music]
yeah who is more Soviet than polish
appeared on the screen
and he was sort of like at this time was
sort of the the military leader of Paul
yes
he looked Grim in full uniform with the
Polish flag looming over his shoulder
the National Council in accordance with
the provisions of the Constitution has
introduced martial law throughout the
country he read this is the last chance
to pull the country out of Crisis and
save it from disintegration
yep there's always excuse for something
so that the Mantra was that that is
about Uprising to happen people are
about to over ready to overthrow the
Socialist legitimate government was
never legitimate government it was never
they were having there were all the
elections were fraudulent but so that
there was the Mantra and to save Poland
from the Mayhem and upheaval and
possible Soviet invasion the general
yarozowski had to do that this dispute
and my opinion is absolutely baloney
that's a that was just another
attempt one of the last attempts to so
to to to save socialism in Poland
besides they understood not only in
Poland but in other Warsaw pad countries
that if socialism files in Poland it
will fall everywhere else
and it did including Soviet Union later
in 1990s but that was the the how they
impose martial law there was one just
one night they arrested they were
running start running up at midnight
they started running up people like on
the mass scales in every city every town
in Poland was well organized and it uh
I I remember that's a whole the
communications were cut in Poland the
telephone lines at midnight went blank
the TV went out there was no radio
stations nothing they were just blank
nothing a lot of people died too people
were in emergency having heart attack
there's no way to call all the
telephones were shut down because they
were trying to save Poland from the uh
Insurgent for the insurgents and polish
uh people who are opposing uh who are
trying to ruin Poland This Is How They
exactly what they viewed it as uh you
say it's believed that over 25 000
patriotic polish citizens were arrested
one night December 13 1981. yes and yes
that's the the thing is that at the time
the Socialist State uh was very adamant
about it these people are not arrested
they are in turn we don't keep them in
prison we keep them in terminal camps
where they are safe and we do it for
their safety we do it for safety of
Poland for safety of poles no they
didn't they did commit any crime this is
why they are not prisoners they are
internees but they were potentially
dangerous to the state they could
be dangerous to the state so we just hit
it up and and kind of intern them send
them to a vacation homes sanatoriums
that's how they explain but in reality
they were just arrested thrown in jails
in prisons around the Poland
fast forward a little bit when the
president of the United States Ronald
Reagan announced sanctions against the
Communist Regime on December 29 1981
polls including myself were cheering
even further infuriating the Communists
and socialists this is when the phrase
was coined uh I'm not even sure how do
you say it the worst the better the
worse the better that's how do you say
in Polish yeah that's something
yeah that was the better worse the
better it meant that the more sanctions
put in place to ruin socialism and
communism the better for Poland polls
and freedom anything that even remotely
hurt Communists was cheered by the polls
the Polish people were ready for any
sacrifice just to get rid of the hated
oppressive socialism that my father
worked so hard to put in place
those of us who escaped or who were left
out of the mass arrests met on the
streets in the days following and
discussed what we could do to resist the
blatant show of Terror and
authoritarianism the country face the
country was faced with news blackouts
and total censorship so we decided it
was going to be important for someone to
tell the truth of what was going on we
found one guy who had a typewriter and
another who had a printing press so me
and a couple of my friends decided to
report on what was happening on the
ground in the back of my mind I kept
thinking about what would happen if we
got caught being found with an
unregistered typewriter or God forbid a
printing press usually meant spending
some time in prison my newspaper was
really only a double-sided single page
leaflet that we produced but the
messages it contained were dangerous
enough that I could have been imprisoned
after printing a few hundred copies we
walked the streets pressing the censored
newspapers or the uncensored newspapers
into people's hands and leaving them in
high traffic areas the city while
desperately hoping one of the Socialist
sympathizers would not turn us in
following the implementation of Martial
law on that night December 13th 1981 in
my city thousands of us would turn off
our city lights every month
on the same day that started martial law
to show solidarity against the regime
whole city blocks would be completely
dark except for a single candle in every
window 20 30 40 apartment buildings all
in a row each 20 to 30 stories tall each
window with a candle in it if you didn't
see a candle in a window you could
assume the person living there was
someone who supported or worked for the
regime I'll never forget the site it was
one of the most powerful and beautiful
demonstrations with the polls showing
solidarity with each other and against
the regime in overwhelming numbers
you know that sounds amazing it still
brings almost tears to my eyes thinking
about it and remembering that so poles
were the any means of protest anything
they was criminalized anything you you
just let socialists and Communists did
not like communities like my father
could put you in prison or get you
killed so Paul's found a way they they
on the day that that martial law was
imposed every month on 13th they turned
the lights off in their homes they and
so you can see entire city almost black
out
with a single uh what do you call it
candlelight single Candlelight in the
window so there was such a powerful
message and what they tell pulse do that
in oppos opposite what propaganda was
saying Millions were supporting the
solidarity and freedom against socialist
State there was not like what you had in
the news and the press that is a fringe
of society there's only very few people
who want this crazy concept of Freedom
or something that is just just crazy and
there's very few of them but here then
you can walk through the
streets and you can say it yourself you
know there's like thousands thousands of
people who oppose that socialist Terror
and oppression so that was very
inspiring you know this is how you can
people can I guess when everything is
taken away from them they still protest
and they still show that what what
really is happening so yeah that was
actually interesting yeah that was
amazing to read about
um
fast forward a little bit some
resistance figures I knew quickly became
very loud and outspoken creating their
own circles that people flock to new
organizations were established every
other day and just kept getting bigger
and bigger we didn't realize that some
of these organizations were actually
being established by the state Security
Police who collected names and
information and were then able to arrest
opponents of soap of socialism in one
Fell Swoop because my group was very
small no one thought to try and join us
let alone infiltrate us we kept a low
profile and covertly distributed our
resistance literature out in the streets
I'm sure the police had been following
us for a long time but they didn't get
anyone until early 1982 when I was
walking toward the printing press down a
tiny little Street I happened to look up
and notice someone was watching me he
was maybe a hundred yards away and
staring directly at me of course I
thought that was strange but I kept
walking and got to the building I
climbed the stairs to the third floor
suddenly I heard footsteps thundering
over my head in a bunch of doors flying
open I had at least eight or nine guns
pointed at my head
it really was like an old school police
standoff they eventually got me to the
ground and handcuffed me I stayed down
there with boots on my back next to my
resistance friends who were already
handcuffed prior to me showing up they
waited for others to show up but no one
did the State security police hauled us
off to their headquarters that same
night they stripped me of everything
except my clothes I was wearing and
carried me off to a dark smelly cold
prison cell even for all my trouble
making over the years I'd never seen an
actual prison cell close up I'd only
ever been in a holding cell this was far
worse reeking of piss and and mold
there was there were people huddled
somewhere in the dark but I couldn't see
anything I stood there until someone
called out hey you just sit down
somewhere I had to feel my way around
with my hands on the walls blindly
managing to find it or barely blindly
managing to find a spot on the wall
among a dozen other people eventually
when they turned the lights on I was
able to see it was a small room with
steel doors with a raised bed in the
middle that was more like a low pedestal
a few people could lie down on it at any
given time
and there were food rations but they
were so small I was soon painfully
hungry apparently others were in a
similar State one prisoner a real mean
looking guy came up to me sometime after
Dawn and said I'm gonna eat your food
today I wasn't about to give him the
chance not even a slim one I knocked him
out and when he was laid out unconscious
on the ground I carefully lifted his
upper lip and using my Knuckles punched
his two Upper Front Teeth and to drive
the point home no one was going to mess
with me in here I pulled the knocked out
teeth from his mouth put them in my
pocket and then I ate his food
yeah yeah that was a you know you know
I'm still kind of like I'm still sad
that I lose those teeth because I was
hoping to one day to make a necklace out
of it you know and carry it but just
they're doing one of the searches they
discovered the teeth so uh yeah I was
hungry but that was the this is
something that we also need to look out
uh watch out for today the methods the
totalitarian States operate they will
have a very small things that you
wouldn't think is a torture but it is so
basically in Poland the Secret Service
is a secret police were doing they were
just limiting rations and keep you
called so there was not like you just
die of it but it was enough to kind of
ache at you and and slowly dismantle
your defenses and eventually you start
talking so that was very common
technique and actually I have to mention
the same technique was used on a chief
Gallagher here in the uh by NCIS in uh
in the in the break in California
golden lack of food yes Cold and The
Limited food Russians so he was always
called he didn't allow him a warm
clothes and the food rations were very
small and again this is not the Russian
to starvey to death it's just enough to
make you uncomfortable out of balance
and this is actually well described in
one of the research papers you can find
on the official CIA website uh I forgot
what's the name of it basically there's
that techniques of that used by Soviet
Secret Police against political
prisoners so that was what was described
there at that time I didn't know there
was a technique I was just hungry the
guy Tony said if he's going to eat my
food I say hell no and I knock him out
but but now since I was when I came to
America I learned about freedom I
learned about these techniques and it
was it really came to realization that
this torture very subtle but were
conducted in Poland on against political
prisoners
um you do end up you someone asked you
what you in for then you say solidarity
and then then they know that they'll
help you out right now you kind of find
some Brotherhood in there during my time
in the State security police HQ at Lutz
did you say it's like Woods is that what
you said would you would you that's
that's how you pronounce it yeah would
you yeah but
yeah L is like a oh like a wood this is
L with the slash so this is how we
pronounce but I say this one time to my
uh to my wife she's like sounds like
like Gucci something not really
something like female genders so
actually well it's a lot this is how you
spell it well I'm gonna say would you
then yeah that's right I don't know if
I'll remember it because it's why didn't
they dispel it
w-o-o-d-z-i-e and then I just pronounce
it right it said it's l-o-d-z how old is
about this oh with the little uh Apple
Store a little point above it and and
that makes it ooh loot
[Music]
all right I was interrogated from
anywhere from two to three times per day
where they asked me the same questions
over and over while in prison there the
police raided my apartment and destroyed
everything
they kept me there for three weeks
asking the same questions repeatedly
sometimes beating me when I didn't
answer the way they wanted or didn't
answer at all at the end of my stay they
announced they had everything they
needed to put me in jail for life and
that I was soon going to the big prison
that same night without explaining
anything further the police marched me
out at 2 am in handcuffs the police kept
moving and under the cover of Darkness
they called me out into the street and
shoved me to the back of a civilian car
where are we going I asked when we get
there it won't matter to you anymore
thought crossed my mind that maybe they
were going to kill me I prepared myself
to fight getting my blood up while I sat
handcuffed in the backseat of the car I
knew it was a lost cause but I would not
go quietly my plan was to hopefully
knock out the two cops with a good kick
when we got out and make a run for it it
was naive but I had no other option
the whole time I was brainstorming they
drove for almost four hours in and out
of town over and over aimlessly until 6
a.m when they brought me back to the
Cell at HQ when I got back confused by
the change of plans and jittery for my
adrenaline I saw some of my cell mates
were crying they thought I'd been taken
out and shot and they were the last time
socialism
they were sure I'd be the next they were
sure they'd be next yeah as the last
people to witness me alive communism
doesn't like Witnesses true
yep
I didn't even understand that that the
the the stress I put on my fellow uh
cell mates at the time because you know
I was taken away I thought they might I
could be shot but I didn't think they
would worry about that that's somehow
until I came back and they explained it
to me why they are so nervous the guys
with the tears in their eyes and saying
dude we thank you for coming back
because we thought that we are next
because that if they're the last
Witnesses who saw me so
what happened well he was taken by the
police never came back and they were
afraid genuinely afraid for their lives
and uh that's how socially State
operates the terror the terror
foreign
a little bit four weeks after my arrest
I was transported to an intermediate
prison the police investigation was done
now they were gathering materials and
evidence to build a case against me the
absence of a confession or any proof was
no obstacle for the Communist Regime if
they lacked evidence they would make it
up but even though I knew they had a
bunk case against me I still didn't have
an attorney to help fight it and going
up alone against a corrupt justice
system usually never ends well I was
initially placed with common criminals
the worst of the violent criminals in a
single cell some of them were snitches
for sure the prison walls were made of
concrete reinforced with rebar the whole
place was cold and quiet mold was
everywhere it was huge the windows were
very high on the walls with bars keeping
us in and metal shields on the outside
of the windows preventing us from being
able to look out how many of us were
there how many of us there were and for
what crimes was anyone's guess
the prison administration's intention
was to break me down by putting me in
the worst cell the biggest guy of the
group tried to strong arm me into
conforming to the cell's imaginary
hierarchy of control of course it did
not end well for him I applied a
significant lesson I learned on the
street you finished the fight when you
are done with the fight not when he
tells you when he gives up
if you stop before submission he could
turn the tables and take you down
despite this guy's screams to stop I
didn't I kept beating him until he
stopped screaming and stopped moving I
fell asleep yeah
that that works I mean this is something
that I let on the street very quickly
you know when you fight I mean like not
in the ring but when you fight on the
street
you find
when until you decide that this is
enough you don't let any even even small
glimpse of the
that this guy can control anything
especially not to when to end the fight
if you let him control that before he
like you totally destroy the guy uh
humidor and this often happened to us
you know I learned the hard way the
other thing I got beat up like this so
you don't stop until the guy is not
moving he may Scream the bloody mortar
stop stop I'll give up I'm your friend
now you know but hey you know what you
become my friend when you fall asleep
and then you know when when we bring you
up you will be okay and that's that's
how it works it is it may I know it
doesn't sound nice but it's just the
safety you know for my own safety if I
stop beating the this guy up when he
says stop stop you know and be nice I
most likely he would still find a way to
attack me or or to keep his position as
the the the top guy in in the cell so I
couldn't allow them so the the like I
learned to beat them up until they don't
move when they don't move then usually
when they wake up they just like they
either go home if they can or in prison
they just
hold themselves in the corner somebody
sit there you know what I'm thinking
about too I was talking about you're
fighting prowess earlier and also you
know what I just remembered from when
you and I would train is you have uh
like real explosive muscle you know like
some people they have good endurance
some people that are super explosive
strong you have that super explosive
strong muscle fiber so like I bet it
dude because I'm sitting here thinking
about this dude like think thinking he's
gonna thinking he's gonna do something
to you and I can just imagine your full
force like explosion at that time yeah
yeah
so that's why they fell asleep very
quickly usually one day when the ones
that happened that's a kind of
um yeah yeah that's you know that's all
of us have that power just sometimes
most of us and here in America is
different I would never now I'm
different I'm American now I don't go
and beat people up I wouldn't do it but
the time there was just the necessity
that was just you have to do what you
have to do to survive especially in
prison when there was such a brutal
place you know so it helped me and
this again like I was saying earlier
some of the stuff when you read it it
seems to be heavier this is one of those
things that I I was reading and I was
thinking damn it says the discomfort of
prison can't be understated beyond the
outright violence there were millions of
little things that made life miserable
for all of us one of those things was
that you couldn't just lie in bed you
had to either sit down on the floor or
on the stool but you could not lean on
the walls or the beds there were four
beds per cell two bunk beds however it
was not meant for the ten or more men
that were actually in the small cell
when I first arrived I didn't think much
of it so and I was so tired and sore for
my weeks at the state Security Police
Headquarters that I decided to lie down
even though the other prisoners told me
I shouldn't one of the prisoners said
don't do it or they will you up
screw that I said I'm gonna I'm tired
and I'm gonna lie down myself my cell
mates were smiling and smirking at each
other in anticipation of what was to
come I ignored them and started to
settle into the bed preparing for some
relaxation
sure enough as soon as as soon as the
bed which was a little more than a
wooden creaked under me the guards
came down on us my resting time was up
they pulled me out of my new cell and
started to work me over I could hear
their punches echoing throughout the
prison as they landed on me they beat me
up and then threw me back in my cell
when they were done with me I thought
for sure this was the time when I laid
down they would leave me alone what
would you think otherwise I mean they
just beat you up right you just you can
you are really sore you work in the
South so why it's natural you need to
lay down right
so I was naive to think because I could
barely sit straight that they would
surely leave me alone and let me recover
in my bed
it was not an act of defiance not yet
however it happened again this time they
beat me with rubber nightsticks in such
a way as to not leave many too many
bruises this method beating this meth
methodical beating included multiple
hits to my kidneys and I ended up
pissing blood as a result once again
they threw me back in my cell this time
I was a hundred percent sure they were
not gonna mess with me it was impossible
for me not to lay down I could not sit
or stand or stay standing so I went
straight to bed I thought they were
going to leave me alone I was wrong they
were not done with me the cycle repeated
himself you know there was not the
resistance at the time that was just
stupidity I didn't know anybody I was
never in prison before you know I was
jailed but something so why wouldn't I
lay down now what's what's a big deal
and then when they beat me up I assumed
that there's going to be well now I have
excuse to lay down so I kept doing it
but again at that at the beginning it
was not just because I was just a tough
and resist it was resisting I just
wanted to rest and
and well but yeah that's eventually uh
dude uh my buddy Stoner he was in Sears
School and apparently you know they give
you like certain information that you're
not supposed to divulge you're not
supposed to tell them like don't tell
them what you know where the friendly
forces are or something right so they
capture him in serial school and they're
starting to like beat him and then
they're starting to waterboard it and
they're like they're waterboarding and
they're like where are the friendly
forces and he's like I don't know and so
then they waterboarded more like where
are the friendly forces he's like I
don't know and then they're like where
are the friendly forces they waterboard
them again and again and finally they go
admin they stop and they're like hey
dude like you're this is horrible you're
getting tortured for no reason you
should just tell us where the friendly
forces are and he goes I forgot
he couldn't say even if you wanted
exactly so it's the same thing he wasn't
resisting he was just freaking forgot
where they were at so there you go
sometimes it's better better be uh
sometimes it's not like heroic
resistance you just forgot some
yeah but you know the funny uh
I can I can lay down I mean I can't
do the same thing you know because they
let me along eventually they said so
after so many beatings they're just like
okay so I'll lay there you know being
sore and they didn't come for me
so he said the same thing he lie on the
opposite side
sure enough you can just the door's open
again and I said like oh that I'm
getting ready for another beating no
they just leave me alone they just grab
the guy and you can hear you know at
least I didn't scream but that guy is
like screaming like a bloody murder
and you can hear people that's beating
up they just their doors open walking
around they throw him in the cell he
gets up looks around
okay you get the out of this chair
I will see it so because he was like a
big hair snap there so he could throw
people off the chairs so there's like
four stools so he see the Run stool from
then on I was laying in the bed that's
laughing my well I was laying in the bed
I was laughing my ass off he couldn't I
couldn't quite take the meetings yeah
yeah he could know that I I think they
they could actually like I was a
political prisoner even whether they
admitted or not he was a common criminal
so that they actually could kill him
with me you know just like that I think
they had
some kind of
uh at least those common guards they
were not really some of them didn't hate
us even through this propaganda and
their training were trained to to hate
us they didn't some of them didn't but
come on criminal that I would I have no
doubt that would kill him
um you got look the get the book there's
all kinds of stories in here and and
details about this stuff at one point
you get in trouble
I mean you get in trouble a lot of
points you spend two weeks in solitary
confinement
um yeah Tiger cage yeah you get this
Tiger cage thing I mean this they took
me to a cell had only an open window
covered by a shield that kept me from
viewing outside but did nothing to keep
the cold out I was given thin blanket
they fed me water and bread and rice
isolation yeah
um yeah then then this time I was given
a week again you get in trouble you're
knocking people out you're breaking
you're just being a freaking Savage in
there well some of it was just from the
fear that if I fell you know they would
eat me alive there so you just have to
be the you don't let you you you you
need to be pretty much on the top if you
don't then you'll have to submit to
other people and stuff and I would never
let happen besides you know I had enough
skills and I had enough expertise not to
let it happen so it was yeah yeah you
get this uh in this one time you get in
trouble again I was given a week of
solitary confinement once again but this
time it was in the so-called tiger case
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah for a moment I
wondered if there was a real actual
tiger in the basement of the prison but
that was short-lived when they walked me
into the cell I burst out laughter it
was so surreal within the cell room they
did indeed have a real cage it looked
like a very large dog kennel they could
not understand what was so funny and
finding my humor in the absurdity
situation did not endear me to the
prison guards it was so odd to see this
misplaced misplaced Tiger cage within
the walls a cell within a cell this the
cage had a steel had steel bar as big as
my thumb and a low clearance so I
couldn't stand upright my only two
options were to sit or lie down on hard
steel they tossed me in and my week
started I didn't hate solitary
confinement not completely it was cold
dirty dark it smelled and the only light
in the room was always flickering or
completely dark I only had a tiny
blanket and a wooden slat for a bed but
at least I didn't have to deal with
other prisoners or guards for that
matter I spent only a few cold and
uncomfortable days in solitary
confinement before the prison guards
came in I thought they would surprise
and surprise I thought they would just
send me back to my cell to my surprise
instead they say we're putting you on a
transport that gave me pause where am I
going Russia maybe we don't know
yeah yeah that was I remember that was
very stressful for me because that was
we knew that they were already
transports to go to Soviet Union to kind
of isolate us that the political
opponents of socialism but uh and that
was the real fear and you will see in
the end of my book it was not only me
but other activists actually were
talking about it the Andrew krasuski uh
who is who is have his except from his
defense against socialist regime
the court defense he talks about it
actually they were publishing that there
are such transports already it could
happen they'd be going to Poland let's
do it from Poland to Soviet Union so
yeah I was scared yeah so what's the
next prison you get sent to uh on the
Russian border so I actually I from
myself I could see the the the Russian
side of the past across the river uh
there was Ruby
present yeah that that's what I ended
ended up on Russian border well not
quite in Russia at least you say it was
classified as one of the harsest persons
in in Poland yes prisoners were
separated by blocks with common
criminals being in different locations
from the political prisoners prisoners
also had more opportunity to interact
with like-minded prisoners it became
very educational environment as we were
sitting in prison with many intellectual
members of Polish Society doctors
professors physicists economists and
Engineers as well as other hard-working
polish Patriots
we all shared the same disdain for
communism and socialism one of the
routine routines was to open the windows
at 8 pm and the entire prison saying
patriotic polish songs that the state
hated every night entire prison blocks
joined together and singing songs about
freedom and Independence these songs
carried into the small town and Beyond
the local polish population like to hear
this patriotic resistance the guards
tried to squash it dragging prisoners
away from the windows but we persisted
as there were not enough guards to stop
all of us and our determined nation was
strong in a cold lonely place like that
morale was vital for our Collective
survival
yes I know this is something that uh uh
when we opened the windows and hundreds
of people start singing the same song it
was echoing in the small town where you
know where where people were living and
that was they couldn't do anything about
there was not enough guards so there was
not like you just stayed there and sing
when they came to the cell with the with
the night sticks and all that stuff
we're holding the bar so that's like hey
can you move away from the Windows like
no so we just stayed there and and
they had to drag us out so it took a
crew of people to drag each one of us
and then they have to move to another
cell and another cell so as soon as they
leave our cell we just go back up there
and keep singing so that was really
unnerving for uh for for socialist
regime yeah um yeah that sounds like a
powerful thing to witness it was
August 13 1982.
we started a hunger strike for the
recognition of our status as political
Prisoners the regime had been hiding and
denying for decades that they held
political Prisoners the last thing they
want to do is admit that the social
estate was holding political prisoners
especially at such a volatile time in
Polish history instead their propaganda
was to show us all as criminals who
committed common crimes after a certain
point in our hunger strike once we'd
wasted away a bit the guard started to
force feed us per prison regulations
they would drag us into separate rooms
in the medical unit and tell us we had a
choice they could either shove a pipe
down our throats and force feed us or we
could eat and swallow on our own either
way we had to eat most of us stuck to
our gunts and said no that isn't what
they wanted to hear the feeding
procedure was to bring the prisoner in
strap them to a wooden chair and shove a
corrugated feeding tube down the throat
it looked more like a vacuum tube than a
feeding tube it seemed way too big to be
a medical feeding device they would push
the pipe down your throat and deep into
your stomach using a funnel they would
dip a large jar into a deep fat of
yellow sludge That Was Then poured
through the funnel into the tube
yeah at first they tried to do it to us
in groups but when enough people
resisted they started doing it one by
one this was a strategic move on their
part it was easier to talk someone
one-on-one and reassure them that no one
else will know lulling him that them
into a false sense of security their
method was to convince a prisoner to
take the cup of first sludge and drink
it himself instead of having them have
to shove a thick pipe down the
prisoner's stomach and having that
sludge poured through a funnel but it
was a trap
the moment after someone took the cup
and drank from it they were immediately
informed that the taking a sip on their
own meant the hunger strike was over and
they were separated from the Striking
population eventually removed and sent
to another prison
yep that was the technique you
especially in the older people who you
know there was this is something so
amazing to me still I was young so I
could put up with a lot of pain and
stuff but those are older people like
you know your fathers your grandfathers
and they sit up there and they say no
I'm not going to eat because you are
evil regime and this is the only means
of resistance I have not to eat so I
will not eat so they and they many of
them stuck by it but you know there's
like older people we're talking 40 50 60
well I'm 60. but you know like you're a
tough sister you're a different kind of
sick yeah but so but so these guys were
uh
who were tormented some of them were
sick with medical uh problems like
Edward kenjorski one of my friends at
cell mates from our Lots we we were in
the the the intermediate prison together
so they they they used that they say
look we just we don't tell anybody but
if you just go and drink we don't have
to hustle you know it's still the same
thing so we just we said of me we for us
to put in the tube in our neck you just
drink it and just go to your cell but
there was a yeah there was a trick
because as soon as you take it you take
a few sips there was the cab was flying
of your hands they slap it off and the
Hand curve you back again and in the
March you to different cells and you
either stay separated from that uh
striking from us striking population or
you were sent to another person because
you were not on strike anymore and then
they didn't want you to be on the strike
so there was a technique but These Guys
these older people you know in days they
had so much
enough of the socialism that they were
ready to die even you know being or
suffocated but but they will not give in
to to the Socialist regime
so it is very for me it was inspiring to
see these old people for me I was 21 for
me 60 years old it was like old all you
know I was like my grandfather so these
grandfathers these fathers with their
children outside and families outside
were risking their lives to free pollen
from cultures of socialism yeah how how
uh
how many days did you go before they
force feed you I uh I think a couple
weeks if I remember that was just there
was there was a time that they uh that
they have to step in that there's a
prison regulations they will if you
refuse to take me or they will force
video but we find out a better way too
because instead of doing it and we did
it too instead of just doing it if that
constant is until you know you die uh
you do it just two days a week or once a
week or once a month uh eventually and I
were describing the book those more
prominent political prisoners yeah
binkowski like Andrew kraszowski
kanjorski and other people they they
came up with the regular regular I mean
regulations and I described that the
fight for to change that prison
regulations so they uh
they just uh they create like our own
code of conduct I would say count of
conduct of political prisoner and uh
most of us if not all of us were
adhering to it so if you get beat up
there was four days hunger strike if you
were
put on the in the isolation cell there
was another strike so whatever they did
we had always tools to respond and to
counteract that uh the the Socialist
regime actions so that was uh first for
me it was inspiring seeing these old
people not giving up and say I'm going
to
I want to make sure that Poland will
become free
you you say this uh my mother came to
visit the first thing she said that she
was very proud of me
of course you are replied for what she
then showed me a letter she'd received
from the prison Warden yeah that said I
was disobeying rules and generally being
a problematic prisoner for them their
expectation was that my mom would come
and visit and persuade me to change my
ways but my mother grinned as she read
the letter she was fussing over my
skinniness a moment later
I wasn't the same young man she'd been
only two months before two months before
prior to her hunger strike I was thin
and looked like I'd barely slept because
I hadn't the mental toll of being in
prison was nothing compared to the
physical toll and I was feeling both my
mother despite her pride in me was
afraid for me and our family yeah I
didn't know this is
I have this letter here I
uttering the states here I have it
actually I found it I found it by
accident I showed it to my wife I need
to find it because we just say okay I
need to put in the place where I will
remember what it is
and this is what I always lose things I
just put like I need to remember so it
is there it is here and I'm going to
publish it on my website I will send it
to you the copy when I find it and to
search for it that was so funny you know
your son is really problematic prisoner
yeah just overall your son's behavior is
highly impropriate
inappropriate in house in inappropriate
inappropriate yeah so and you put it so
they they can ask her they wanted him to
come and persuade me to behave
so my mom was like
she used it just to see me so I say yeah
okay I will come up there I will talk to
him talk to me say keep going don't stop
that's awesome uh fast forward a little
bit the Communist Regime in Poland
following up following another visit
from Pope John Paul II announced amnesty
for prisoners including political
prisoners like myself in Poland at the
time people were always tried to dress
decently even if they were poor when I
left prison in the spring of 1983 I was
smothered in my old winter clothes which
hung off my starved frame like a costume
and for all the production behind my
arrest imprisonment in the end the
guards just basically kicked me out the
front gate and said off you go that was
it besides giving me my old clothes back
they also gave me just enough money for
a train ticket home but I had to walk
all the way to the train station my old
winter clothes and heavy boots some
passerbys pointed to me in Whistling and
whispered laughing behind my back
calling me a bum I was freed from prison
but not a free man not yet yep so in
Poland is a castle now people always
want to look nice when I was growing up
so even if you go take a trash out
Apartments you just go and throw it your
trash you always dress up just to look
nice not to look like a bomb and uh you
know we often look like a bomb bombs not
because we dress up like this because
this all we had to wear but there was
different there was just people knew
that you just when you step outside you
look your best
and uh so so me working now from prison
this big Co heavy code you know the
winter boots heavy boots you know the
the
I look like a hobo like a bomb and
people were like yeah look at that guy
you know it's like so it's kind of odd
but yeah I made it home so that's
important uh yeah that's definitely
important you say by 1983 the people
were so tired of hunger Terror and years
of fear they endured under the social
estate that they were ready to hang
Communists from their Lantern post if
they could have gotten their hands on
them yes that was you know and this is
something where we need to be very
careful uh we need to understand this
process that happened in Poland uh
because uh
Poland just could not stand anymore the
Socialist State and the Communist party
apparatics so they were ready actually
for violence and and they were CR these
groups when you mentioned earlier they
were they were creating uh many of these
groups
were created by the Securities secret
police the State security police and
they were just like you know what they
were they were the most seems like those
agents and informants they are the most
patriotic polls seems like they were
just like okay so we need to make the
oath to this course here let's get
together and let's make a secret uh
meeting let's make it so we we we just
we don't do violence but we will be
prepared for this prepare for that and
this is they were getting these people
to join in they were taking these
different O's and different things while
these agencies are writing things down
so if you and and this is something that
eventually they could use these groups
they wanted to use they they didn't have
a time to do it because the comments
fell but they reduce these groups to
instigate violence and then let's say
the the danger was that one of these
guys the the agent or informat will do
something to provoke things or something
provocative and then they would have a
reason to just arrest entire group and
they were doing that too there were
priests who were being trying to be
framed they were priests they they were
activists they were being framed like
this and they all went to jail because
the the one of the informants did
something that allowed State security
police to arrest entire group so would
they use that the propaganda as well yes
yes
they did and but it accumulated in the
murder one of the priests the father
populusco popular
Security Police tried everything they
tried to say he's a gun Runner he runs
the guns or then he is the pedophile
then he is this nothing stick this guy
was very patriotic he was very as
preaching Freedom preaching don't leave
on your knees and eventually they get
tired of it they kidnap him they murder
him and and they they eventually and
think this so if you if you are and this
is that the lesson to or to oppressors
eventually your time will come because
today they are Prosecuting these people
these people these cops when pollen
became free the security police went to
prison these these agents went to prison
they uh they prosecute actually they are
actually they call it extra judicial
murders when judges were sentencing
patriotic poles or fake uh uh evidence
uh or just just sentencing them to death
they call it murders judicial murders
and they uh
so the these these judges are being
today prosecuted matter of fact I was
contacted recently maybe a couple months
ago by one of the prosecutors in my city
trying to build the case against these
oppressors today years decades after it
filed so if you are an oppressor if you
are pervert if you are the the the the
the the the the the the Marxist Bandit
your time will come
you you you will be one day prosecuted
in full uh uh uh by the law and you
you're gonna get yours the nobody's
immune and that's where that's what
happened that's best example is Poland I
never thought it would happen but they
were Prosecuting these murders those
judges those uh prosecutors and those
police uh secret police officers uh for
the for what they did to Poland
your time will come
yes your time will come
um
after I was really back going back to
the book after I was released from
prison I became hyper aware of the
Communist atrocities being uh committed
and the miserable living conditions in
Poland you also had a priest that would
do
that would that would um
visit the prison while you were yes yes
and that was pretty moving yes Father
yes this is something for me important
at that time as a young person you know
you don't really dwell much about your
faith about you know the philosophical
things but uh when you know when he
starts coming and visiting us in prison
and talking about Freedom talking about
things that uh about faith it really
changed me too so that was like for me
it was very uh a significant moment in a
time in my life where um he had a big
influence on me actually I had the main
chance to meet him uh recently when I
went to Poland for the reunion of former
political prisoners in 2022 and the pope
had a huge influence too Pope had a huge
influence too yes and
he refused to come to Poland unless the
Socialist regime the Communists running
socialist regime release political
prisoners this is how I got out so
um among other political prisoners not
they didn't release everybody yet they
were still people kept in secret that
nobody knew there were some people that
they deemed extremely dangerous they
didn't release but they released most of
political prisoners before John Paul II
came to Poland second time with a great
person though now it is the the the the
the
globalist and socialist Elites tried to
smear his name and Destroy his
reputation now today of course that's
what they do
um
you say this the Communist Regime
believed that depravity and perversion
when thrown on society make it easier to
divide people and therefore control them
yes relative morality was key for
communism to succeed your morality must
be based on the ideology and the
political agenda of those in power not
on God's laws God gave faith and
strength to the people which made them
dangerous to the regime and independent
in thinking independently and not
thinking along necessarily party lines
yes that's true the the prayer the the
the private the perversion alcoholism
alcohol and vodka pushed on people make
them
volatile make them also would divide
them and then they can step in they can
broker the peace between this group and
that group but also they use these
people they use these groups mentally
ill people to to wage the war on the
nation and to for for control so people
who normally you would have compassion
for and the mentally ill person you
would like to set you know allow them to
live in dignity that was taken away from
them they were being used as a scapegoat
often or as a bargaining chip
are trying to destroy the Polish society
and civility in in Polish Society so
that was very common and you know
as
people do take sides they have their own
opinions but if you can if we keep
presenting group of people as uh as as
evil or we pray you present evil as the
good thing this is what you're supposed
to emulate and you know in your heart
that this is just perversion the private
and evil
um then you are you you already are
rallied against these people
if you present mental illness as
something that you have to this is the
normal this is how it's supposed to be
you of course normal people say no it
cannot be like that and very often they
will lash against these mentally ill
people who just did nothing to it they
are being found used by the Socialist
regime to control Society to divide us
further so that's how how it works this
is how the perversion the private
Immortal illness was used to further uh
to further their agenda to this mental
family the attacks on the faith and
patriotism was a big thing you know if
you are a patriot there is no way you
will go and join International Club of
the Communist party or something so they
you know if they destroy the borders in
Poland if they destroy the the uh the
Family Faith and the patriotism and the
national identity then you are so a easy
target for to become the national
International uh uh uh subject and it is
making it it works today because when I
went to Poland I had the chance to speak
to from my one of the friends a German
who I refer to German
apparently I offended him uh he was not
a German he was the European Union
citizen Cunningham German was the right
extremist it was the extremism and that
shouldn't be ever used he was not the
German he went very clear in verse way
to me that he was not a German he was a
citizen of European Union Germany is
just extremism now
yeah that's the goal the goal is to
break apart the family remove faith and
anything uh other than the state because
then you've got the state can control
you
foreign
fast forward a little bit
and this was interesting to me even
though I'd been freed from prison I was
still considered an enemy of the state I
never escalated to the point that I
faced prison time again but it was a
constant fear and it became impossible
to live my life trying to live normally
when you regularly looking over your
shoulder waiting for some State security
police officer to jump out of the
Shadows or from around a corner isn't
life it's torture it lasted for only a
few months in the Autumn of 1983 I
finally decided to visit the U.S embassy
in Warsaw and request political Asylum
and ask for help
and it was such impossible thing for me
to think that I could ever be allowed to
leave Poland and come to live as a free
man in America you know in America was
always for me this this country where
people are free that they can live their
lives the way they want to there is
government not telling them how you have
to live your life and and but it was
such a distance such impossible to to
have to to even imagine that I can ever
come to America and and so but when
things happen the way are you what you
just said I said what what have I what
have I to lose
I can go and ask ask for help I didn't
think they were even allowed to you know
to come to such a great country and
especially me being a criminal at the
time oh no criminals not really criminal
right but with the present time and now
actually those opposite happened I found
it was fine with like a lot of warmth
and yeah we're gonna help you we need to
help you so this is what we need you to
do I was guided through entire process
and like very quickly I got a promise at
the promesa promise for the to have uh
immigrational visa to the United States
and I was allowed to come to America you
know there was
yeah that was something did you just go
down there and knock on the door yeah
like yeah I just went to U.S embassy and
say and uh this is what happened to me
you know they were wrong lines already
too but there's if you if you were a
political prisoner at the time I think
you they look at you differently so yes
I just waiting in line came to my my
time came in I explained what happened
to me what is my uh real story and uh
that's and then here I am you know now
I'm in America yeah he said it took like
a matter of months within months yeah
three four three four months yeah three
months I think I was I had this promise
usually it took a long time and to get
immigrational Visa out even longer time
than that but because it was emergency
then uh like they understood the urgency
of it and uh yeah I was allowed to come
to America very quick it was actually
funny because I I could talk about it
for for days because
um like no I was always called so I
would isn't there to ask I would just
want to come to America but they even
asked me where I want to leave I was
like it must be crazy so I said like
anywhere where it's hard you know I just
don't want to be called
I went to Memphis Tennessee I was like I
don't know what it is is it hot up there
oh yeah it's hot
like me that's good enough
that's good enough
um you say this when I was I'm gonna
fast forward again you you go through
some of that details of that
process of getting out of there finally
you get on a plane West Germany was the
first stop on my journey to freedom in
Germany I learned a lot about the
American citizens and polish expatriates
living there who work for the U.S state
department and who are assisting me with
other me and other polish political
refugees and the transition to our new
life in America they taught me and
others fleeing from various oppressive
communist Terror States what America is
like the Customs so social mores and how
to be successful being good American
citizens it was a lot to learn and even
then it barely scratched the surface
this is when I made a promise to myself
that I would be the best citizen that
America could have it was my pledge to
America the greatest country in the
world the land of the Brave and the free
yes that's you know this is something
that is still with me today very very uh
very live you know it's uh
I was never asked well what can we get
out of you
I was only asked to when you come to
America we ask you to respect our
citizens respect our laws and respect
our flag in our country and
believe go and leave live in peace that
was it it's like and there was so like
well so they just don't want anything
from me no you they we just want you to
come and leave
as a human being and hopefully you
learned about America enough you can
become U.S citizen even and you can vote
you can actually be part of this this
setting the direction for the country I
was like that was just it was like
science fiction to me at the time and
that's what happened
on March 21st 1984 I landed safely
albeit exhausted in America with the
equivalent of 10 cents 10 Phoenix those
gentlemen of our 10 phoenixes I don't
know like maybe five cents actually but
it's like 10 cents I was picked up from
the airport by a church family who'd
volunteered to host me while an
apartment was being set up that part
didn't take long at all when the days of
my arrival I was brought to my new
apartment near the projects in Downtown
Memphis it was completely stunned it
wasn't the nicest place but it was mine
and most importantly it was America
for me it was the most beautiful place
on Earth the fact that I had suddenly
had an air conditioning unit Central
Heating and refrigerator was
mind-blowing to me oh yeah you know it's
like in Poland I remember when I was
growing up in Poland or sometimes
watching American movies you can see
these boxes in the windows and I was
like why it is such a simple idea to put
the just a box so when my mom puts the
when my mom puts the milk outside
because this in Poland was called so if
we keep the foot on the ledge of the
Windows like third floor or fourth floor
so sometimes this thing fell off so so
say what's such a simple idea those
awesome boxes mom why don't we build the
box like you have like America here in
our home well I didn't know there were
other conditions I thought they were
just boxes when you keep the milk and
meat and that stuff that needs to be
caught outside so I learned that but
yeah there was such a you know like I
still remember remember that time when I
came in like like there's nobody telling
me what to do I can ask they will tell
me but is nobody waiting to put me in
prison I can say whatever I want to say
without of course not offending other
people
and and be free man you know there's
that's a I really felt free and this is
something that even today is touches me
you know that I still can come back to
that feelings where I was really
frightful for the first time there is
not the government here to torment me or
or you know or put me in prison so I
still remember how long did it take you
to feel like that was it like
instantaneous where you just said the
first when I landed it was the first
time that was like they can't get me now
but then when I start living on my own
you know I was a janitor yeah so that
was your first job you got a piano I was
a janitor yeah so I was cleaning the
toilets mapping the floors and this
would down on me
I can't pay for my I can pay for my
apartment okay but you know what this is
this is not all the story because you
know I wouldn't make that would be maybe
so easy for me I had American people
coming and helping me basically this is
how you need to do this this is having
to do this we need to close my clothes
worn out you know I was making barely
money because I was part-time janitor so
just enough to pay my apartment my food
but like clothes and stuff is American
who's bringing me people I didn't know
from Adam they just feel that you know
what he is in need so we're gonna help
him and this is something that people
here don't think about they don't
realize it even it's so transparent to
Americans a goodness being good to other
people and helping other people and
sometimes actually why you are helping
this person and they what that's where
we are you know this is the way America
is you can help you help and
what's wrong with that I said like no
nothing you just you don't even think
what you are doing you're just doing
because this is the way you were brought
up as an American helping people helping
other people and if you succeed you help
other people succeed and this is this is
well but this is so this is normal this
is how we are well that's how we are but
this is normal but this is not normal
anywhere around the world so this is
different I know a family of refugees
from uh
from Vietnam and they came to America
someone paid for them to come to America
they paid for this family to have like a
small house they paid for like food for
them to get started they same thing yeah
so they paid for all the stuff and the
family ended up the the Suns ended up
doing very well they're like super
wealthy now they they still don't know
who the people are that sponsored them
yeah they don't even know it's just
someone just gave them a a ride to
Freedom yeah and then a head start in
America and the people that did that
never have stepped up and said hey
you're welcome or hey how about some
payback nothing they just did it out of
the goodness this is something that
American people don't see it because
it's transparent to them they are
brought up like this this is this is the
way we are but for us immigrants it is
different it's like holy this is
the entire nation is is so different
it's built on goodness personal freedom
it is being cherished and this is
something that that it it touches me
every time I think about it is is that
the the nature of America and the
character of America which is like
people don't think about it because
that's the way we are you know it's like
what are you talking about you know but
yeah there is a lot to talk about you
write in here about the first time you
went to a mall what was that like you
must have been blown away
well before I went to the mall I went to
downtown because in Poland there was
never malls right there was just like if
you go you're gonna go see like nice
tape recorders or like I was in the
electronics actors he like have a nice
type record there having maybe some nice
Radio Service in Poland you want to go
see you go to downtown and there's like
we work on the street and you see it uh
because the climate is so mild that uh
there's no reason to go inside you you
outside so I will I did sign myself to
go check it out myself I was encouraged
by the people who took care of me first
time that the older couple to explore
America so I decided to go downtown well
I see those big buildings in the far
away I couldn't judge the distance that
if I never seen that thing that far so I
said like I just walk up there so I put
my flip-flops on and a flip-flop
flip-flop just going to jump into over
the interstates because like I came to
the stop it's like there's no how do I
go well the pilot just crossed the
stream so I didn't know that it's just
interstates were so across the
Interstate jump over the fence climb the
bank you know keep walking
and to go downtown took me like a few
hours I came in there and it's like
nothing there
so there's like big offices you can see
nice dress people during the lunch time
no going to eat something bunch of
restaurants but like nothing to look at
just the Office Buildings so then I was
stretching my way back and again I
served every so often some Americans
stop do you need help do we need a ride
I was like no thank you I don't I
couldn't hardly say what they want I
could tell what they want because my I
didn't speak English but I kind of
figured out they won't give me a ride or
something I say no no no thank you and
keep walking back but you know act like
blisters all over my feet I said I'll
never do it again and definitely not in
the flip-flops and then I was at all
about my Escapade and this older couple
so they took me to to them all say this
is where you go
holy I haven't seen my life things
like that that was like everything there
you know and these people like nice
dress you know they're walking around
and like nobody's chasing them they
don't try to just run into store and
grab something like I was used to you
see something good you just go and grab
it so I was like wow this is so great
you know so then I was always like where
do you want to go I want to go to the
mall so outside become like the
permanent mall fixture I think in
Memphis for a while because I just
couldn't have enough of it
so you eventually get a job uh you know
in a car shop a car dealership yes your
your your uh Fallen Parts basically that
they need yeah yeah okay easy fourth
those okay there and as you're doing
that your English isn't great so you're
kind of messing up some of your parts at
your phone and eventually Yeah Yeah so
basically the dealership the Oakley kz4
didn't want to fire me because I was
working so hard and they knew in my
challenges my English but they like me
so they the opportunity opportunities
show up and another dealership to be a
mechanic either for Porsche Audi on Saab
so they say you know like would you what
do you think about do you know anything
about foreign cars do you do you know
the European cars I was like yeah I I
didn't but you know I didn't even know
anybody none of my friends even owned
the car and uh I never owned the car for
sure and then my father only did but he
was never with us I never seen that car
so but your European so you must know
about yourself yeah I came from Europe
so do you know about European cars right
yeah and uh and I just wanted to uh you
know
progress I wanted to another opportunity
and I knew that I was not doing that
great here I was trying very hard but it
was just my ability was not quite there
but you know banking with the tools and
Hammer I can do that all day long and so
they say yes yes and we went to uh so
they drove me to the dealership and to
stream two mechanics show up first for
Porsche then for Audi but they both look
at me and it's like you know what the
guy really don't speak English very well
and I need somebody who actually can get
up to speed on these cars they were very
expensive cars to to do something so uh
no no thank you and so they said okay
well let's wait for the last one that's
the sub mechanic and here it is you know
the the the the the the ramble of Harley
Davidson and the whole dealership shook
see so the guy just pulled in I wouldn't
know I could hear him but they wouldn't
see him yet because we are in the office
and then the six foot something
Sasquatch shows up uh Yeti a big
guy it's like she just look at me he
said that guy it's like yeah let me do
you want to be
Saab mechanic it's like yeah it's like
okay I need a slave so I take him as my
slave wait to go work for me and I got
hired I got the job and this guy
you know they they were afraid of him
there often that they call him
motorcycle gangster uh he took me under
his wings
everything I knew and knew about cars
even today I learned from him and he
that he basically
allowed me to
to move on the next level in American
society I became mechanic and he made
sure that I am damn good mechanic and he
I remember for me it was still very
challenging I had to read manuals I had
to connect the words that I read with
the parts that I'm fixing and working on
so I figured out the easiest way would
be to let him uh go and read this the
text for me so we were already friends
say Jim
if you could
I would like you to read this manual for
me loud I will record it so then at home
I can repeat and read it over and over
I I thought the professor is looking
like what the is he asking me for
it's like I thought he would kill me but
he says like you know what
I help you but if you tell someone that
was your and reading your books
I'm going to kill you I was like
I'm never talking about it and I think
he doesn't mind now I can tell but uh
but at the time yeah he was the he was
the the the the biggest baddest guy I
think I met till in my life
so he taught me everything I know he
knows about cars he made me good
mechanic and he um but when he read he
was not good at reading and I know his
resistance Now understand why he didn't
he didn't want to read but he did he
struggled through it as much I think as
I do I think I could do I read as much
as he could but he did it and then at
home later on every night I was
listening to the table recorder and was
following in the text and then the the
figures the the drawings and it really
helped me help me really become the good
mechanic and uh I owe him so much so
Jimbo if you listen to this my respect
to you and my gratitude thank you for
everything you made me better American
thank you brother
there you go uh James James Moore James
Moore so you end up with that job you
end up getting a job then with Mercedes
um
time's going by you went on a date with
some girl and she had just been
skydiving yeah you know like I never
thought even this possible it never
crossed my mind but here I met the meet
the girl and she jumps so now I feel
like a next to her it's like what
the hell so we talk about it and say why
don't you try and it's like the I think
it was one of the times like unlocking
moments that yeah nothing is stopping me
why wouldn't I try this is America this
is America you can do whatever you want
to do of course within the limits of the
law being the good citizen but but yeah
so I count the drops on and say hey uh
can I jump yeah I'll be right there and
I just drove myself there anyway I was
ready they would put parachute on me but
they say well that doesn't work like
this you you can do today you can do the
tandem jump so then if you like it then
you know you can ask you can you can
schedule the classes and usually take
couple weeks that you know you go to
class make a jam get another class make
a jump and within maybe two weeks you
will be skydiving on your own like as
you want so I made the first tandem jump
and say I need to do it again so
went back again and then I just ran out
of money for the weekends so I said like
I I Want to Start Skydiving and they say
okay uh when can I start
uh we can start on Thursday so we make a
Thursday Jump Then maybe you can bike
work on one on the weekend then maybe
another Wednesday maybe another weekend
with the seven jumps because AFF and
you could then you can start jumping on
your own
oh I started on Thursday I was
Saturday I was jumping on my own where I
we just went through all these
jumps I was just nagging begging them
say hey don't leave don't leave yet one
more jump one more jump so the
instructors tell me Kinder rest in peace
brother and and the Wolfman uh Robert
Collins as they were one of them Reggie
and Sarah they were my instructors
they're actually registered me first on
the on the first sky that this is the
guy who hooked me about skydiving
and they were there all the way through
my uh progression until I graduated from
the AFF course when I became the uh the
seven skydives on Friday and Saturday I
was jumping on my own actually a barrow
parachute uh
parachute and I was trafficking on my
own and they and I was screaming like
Geronimo because they told me to scream
like this so I was bombing out of the
airplane on my on my own after like
eight and nine ten jump Geronimo and
also with my name to uh my name is
jerron so it's like there was like two
or three Thomases at the drop zone so I
said enough are you Geronimo that's
easier for us you know we don't have to
worry about that your funny name I
became Geronimo
so you're learning that you're learning
Free Fall you also at this time
um are studying to become an American
citizen yes and you memorize all that
information you learn the the American
history yes because it was examinated
yeah and as you're doing that the
the war kicks off the first Gulf War
kicks off you come you become a a
citizen of America May of 1991 yes now
the war is going or looks like it's
going to go off and you decide you're
gonna
that was I'm American this is my country
in war and need so I will support my
country I will fight War for America and
this is when I decide to join military I
never intended to spend you know to do
career out of it I just I just wanted to
fight war on behalf of America because
America was at War so that was I had to
do that and uh I I didn't know how to go
about it so I went to post office and I
found there that thing that says
you say in the book in the post office I
had found a Selective Service
registration card for the draft Yeah I
proudly filled it out sent it off and
went home packed my stuff yeah I was
expecting to get a call from the
military anytime America was at War and
I was ready to serve yeah yeah so they
they so uh the guys came in they said
what are you doing
care of it for a while and I'm I'm ready
so when are you living as like any time
because I didn't know it so so they uh
there's like okay but then the the the
the response came in that I'm too old
that's just the there's another there's
just a registration it is not the uh
you know contract the military contract
right and I was like sudden but let's
figure out well there's some way I can
support my country I mean it doesn't
have to be maybe Northern but I would
like to do it because it's the easiest I
cannot build the jobs I don't have
resources to build more jobs for my
fellow Americans so I will fight for
them and I will and they kind of guide
me later say uh what what this is what
you need to do to go to the PO to the
recruiting office and join it and I had
no distinction between Army Navy
military
was military to me I was like Army Navy
I I didn't know any difference there
there is a difference so I went to Army
office or says Army so and I'll go there
they send me there and they fill the
paperwork they proceed the paper with
all this background check and everything
took a while and um
and in the meantime when they already
complete pretty much everything that
came in that Navy Seals came into
Memphis Tennessee and they uh they uh we
jumped together because they were the
jump team right yeah it was a jump from
the leap rocks LeapFrogs they were doing
some demonstration in Memphis so of
course they stopped by our Drums of too
much extra fun fun jumps and this is how
I find out they told them what I wanted
to do and they're like well why don't
you go and ask the navy God joined the
Navy because ask them about Navy Seals I
say okay I really didn't know the Navy
Seals were at the time I I just knew
there's some special forces and Stafford
was not my goal to join Special Forces I
joined and I just wanted to be in
Military and fight the war because
America was fighting a war and then so I
went after that to them and say look uh
I just met here guys at my drop zone
they told me to come to your office and
switch my paperwork from basically not
to join army what I'm working with now
recruiter next door just come to talk to
you first and who are these guys I said
they call themselves sales oh
okay so what do you want to do in the
Navy I want to be Navy SEAL just like
these guys
okay so now then we start working on it
they told me to bring the paperwork and
I was kind of very awkward for me to go
to these guys or to build relationship
with that that army recruiters and the
governor said like well thank you giving
my paperwork I'm going next door but I
did that I didn't like it but I did it
uh didn't like because I didn't feel
comfortable you know like I feel
obligated to do this guys and and then
uh so I brought the paperwork stuff and
that was pretty quick from then on
because they uh yeah that was that was
very quick yeah yeah I mean you say in
the book The Following Thursday I was
sworn into the U.S Navy delayed entry
program that Saturday I left for boot
camp yeah
what happened is
um they asked me what at least they were
honest with me that
they were nice with me that provide me
with the job because you can at least in
the Navy as undesignated and then after
bootcamp the Navy send you somewhere but
uh they knew that I'm way too old and my
chance to join Navy sales was pretty
much zero
so so they say well at least we give him
the guy a job he's so excited to be part
of the military so so they say what job
do you want to do and I say like where's
something with parachute would I be
because I don't know what the jobs maybe
jobs are but but with yeah I say right
on sign me up but then he's like well
but you know what
they call me like next week and say you
know this is like if you want to go to
Paris rodrigger you have to leave now
because
this is the schedule as a boot camp and
that we need to schedule so from
bootcamp you go to a school if you don't
go now you have to take another month or
two to go to boot camp and then so the
time frame comes just right so after
bootcam you go to a school so I say well
I don't want to wait that long the war
is on so sign me up so I killed my
girlfriend that's like I'll say the line
uh
we're getting married because I'm
leaving for the Navy it's like what it's
like we're going to the Navy I'm going
to the Navy so when to get married
and uh and uh and uh she's kind of like
was a little bit upset but then she she
came in because I was in town to say hi
we need to go and find the judge get
married sign it up and I'm leaving this
weekend so we went up there we we got we
found some judge who was actually
leaving home so say hey can you can you
marry this
so he was a nice super nice guy who
thought he talked to us and stuff with
the paperwork we got married I went to
uh I think on Thursday get sworn for the
Line enter the delay enter the program
and I think Saturday I will ship out to
Saturday or Monday I think Saturday I
don't remember I was ship out to
bootcamp and it was it so I was I was in
the Navy I was happy damn dude and all I
ask is just to go to war I said like
send me to war and then never intend to
make career out of it I just thought to
make a
just go for fight a war when the war is
over come back and resume my life it was
a good life you know I was I had
everything in my life I could dream of
and then you ended up in Navy boot camp
there you go yeah and this was something
that uh
was for me there was the initial thing
was pretty scary because they were
yelling at me you know and I shaved my
head took my calls away give me some you
know the military clothes it was a big
shock but you know the for a second I
was like that's pretty scary but then I
said this is this is the path for me to
fight for America so I need to do that
and I I say that and I was good because
I graduate as a number one recruit
in this whole graduation cycle so I will
receive the military Excellence award
number one recruit and was sent off to a
school the next the parachute rigging
school and what was you got a kidney
stone during boot camp yes yes they
actually laid up almost got rolled back
yes so I didn't know what the kidney
stone was that never had one never you
know I was not that educated I was
laying in the bed you know what night it
just like the pain just kicked me right
so so badly in my back that fell off
that bunker from the first second bunk
on the floor and it was like you know it
was already dark because we were
sleeping and it was like Kaboom I was
like what happened the lights went on
and by the time the the second medic
because I couldn't speak it was so
painful and and and I'm on my four and
with but before the Medics even came out
I had a that big puddle of sweat from
pain under my nose and this guy coming
are you okay I was like do I look okay
to you I was like No Okay so
that was okay you know I pissed this
thing up when
they told me I need to be moved to the
class behind in my company the 169 I
think that was graduating that's right I
was back inside no please send me back
I'm good I pissed this this Stone out I
have no problem I can I'm good and they
decided actually they allowed me to come
back the funny things was like inspiring
for me so when I walk into the group
because they announced the company to
this recruits that I will be moved to a
class behind I was uh I had a medical
emergency and I'm not going to be
continuing and then I'm walking in so
there I could line up and I was working
there everybody was clapping and you
know
and it was so inspirational to me you
know these young kids these young guys
and they they like that you know that
I'm buying the with the in their company
so yeah but they also almost the real my
Seal training because I didn't know at
the time but eventually I was going
through I passed the test so I was going
to Medical checkup is medical for this
Navy Seals and I went maybe like two
three stations in the the one that Dr
Rook said they'd say well I think your
sales career is ends right here that's
like well yes sir as you say you have
the kidney stone you have to wait I
think year year or two years I have this
document still at home so you have to
wait a year and then you can reapply for
CR training again so midnight but you
can continue with your a school and just
go assign the like the command somewhere
and uh so I was like
I was like going 32 so like four years
over and uh and then you know another
year waiting and then more few years
that would never happen well luckily you
got hooked up you got this part in the
book here you say while in Millington
this is where your your a school was
where you're learning about parachute I
visited a Navy SEAL motivator on base I
asked him to take the initial CL entry
test and I passed it then I told him my
situation with the kidney stone he
thought for a minute and then told me to
bring my medical record to his office
sure I ran to the clinic on base with
the request with his request for my
medical record and was back within an
hour
the record of my kidney stone was on the
first page the Navy SEAL motivator
Lester told me to wait outside his
office
I could hear a loud rip and I was called
back into the office he looked at me
with concern and said that he was not
able to find any record of my kidney
stone anywhere
he asked me if I could point it out for
him
as we trudged through my medical record
I could not find it either then looking
carefully at me he asked me if I was
sure that I ever had a kidney stone
at that point I was already a hundred
percent convinced that I hadn't yep
that's that's less Barrios rest in peace
Brother that's he's no longer with us
but he's the one who actually put me on
the right track and put my career on
track the way up so I ended up in the
SEAL Teams but you know what this I want
to make one point here that my biggest
motivation was not to be a Seer was just
to join the military join US Navy and
fight the war on behalf America when
America was at War so well you know if
in sales capacity that would be great
but if not it literally was that not
that important for me what capacity I
would be serving America and so then but
it happened that was Barrios he knew
what he was doing he asked me to bring
the paperwork he fixed it and I went to
and I eventually because I end up also
with with the trade school the a school
as a PR as on the top of my class so I
was doing well in the Navy and I think
this is why I got these waivers
eventually so the only thing is barring
me from training was my age and that was
uh with less body as a recommendation
and I was granted the waiver uh yeah do
you know what the oldest person is to go
through buds do you know I think it was
maybe a few years older than I am but
there's like four or maybe like four
older people than I was uh yeah I was
gonna I think I've heard of someone
being 34.
uh
there is now somebody who was older than
dead but he didn't make it through uh he
made out of bats but didn't make it to
the training he he was uh he didn't make
through sqt but but there was just very
few people I think yeah I didn't know at
the time that that I'm one of the oldest
ever going to that but I kind of you
know yeah I've heard well you you just
it's hard to recover for guys that are
older now listen you're a straight up
mutant because you're sitting here right
now you're freaking 63 years old you
look like you're about 38 years old at
the most so yeah uh so but most guys
they can't recover fast enough when
they're 33 years old when they're 32
years old even when they're 30 years old
and then so it's really hard for guys
that are quote older to make it through
and then it's also hard for guys that
are young to make it through I heard the
other day a stat that guys that are
underneath 20.
have less than five percent of making it
because
when you're young you don't quite have
all your strength yet and a lot of times
the guys just aren't mentally mature
enough to be able to gut through stuff
so I think the prime age is probably
like 23 24 or something like that that's
the most of the guys in my class yeah 21
23 24. yeah I was all I mean I I didn't
feel old amongst them because I could be
that many of them but but I was I was
but you know they took care of me they
knew I was kind of different I was
different so you bet they uh and I was
like I became like a mascot in the class
I guess even they're just making fun of
me instructors too but you know they
didn't find any buttons on me so like to
push on yeah so they move on the yelling
and other students I got yelled at them
too but like not more than than average
in the class but uh when when they pick
somebody in the class who was like weak
on something it was like sensitive about
something they just keep pushing this
button until until this guys Kuwait yeah
or or or stop being sensitive traits
yeah yeah that's right they can either
become hard or they can't quit yeah yeah
and that never bothered me I was wrong I
went to prison time I went to the staff
that actually helped me uh maybe mature
me mentally enough that that never
affected me I never never pay attention
to that they could yell at me all day
long I just wanted to do a good job I
just wanted to be good now you say in
the book that your biggest issue was
that you weren't the strongest swimmer
and I was thinking about that when I
read it I was like yeah it wasn't like
you were going in down to the Country
Club pool on the weekends in Poland or
anything like that you weren't taking
trips down to the seashore to go
swim so you didn't have much water time
growing up yeah no not at all I mean the
things and there's a stream like a river
a little tiny River by my grandmother's
uh place where once every year once
every while I was going there but you
know I didn't know how to swim very well
so
um and I tell you this how a naive I was
this I will jump for a second to but
when I show up in Bots you know that get
wet and Sandy run again so many of us
just run to the to the ocean I see this
guy just getting like a knee deep like
the ankle deep water they roll in it and
just come out roll in the sand so I said
that's kind of stupid I just why don't
we just it's kind of like painful
because it's cold I just go and let the
wave because with big waves roll over me
so I just duck the wave rolls over me
and I get wet and I just rolling descent
and come back to instructors to the
class
good God I didn't know the powerful the
power of ocean I thought I would drown I
thought my my hands my legs got ripped
out of me I eventually the the ocean
spit me out and I was like totally
exhausted I said what the was this
and so I basically crawled out of that
thing rolling the sand and Limp back to
there and I never then I say like those
guys were smart I need to follow them do
what they do but yeah I couldn't swim so
uh I was uh and you know we were trying
to practice it like Jason Cabell as like
Mary Bell yes yes so we when we met in
the pr school this is when we try to
help ourselves and prepare but there's
nothing can prepare you I couldn't swim
jabel couldn't swim ever less than I did
oh really yeah
I don't know how he this guy made it to
the sheer willpower he just would not
quit but yeah we didn't swim he was a
determined dude he's oh yeah he's a
hard-headed German dude to make stuff
happening and you know often this is so
when I had a hard times we kind of
become good friends and uh in the a
school so I went to bats very often I
just like rely on his opinion or his
what he what he thinks you know what
should I do and he's the same thing
we're just asking helping each other out
so Jay bear was uh together yeah we're
the bicycles together too so
so yeah that also something that I think
we we are friends forever and so we're
brothers forever and then you know we
met in combat too in in Iraq so there
was something but I remember when I was
learning how to when I was trying to
swim when I first time came in I'd never
swimming with the mask in on my face so
when they told me to put the mask on and
they thought I'd swim the laps when
after the first two laps I was already
drowning because I couldn't breathe I
was breathing so much water into in the
lungs as air and and I was like we were
seeing this black spots you know this
the they're about to pass out so I
remember like if I stand up they would
just kick me out it's like I can't swim
but if I don't well I would not drown
they would pull me out of water
resuscitate me so see I just swim I said
I will swim until I pass out and I did
it and you know I was getting easier and
better and better and eventually and the
end of it when we finish with this face
the next phase came in I was chosen to
demonstrate sidestroke swim this is you
guys so so I did well so you figured it
out and I mean you're used to you
already been in freaking a communist
prison camp uh so once you got to the
swimming people are yelling and
screaming at you no big deal yeah uh and
then the running the O course all that
stuff pretty much no factor for you it
was I was pretty good that that was not
the top of the class but I was never I
was never going until third phase when I
started piecing blood but uh otherwise
uh you know I was always someone in the
middle of the Park yeah and uh yeah but
it was taxing for me you know like guys
after finishing I was with Amusement
watching like these guys okay
let's go drinking I was like I
can't do that I can hardly move I cannot
leave my hand so um I did manage to go
drink with the guys too just not so
rough
did you ever get rolled back uh I
gathered back just in the beginning of
it right before the hell week I got this
Mercer Perfection so my legs swore I
couldn't put my pants on and I was it
was not smart about it instead of I
figured out I don't go to the medical
now but what I will do I just wait till
Friday so they will cut that out
and then I would have three days to heal
and I'm good to go yeah well so I went
to Balboa in uh on Friday after we
finished with our exercise with our day
and they they clean it up they cut the
out and they sent me home and I was
like okay I'm good by Monday morning my
leg is so swollen that for to put my
pants on I had to actually cut my pants
open and I went to medical and they like
they were pissed they didn't what
happened is in baloa they did not
irrigate that wound so they just cut it
out and just send me home and so so they
they fixed it and my swelling went neck
within an hour down so I said can you
put me back in the class and say no
because we are going into muds and you
have open wound it will Gathering fact
that you can't this house is like no
please do it I'm strong I can do it
yeah and they say okay if you can run
here that okay I think they told me to
rank a mile back and forth and you come
back on time oh we we will reconsider it
and I did I did run I was I was painful
but it was they already cleaned it up
the swelling went down so I did I finish
it up and say can I go back
no you you it's still open so it was one
class 184 and it was before the whole
week and so I started 185 and I finished
water 185. it's from Amazon week was it
how was hell week uh hell week we know
we're like I I don't remember as a bad
thing for me it was like we get in
I got kicking the balls and then we left
and that and I was done the the more
important the more difficult for me was
third phase that was real healthy that
was Halloween for me I was kicking my
ass that's when I started piecing blood
and uh that was like what about what
about second phase what about how about
pool comp since you didn't swim much
growing up you how was Pool Company by
this time I was swimming good so
everybody so you know that's that's nice
about the Navy and but if even if you
try and the instructors were happy they
make sure that you you know the material
you know how to swim and but was kind of
uh I failed the first one first pool
comp and the second one
I was so stressed out when I felt I had
to take the test next day they were so
stressed out uh that when I was driving
home I beat up two guys up there and the
uh by my apartment but there was
uh there was another story but I passed
it next time
uh you say something really interesting
in the book which I actually think a lot
of guys
would agree with but I've I don't think
I've ever heard anybody say it this way
you say Bud's training proved I was
capable of a lot of things but it also
revealed a lot of ways in which I wasn't
as strong as I thought
and I was thinking like yeah you get
pushed to your limits where you can't do
anything else like you get you're gonna
do exercises and do things
to where you know oh I ca there's a
point where you can't just do anymore
yeah like there's a point where you
can't climb a rope anymore like it
doesn't matter how bad you want it I'll
always like the the uh example of
climbing a rope because you can climb a
rope to failure and you can't climb a
rope anymore like you could get another
grip before you slide down there's that
would happen to some guys they'd on the
O course like you know they wanted to
pass the O course but they couldn't
climb that rope to grab the Rope
transfer or the ring transfer so there
are things you we as human beings like
everyone talks about how in buds you
learn to push through anything but you
also learn there's some stuff you're not
going to be able to push through and
that's why you're gonna need teammates
exactly oh exactly it teaches you and
what it told me to some of the stuff
that I need to be aware of that that is
that there are things that I need to
rely on other people and especially on
the teamwork here that teaches you that
by yourself by anything yeah you can be
powerful Powerhouse but you still need
the teammate you can't do it on your own
and it's not only through bus but right
the entire seal career you learn to rely
and you you know that buzz is teaching
you where you need that push that extra
teammate to to to to to to to to to get
you through the hump why was why was
third phase which is land Warfare why
did that kick your ass so bad
well first because my I think my by this
time my body was a little bit exhausted
too I I allow myself before going to San
Clemente Island to be dehydrated and I
remember we came back from the rucksack
March and I was pissing blood because I
was so dehydrated and I was so tired I
guess besides my kidneys I guess we're
not very strong because the beatings I
got from the they were that's how they
the guards were beating us in kidneys
where you basically have no marks it's
not many marks so that paid the cat at
all and I think from then on I remember
I was always uh I was weaker I was
weaker than I normally would be and so
we're going to San Clemente Island as
you know that uh you you just uh there's
like a hell week but on steroids you
don't sleep you don't you hardly sleep
you you always cold and wet and
everything is very physical but on the
top of it you need to think you are
shooting live ammunition next to your
teammate next to your next student you
move you do things that could
potentially kill you so you have to you
are tired exhausted but you still have
to think and you have to think quickly
and on the top of it if you want to eat
you have to make those perfect 11
pull-ups in full gear so like say I was
weakening already so sometimes I was
able to make those pull-ups but if you
didn't then you make those races you go
race back to the serves to the surf and
if you don't come back on time assigned
to you by instructor you run again you
run again you run again and eventually
you end up eating outside so there was
December of the time was freaking cold
and it was the time I ate outside so so
that was kind of yeah it was hard that
was her week and steroids that's what I
call it yeah you also say this from the
outside this training she was absurd and
it is brutal but everything that happens
during Seal training is taken from a
carefully curated and calculated
training guide that is updated and
improved upon year after year
um there are no random exercises and if
it's not in the manual it's not part of
training unlike the popular belief that
some exercises are just arbitrarily made
up and crazy in Seal training there is
no Randomness or haphazard foolishness
everything goes by the book and manuals
the training is dangerous as it is
there's no need there's there's no place
for craziness there are many safety
measures implemented to protect students
most of it is invisible to trainees
they don't know about it and this was
one of the ways to introduce stress on
the students so they can be graded on
how they perform during duress
yes that's what there's a big mixed
conception and I hear it all the time
from people from civilians the Seal
training is just crazy these instructors
are coming out with some crazy and
they will just drown you they will
resuscitate you there's like you know
what but this is so stupid and people
need to realize the training the skill
training is dangerous as it is even the
initial part that selection course is
very dangerous so there is no time there
is no place for some craziness and and
and and wild things everything goes by
manual everything goes by the the
instructions you cannot deviate from it
because if you do you risk students life
you you reach these kids lives so I
didn't know it when I was going through
the training I thought this freaking
crazy this guy that instructive that
thinks it is crazy but it is not
everything goes by the book everything
is already assigned and and it's being
approved improved upon every class so so
it's getting better and better yeah
um so you get through that and
you end up getting assigned to team two
still team two yeah and uh so that was
uh kind of uh it got me to because you
know when when you check in you you
always under the pressure stress to
perform to be the good good student good
sailor so when you check in the teams
like that's that what they tell us too
you remember like get your Best Uniform
you have you present yourself in
professional sales way and that's what I
did I just pressed my spent all this
weekend pressing my uniform you know
make sure this is perfect as everything
is shiny and and cool I show up on the
quarter attack and uh
it's like okay oh they introduced me to
a CEO a master chief I went through this
initial tank and then I said you go to
the back to the back door up there and
get your go to get your gear issue and
all that stuff so well I did that but I
didn't make it to the the issue thing
because the old seals caught me and uh
so you know I already knew there's going
to be some harassment so I was kind of
prepared for it yeah but not for that
you say as soon as I was outside of the
CMC and walking through the compound
I'll stop by other seals told to jump on
the pull-up bars and keep doing pull-ups
until Toad the Dismount from the pull-up
bars from there things got fast and
painful after pull-ups I was yelled at
to lay down do sit-ups and push-ups and
I was ushered out of the Seal team
through the back gate marched the
starting point of a three mile tent run
testing route and told to complete the
run in the required time mind you I was
still wearing my dress blues uniform and
perfectly Polished Shoes by the time the
older seals finished with me uh my
awesome uniform looked like sweats for
playing basketball
well you can imagine now too so uh so
here it is on the base right it's normal
traffic that people go over there where
we run those three miles round it was
along the road where yeah people drive
all the time when they move so can you
imagine the dude with the white hat you
know with the with this white long pants
and and the shiny boots and stuff and
and and the the the the the sky the the
neckerchief the neckerchief the flap on
the back flopping around and you run
like crazy so there's like what happened
this guy just lost his mind or something
so yeah yeah that was that was my
welcome to the teams
I kind of expected to be funny things
yeah happening to new guys here's
another good one one Friday the older
guys invited us fngs to join them for a
kegger as a new guy I was impressed I
thought that I thought there was genuine
interest in team building we're all
looking forward to the end of the day
honestly I remember thinking oh wow
these older experienced seals are
inviting us to join him for beers how
awesome whoa yeah
we felt like the popular kids it just
invited us to sit with them at lunch I
quickly learned however that we weren't
there to build the camaraderie or hang
out with the popular kids we were there
for the amusement of the veteran seals
this was them giving us an old school
Navy welcome the cool old guys jumped us
and bound our feet with riggers tape
they hung us from the high Bay ceiling
with cranes and chain lifts of course
there were more than a few punches
thrown throughout to minimize our
resistance to their welcome we soon
found ourselves hanging from the ceiling
like big grumpy bats every once in a
while we were lowered down from the
ceiling for a swig of beer or another
beating or to be laughed at when our
faces changed another shade of red we
weren't back on our feet until the
kegger was over while this ritual might
be considered hazing by Outsiders it was
meant to be a kind of testing ground for
the new guys we had to prove we were
tough enough to be trusted in any
situation today there are no longer
kegger Fridays in the SEAL Teams and no
alcohol is allowed in the compound very
strict policies regarding alcohol are
now in place the old welcome to the
teams has been softened and put under
control so the new welcome procedures
are not mistaken for hazing there are
very strict policies in place regarding
any welcome events but at that time it
was all good to go yeah you know and I I
think there was there was nothing wrong
with that
um uh they say that some people got hurt
but I think that mostly their feelings
get hurt but you know if you have to
have a thick skin in teams so for me
kind of like you know I just roll with
the punch I say that's this guy's not
gonna kill me at least I hope not and
there's going to be fine so I put up
with it and uh eventually you know they
move on to somebody else I mean so you
you do deployment then you are dishing
out this kind of hazing stuff so there
were funny things too you know like when
I was already I wasn't a new guy anymore
I was a
Seasons here so we had a new guys coming
to the Seal team too and we did the
spiral exercises you know just the the
hero comes in drop the ropes you hook
yourself to the rope and then takes off
with like five six guys hanging hanging
on the road and so we just talked to the
pilot and say no well it's just like
when you fly over this pound up there
why don't you just dip these guys in it
and so it's like mine is like December
in Virginia Beach them called and it was
not for things no it was not frozen yet
so yeah we just threw the hill the hill
came there's new guys in it
so you know things like that happen but
then again it makes you harder there's
like nobody gets hurt yeah maybe a lot
of feelings got hurt and I know these
people who whose feelings got hurt they
no longer they didn't spend a lot of
time in the SEAL Teams yeah you know uh
I always felt like the guys that didn't
as a matter of fact when when I was in
platoons like if if you didn't like a
guy or if you really wanted to kick him
out of the teams then they wouldn't get
hazed they would just get like
ostracized so amazing was kind of like
or whatever you want to call it I guess
you can't call it hazing but whatever
this is called hazing welcome to the
teams yeah this this stuff was kind of
just for fun I do know that there were
sometimes there was there were some
times where it got out of control
excessive yes and I was like yeah that's
over the line and so the problem is I
think instead of saying like okay here's
and look it's you can't be like hey
here's the rules yeah this is how you
Haze the guy yeah
but you know they could have put some
kind of parameters on it it was also
good because
man it was it's humbling right like
you're new now you're showing up you if
you're a wise ass or you think you're
you think you're the greatest thing in
the world you don't think that when you
get to the team and you see what's going
on yeah not for very long for about
seven minutes before you're getting
you're getting squared away uh yeah so I
think it was a cultural thing
um
and you know I mean I know you've got in
here that it there's official
regulations again it said I don't know
necessarily that it's that there's not
clandestine welcomes going on
but but yeah you know I I think like
anything if it's taken to an extreme
then it gets dumb but there was
something really positive to it too
um
you know there was a thing I watched
this documentary about
hockey and there's a there's a player in
hockey called The Enforcer and the
enforcer literally just beats people up
and he beats people up that do things
that aren't okay in hockey they're not
illegal in hockey but they're not okay
for instance there's like a star player
yeah and someone would Blindside hit the
star player the star players out there
he's he's a skilled guy he's focused on
scoring goals and all of a sudden
someone would Blindside hit the star
player although the enforcer would come
out and freaking beat the out of
that guy and so what happened was
there's actually balance and people go
yeah I don't want to do that because
then I'll get the beat out of me by
the enforcer so there's what there is is
respect
and so I think you know in the SEAL
Teams there was respect because you
didn't want to get the beat out of
you yeah and guess what a force you do
first you listen first you pay attention
so you know again if it gets out of hand
obviously it can get stupid but it was a
good way of me when I was 19 years old
checking into a Seal Team thinking I was
a badass a good way to be like Oh I'm
not a badass I'm just a dude and I need
to get on board with the program cool
got it got it yeah so you know it's it's
humbling and it's good
um oh this is the way I look at it too
it never it never hurt me physically or
mentally it was just making me kind of
like
I thought it was funny yeah
it was painful no I didn't laugh all the
time but but but but it was kind of like
accepted it's no that this is the way it
is yeah and and it doesn't make me
wicked it doesn't make me it makes me
just better tougher guys yeah yeah I'm
fine and it's a little camaraderie you
know it's a little classic because after
after the beating we used to drink
together yeah let's go
uh so you end up you go to seal tactical
training
stt this is back when we did it at the
team yeah
um this was funny you didn't have your
freaking clearance yet oh yeah yeah that
that was kind of like I I knew that you
need this it's something like a
clearance but apparently never but
nobody ever asked me about it so I
thought maybe this is something I've
misread didn't understand well so we
went through entire stt course and uh
the uh and the phase when you do the
radio communication and cryptography
when you learn how to crypto encrypt
messages decrypt them and work with this
secret equipment so we went through
entire course me and another guy is
catalinton Scotty if you hear it
yeah so so me and Scotty they're sitting
in the in the bench like day before the
FTX the final exercise then we need to
like like an exam from the crypto that
stuff so we are all ready we can take
the test the instructor comes in so like
hey uh
it just comes to me it's like
do you have a clearance I mean like what
Clarence like secret clearance it's like
I don't know never heard of it I mean I
never heard them nobody asked me that
before
okay do you have a clearance to scatter
Linton right do you have a clearance
it's like I don't think so I'm not a U.S
citizen
so Scotty Linton was somehow he's born
in England or something yeah yeah yeah
and then he moved here when he was like
10 or something like that but he still
had a little bit of an accent yeah he
spoke with an accent he's a great guy
you know yeah for sure but it's the fact
that no one picked up on it and said
like hey bro where are you from because
he was clearly not from America the way
he talks yeah uh yeah yeah I love Scotty
so we he just pulled us out and say come
on with me and he was one of the shaken
at the instructor I don't remember his
name but it's like okay this was going
to happen
never ever say to anybody that you even
seen this course you have not been here
understood
okay you're gonna get your clearance
you're gonna pass this test again it's
easy for you guys because you already
went through this course anyway just
don't don't say to anybody yeah and and
we came back and uh eventually for me
because my background the the Credence
took longer time but it came in I went
and took the test in the RadioShack
upstairs and passed it Scotty Linton
actually whoever went to his citizenship
ceremony here we have Citizen First
before he could uh so if you can say
this get his clearance and we deploy to
uh to to Bosnia coming to uh Italy at
the time yeah well I mean you had first
you had to go
um go through like you used to have a
probationary period in the teams yeah
and you say this after probationary
period passing the seal board made up of
Chiefs and officers we awarded the the
seal Trident in the morning master in
front of the entire
entirety of Seal Team two we were called
up front and center and we're presented
with the coveted tridents in the
presence of Admiral Joseph McGuire he's
an admiral uh today back then he was a
commander yeah it was a great milestone
in my life it was a great moment but it
also made me reflect on many things it
was crystallizing in my mind that this
could only happen in America such an
exceptional country only in America is
it possible to come without even knowing
the language and carrying only a bag of
clothes and still succeed through hard
work and determination as much as I was
proud of my seal Trident there was an
even greater honor that was bestowed on
me before it was American citizenship
the citizenship and American flag
encompassed the Trident I was a trident
wearer because I was an American
boom you see this is why like I don't
wear a trident
once I'm out of uniform now when I'm
already civilian uh people do and they
can they deserve they earn this thing
but our American flag because this
encompasses everything it does
encompasses the Trident so me wearing
the Trident is like a distraction to my
American flag that I work so this is
this is what is important this is what
what what drives me and yes there's
people say congratulate me of being a
seal making to the Seal training and
being a you know good operator but
that's not my biggest accomplishment
that's my biggest
accomplishment my biggest thing that I
ever did is become American and not only
through just through the ceremony but
also thinking like American and bringing
my heart American so this is something
that I'm very proud of that's the
proudest thing
uh like you just mentioned two months
after I received my Trident and
officially became a seal we deployed to
Italy and
um
this was cool soon after we landed in
Italy we were sent on a mission to find
and if possible rescue a down pilot from
Behind Enemy Lines an American pilot had
been forced to eject from his plane then
to survive a week in his own hostel on
his own in hostile territory before he
was rescued seals were among those sent
to look for him at this point the full
realization it was real now hit me
I was no longer in training there are so
many safety nets and training precisely
to make sure that students don't get
injured during the training however
these safeguards are no longer there
during missions and you must rely on
your training and your teammates to
reduce the chance of injury and to
ensure Mission success from the moment I
first checked into Seal Team 2 it dawned
on me that every day we were doing
something that could kill us training
obstacle courses parachuting diving
swimming the open ocean I remember
during one of the flights over the
Adriatic looking for the down pilot one
of my teammates Scott was sitting on the
edge of the helicopter's ramp legs
dangling with his head leaning out of
the Helo he had a safety belt on him to
keep from falling out but at one point
it slipped off by some freak accident he
was sitting on the edge of the ramp with
a safety belt unbuckled laying behind
him Bill walked back to Scott yeah bro
right on grabbed him and pulled him away
from the ramp inside the Hilo we're
afraid that if we yelled the Scott he
would move and fall off the ramp that
would be tragic it was narrow escapes
like at that reminded us we weren't
training anymore and it happened it
actually did happen in serial team too
later on and in Bosnia we lost guy like
this fell out the helicopter and with
Scott yeah those uh there was Scotty
Linton actually it was still there yeah
it was scary so he was sitting training
with his uh a sniper rifle and um
uh you know these belts that we have
they had there's like a buckle that you
can just sometimes touch that catches it
and just comes off this whole belt comes
off so when we look at this he's sitting
like on the ramp he's uh on 53 his legs
are dangling he's just like leaning here
that's tweaking with his gun if we call
him he would just stand if he turned
around he'll lose his balance it was
like he just fell off it and so uh Bill
white actually he just we look at it
like in horror so building sort of
saying anything he just kind of just
grabbed him by his by the neck by his
shoulders and just drag him inside he
was like what the but it's like
dude you almost died and he will show
him the belt yeah yeah he had no
problems being manhandled but but yeah
there was things like that happen you
know and and this is why it did down on
me that those safety nets that we had
always have in their training in the
initial training they're no longer there
the balls of the wall
um you you tell other stories in here
get the book to to get the rest of these
stories you come back from that
deployment
and you know when you come back from
your deployments uh in the SEAL Teams
adapt to your opportunity to about six
months you can go to different schools
and whatnot so people put in for Sniper
school and preacher school and J
tactical just put in for a bunch of
different schools to get more skills uh
you say here I was assigned to English
101 school on base in Little Creek these
guys would pass me a Navy buses on the
street on their way to their respective
schools they would shout hey drongo
where are you going I'd hold up my heavy
textbook I'm going to English class
yeah so you know they they seen
something in me something promising that
instead of counting me from the
teams uh because my English was not that
good I mean it was was good enough to
mask to cover it but I still have to
listen to you translate in Polish then
translate in English and tell an answer
to you I was quick with it so nobody
caught it but it took me a long time so
that English class whoever uh made the
decision to send me there actually
helped me a lot and make me allow me to
continue with my career so yeah that I
was like that was my my I was not even
upset about it I was like saying
anything to make me a better sale if my
English is lacking I will fix it and I
did were you an aw in your first platoon
machine gunner what'd you do yeah
I was like for triple tons so I I loved
it you know it was like it was heavy but
you carry the heavy steak so when you
unload it when you open up everybody
knows that you are online yeah I love
that hell yeah uh second deployment you
go Germany and Bosnia
um yeah and what's cool about this you
mentioned this uh the biggest influence
on me in my seal career the guy I always
wanted to emulate with
and that's his first name
was a great leader yeah Not only was one
of the toughest he was also dedicated to
making us the best seal operators there
were I swear the guide never slept he
was always trying to think of ways to
make the platoon harder better and
stronger his knowledge and expertise
were legendary especially in Winter and
Arctic Warfare he taught us how to ice
climb ski navigate Arctic environments
everything nobody else in Seal Team 2
knows much new as much as
who in his late 30s was also older than
most seals about that stuff legendary
guy a legendary guy I can say his name I
think now I hope he doesn't mind me that
but uh you know if he does we can always
cut it out well let's just not say
because I don't want to I know he still
does different you know he still does
various things yeah but I think he knows
who he is and he is the guy he
definitely knows who he is yeah I mean
he knows
yeah yeah so he this is the guy I was
trying to emulate always and to the
point that even like with Rob O'Neill
dude that thing's so easy when you do
this stuff it looks so easy how did you
get to this actually I'm just I'm just
trying to be like my chief
and try to emulate him he was the but
you know what there was not only the
toughness of him of his uh I mean the
guy was
some of the guys in the Seal team to the
training Cadre he thought he's unhinged
they even came to us and say you know
what we we can catch you we can
regardless what your Chief wants we can
put you back in the buttocks because he
did not allow us to sleep in the
barracks we go to Barracks only for the
weekend we slept in the winter time in
in the winter time slip on the Range it
was sleeping bag baby bags and
everything in the we're on the Range
Minnesota we slept on the Range so uh
he was a
he was he was that guy but not only that
you can tell this guy hard he always
knew he always asked if he how you are
doing how can he help you and in the
platoon so like time we stopped you know
we have these breaks a little bit we set
the perimeter he was always there how
are you doing is everything okay there's
anything you need are you okay
everything's fine yeah so he was he
always makes sure that each one of us is
fully ready for the next thing and stuff
and it was such a
pronounce that I tore myself from this
person I want to be like him I want to
be like him and uh and that's that's
what I tried I failed many times I was
there's the caliber of people that you
can't sometimes emulate yeah and and
just the universal respect from
everybody knows who he is yes and he
just freaking loved the teams he cared
about the teams and when you've got a
guy like that like it's just awesome and
I never actually worked with him I only
would like I I but you know it's a
conference or we'd be at something and
so I'd get to talk to him but uh yeah
ever ever just just uh awesome
reputation and it's cool that that this
is what carries you know the officer in
our platin 2 bill again this is thing I
wanted to call him I just collect
reconnected with him uh I just didn't
have a chance to ask him about it to
bring his son I will not use his name
but he knows who he is he was the OIC of
that platoon bill he's uh he's very
successful now and in civilian life but
so these are these officers that I was
so lucky to to work for them you know
like I never had bad officer you know
all of you guys I work with it was just
like fantastic I was extremely lucky
because you know sometimes you have
officers you might not may like less or
you don't like but I never had officer
that I I would not uh I would think less
of him because there were just every I
always above the cut
every the officer I work with so I was
very lucky yeah that is lucky that's
awesome yeah that's awesome
um
so you get done with that platoon and
then you go into your third deployment
which is Bahrain and this is when you
and me were together and what the team
was what what were we foxtrot or we Echo
what platoon were we do you remember uh
echo echo so that's where we were Seal
Team two Echo platoon no no no no that
was the uh I'm sorry that was a thing
was it might have been foxtrot
maybe you see like I I was not putting
this in the books because I tried to
avoid this uh you know not to give away
too much like what the SEAL Teams what
how many combat missions so nobody can
figure out the Up Tempo or stuff like
this so I try to keep it away from the
books is that bad operational security I
just broke by it by not knowing my uncle
too
I guess no one learned anything because
I don't even know it I'm kind of like
Stoner I can't give you the information
because I don't know it
you know there is so many plateaus you
do yeah that's just plants yeah uh so we
do we get in a platoon together which
was freaking
um oh yeah really fun the dead was when
you know this is when I met you first
time yeah and God I remember that was
that this is the first time when I see
you actually we end up doing the the
swim the the quail swing qualification
dive oh yeah yeah so I'm just like I
look at you because I was we are paired
up so it was three month pair okay and I
look at you and it's like well that guy
is Big so he ain't going to swim that
fast I think I'm good because I was
never a fast swimmer I can swim long but
not fast
and so it just give me the buoy and I
said I'll swing with the buoy
and uh so then it's like for a while I'm
doing okay but then I feel my dragons
getting hot but hey it's like I
can't I can't keep up like this
so I'm kicking my ass if I look at this
guy next to his three-man pair swim he's
already in our toe you just throwing two
guys and suddenly I was the same thing
and so we swim there and back and I was
like that's that's a big guy but
that guy's an animal so so yeah so that
that was right there the respects like
I thought I'm good but not that
good we are our awesome platoon we had a
we had like a condensed work up if I
remember like we didn't have we just as
soon as we formed up we were in work up
yeah there was that yeah there was a
first strike platoon too so they were
like in the rush I think to put us out
yeah so we did it we we didn't have any
like what they call Pro Dev phase where
you're kind of going to schools the
thing I just talked about where you're
going to schools no one went to schools
everyone's just like boom we were in a
platoon and we were automatically going
to work up and that was um fun I know I
was trying to get people to train Jiu
Jitsu that's that's that's that's the
thing that the welcome to the platoon
that's like the guys like I was like
Jiu-Jitsu I didn't know much about Jiu
Jitsu I didn't even know I thought it
was like a judo or something and your
first thing was you just came back you
look at the platoon so I'm going to
check out the entire platoon in 10
minutes so we were just laughing I was
like uh yeah either like we didn't know
who you were so so by the first two
three guys stepping out or pass out and
the other thing that I remember like
most of the guys just they lay on the
back and we are shaking their legs and
bring them back to Consciousness you
know so so that was the case and then I
can see like a couple guys like well I I
need to do something I'll be right back
and just to run the errands like they
never came back but yeah this entire
platoon including myself would choke out
and that's another thing you know it's
like then I was fascinated I want
to learn that I I want to be that good
so this is how we actually we start
doing the Jujitsu in there yeah yeah you
have a little note a little story in
here you you were uh we were doing some
Jiu Jitsu in the platoon I was kind of
kind of coaching and watching you guys
yeah yeah yeah and um here I'm like
yelling uh Drago man you gotta let him
go let go man he tapped out while while
choking him even harder I started
arguing that he was not tapping out yeah
yeah I did not feel or nor hear any
tapping they had to pry him out of my
grip I released my sparring partner
confused he didn't tap out I told them
yeah he did Jocko said while laughing
did you hear that sound I said what was
that my sparring partner eventually
caught his breath dude you had me so
pinned down that I couldn't even move a
finger I was trying to say tap tap tap
but I didn't have enough air and the
only thing that came out was tits before
passing out I immediately apologized I
felt awful well maybe a little uh yeah
actually I reconnected with Scott so I
was after that that was just recently
yeah oh yeah yeah
no I know the other side yeah I talked
to him the other day too I traded some
tax with him yeah who was he would get
he would get so mad doing Jiu Jitsu he
would get he would get uh what's the
word he'll get personally mad at me he I
would be rolling with him and like
he would he would I would just be a
cross side or something on him and he
would just tap out he'd be like church
girl just get off me man
that's not cool the is this stuff
he would be mad at me like literally mad
at me and then like five minutes later
he'd be like dude I suck or whatever but
and the moment of of claustrophobia he
would get freaking mad yeah but you know
this is a typical team guy yeah stuff
you know aggressive guy
to pass out so just get mad you
cannot get scared get mad so he was and
uh the Jujitsu was not working for him
well but but I like Scott he was crazy
he's so funny he would say the funniest
stuff he would um he had this voice that
he'd use like he'd say ice cream Sammy
he'd be like let's go get an ice cream
that's because I am an app
I think he played some kind of like
college I don't even know what sport but
he was definitely a really good app yeah
I might respect to Scott yeah oh yeah
but funny as hell funny he had this
story where they were in Sniper School
and they were going through the drill
Kim's keep in mind right so you got to
look out at the field and you got to
find stuff yeah
and so there was a guy that was going
through sniper school with him that they
didn't really like this guy I guess he
was kind of arrogant he's kind of an
and he was pretty good pretty
doing pretty good in the school so
they're all on the line and they have to
look out into the field and find you
know they have like a canteen and
they'll have a notebook and they'll have
this at a bullet casing and so you got
to find as many things as you can so all
the guys are on the line
and they cheat and they kind of tell
each other like yo there's a you know
Canteen at 120 yards and then like it's
building so they all cheat
and they but they didn't tell the other
guy and so they all write down and you
had to find like 10 items
and so they all turned in their pieces
of paper they all have 10 items
instructors are like yeah and they and
they're like hey yup everyone did pretty
good one guy failed
um and they could tell it was him the
guy that they didn't like it was him
because he was like his face turned red
he's all mad
and Scotty Scotty goes there walking
back to the to the freaking buses or to
the trucks or whatever
and as they're walking back
Scotty's talking to that guy and he goes
I'll tell you what you got to be a real
piece of to fail that
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
didn't work out with me because this is
where I got my dragon nickname and he
was like why don't I get a cool nickname
like that and then you came up with the
nickname for for Steve but he was such a
quick wit and such a funny guy and Robin
of course I mean that was just like
comedy show yeah I have never laughed so
hard maybe in prison a little bit but
even not in prison as I was laughing in
this Plateau that was the funniest group
of people I ever been with it was fun
um I had I was we were out at some bar
and something happened with Rob where he
left right and some girl comes up to me
I don't know where this came I don't
know where this came from this girl
comes up to me and she goes hey do you
know that guy's Sloan and I'm like I go
I go uh and I have no idea I don't know
anybody so she goes you know that guy
named Sloan and I go yeah I go I think
so what does he look like she was like
oh you know he's kind of like a little
taller he's got red hair and I'm like
it's got to be a meal because there's
the only like red hair dude I know and
I'm like yeah no she goes where'd he go
and I I'm like he went back to our our
house right Barracks I'll take you so we
like I get and I I bang on on O'Neill's
door and he's passed out and I'm like
hey bro I got you something I'm like I
go hey Sloan and he's like
okay this is uh I forget you know
whatever her name was yeah she was
looking for you and he's like oh thanks
he's and he was passed out so he was
just like looking at me all
[Music]
that's the platoon you got the nickname
Drago yeah yeah and that's from Tony
Tony G that's what Tony gave you from
Tony yeah yeah yeah those were not beat
up on the uh uh uh Shad you know but uh
the the new guy who's a new guy oh yeah
yeah that's a that was a so-called new
Drago yeah yeah because well he was just
saved and cubby came into me and say hey
uh why why did you do that why did you
just did it to him
yeah he was new guy who was mouthing off
a great guy here's the funniest you know
there's the whole entire platoon it was
like a comedian show you remember the
time in Fallon when we went to patrol
and the so we trained the the reaction
to Ambush right so the up Force came to
believe us this is how you go you go
this way this way who will Ambush
somewhere they want to see your response
how you acted so so we are getting we
the guys left so now we are you know
lining up for patrol and and it's like
what a shot
uh
I don't know Shad Shad I said come radio
hey are you guys missing the the up
force that the guys were supposed to
attack us are you missing the guy
yeah we are missing shad
there's a walking behind us
and patrolling passing us the signals
and all that and the he's he's like
he's acting like real security there's
that guy said yeah it's got to be that
guy so basically he went with the up
force and this guy was just slowly
getting just walking you know talking
and planning the Ambush on us and this
guy was patrolling behind him passing
them to sing I was like yeah it's good
you know it's going with the car
yeah Tony G what was pissed me off about
him is he was like this little guy kind
of like a little bit Stout a little
round by the PowerHouse but he was
stronger than me and faster than me he
would freaking out bench me and could
run fast me it was freaking annoying
Tony G I know you're out there bro it
always pissed me off I never let it show
of course but I'd always be like God
damn dude he's fast and strong yeah and
just unassuming looking and super
squared away across the board yes I was
using my buds class too he's an awesome
guy yes I miss him yeah yeah for sure uh
so yeah we also on that on that
deployment we we did a cool we did like
what at the time seemed like a pretty
cool Mission taking down uh that one big
oil vessel if I'll go left to vulgar
neft 147. yeah that was actually finally
started too you know he's like for for
at that time you know that we were not
at the war so that was the first time
like first leader life mentioned that we
actually went and hijacked the the
foreign ship so we just we we uh uh and
I remember we remember they move us from
the carrier on the uh on the Destroyer
uh and then from Hilo we just launched
our assault yeah on the on that on the
tanker and Robin
was there too and so I wrote some hey
Dragon let's go we need to go so we
already prepared so we just dress up
kitab and and go so we took down the
remember we had a very limited time to
do it because uh they were they knew
that we are watching them so they were
skidding the territorial Waters of other
countries so we had like three minutes
to take it down because otherwise we had
to jump off the ship Not to cause
international incident like the U.S
armed forces are getting somebody's own
territory so we need to be quick
and we faster on the chef we took it
down very quick and we had like three
Russian speakers I was speaking yeah Mr
F I don't know if I can say his name
he speak and Rob spoke Russia it was
crazy because like seals don't we suck
at languages and like the Special Forces
they go to language school that's part
of their pipeline in the SEAL Teams like
generally speaking guys don't really
guys don't really know a lot of
languages and all that and for whatever
reason we killed people we don't speak
to them so for whatever reason in this
platoon we happen to have our platoon
commander who had studied Russian in
college and then gone and done a
semester in Moscow or something crazy we
had a Berkeley hippie that studied
Russian in freaking college and so he
spoke Russian and then you were forced
to speak Russian by these communist
bastards yeah yeah so we have out of 16
guys we had three freaking really good
Russian speakers and we went down to
take take down this Russian chip that
was awesome yeah yeah I remember too so
I could hear and so Mr F could hear too
that the the captain yeah yeah don't
obey him don't obey Americans resist
what you can don't do anything and Mr
Dragon just take this guy out explain to
him so he's wrapping by the scarf
walking him up there was a chimney and I
was like opening this the size maybe of
the briefcase like a bigger brick case
or suitcase so I told him you know you
you open your mouth one more time I'm
going to squash you in it I will fit you
in it and you'll spend the rest of the
travel in this chimney right there so
let's look at this chimney I just said
that in Russian to him yeah and then he
says like okay I won't say anything and
then we're just like him having that
thing but you remember the funny things
with it when we searched the ship right
because we were the initial team to the
the group that took it down so after we
hijacked it it was already on our
control we moved out and other Squad
came in the the other sales our sales
came in and then we changed them again
we're like rotating so when they coming
back you remember they came out with a
big bag for clunking
dudes you just failed you just left all
these weapons all that stuff and it's
like damn that's not good how did you
leave all these weapons what it is and I
haven't seen so he opened the back
there's a butter knives and
forks and spoons in it there's like dude
they're me and then
they were trying to make us like we had
missed these weapons that could be used
and he's like hey you guys you guys
missed some weapons over there I'm like
oh and then you lose yeah that's
right
so and he just didn't mind those axes
hanging up there on the door you just
started butter knives and forks and
these axes are still hanging there yeah
they had like damage control fire axles
like hey what about those freaking
straight up axes that they got sitting
over there that wasn't a threat they
were like
oh yeah but you know the funny thing is
that then when we exchange again we came
back these Russians they knew I speak
Russian so they came to me and said like
please how about so we we need our force
and knives and a spoons back
I said like why would you need the back
you know
can you eat with your hands it's like no
we can we don't have teeth and they open
their mouth and I tell you so all these
women and and young guys
everyone is missing so many teeth that
they want to be even one side of one
full set of teeth among all of them they
were just over there coming out on
something yeah you remember I came to
you and say like this is what they asked
and they can't eat that they don't have
teeth so we say okay so you you eat all
you tell these guys to bring the the
forks and butter and the butter knives
back we'll we'll mitigate the threat but
they were so grateful that they didn't
cause any problems after that you know
they were just happy they were greeting
us thank you for the knives and farts
you know they every time they eat it
like we wrote it when I was passing by
it's like they were shaking their
efforts and I was like thank you it's
possible as possible yeah yeah an apple
tuner I just remember you're talking
about the first uh Squad going on there
and we were trying to get as big as
humanly possible and so we wanted the
average platoon weight to be over 200
pounds and we had some smaller guys too
that were in there and we signed up for
them yeah we made up for them I got to I
got to 250. so when we left for
deployment I was like 247.
and we the first place we went on
deployment was Spain and they had an
all-you we stayed at some
all-you-can-eat buffet hotel and I was
like oh I got this and so for like three
four days I just dead lifted and ate and
uh I got to 250 and I was like cool I'm
going on a Four Mile time drawn and I
was like all right I need to lose some
damn weight boy but yeah we all did yeah
we were all freaking jacked yeah yeah
but you know they were so awesome
because you opened the we went to Rota
right I think it was in Spain yeah
whatever we were up there uh that that
place where we stay we just opened the
door that the resort you step on the
beach yeah and there's maybe like maybe
20 yards as the ocean so the the
Atlantic so that was such a great trip
there were so many good things you
remember it went also to see the uh uh
uh
the Indiana Jones
experiments
in the pyramids too yeah but I was not
fascinated by the pyramids because like
I remember they uh those people were
just coming they're just like Mr Mister
here is yours here is your we give you
the the Arab Garb you know that that
that that that what you call this I
don't know what you put on your head
right here
and they just give it to you but then
they start giving the money give me the
money you know you need to pay for it so
it's like well like where are you from
it's like I'm from Bangladesh and so
they're like oh Bangladesh okay from
Kenya so like leave me alone so they
they wouldn't have something to ask
somebody else
do you remember when we got to Rhoda the
other platoon I don't know what team
they were from I think I might have been
from Team two those team two yeah and
freaking tiny was there
yeah we were rushing the medicine for
him because he was like out of medicine
and was in such a pain that we just need
to do something the first thing we did I
remember just break away from the
platoon around to time is Tiny here it
is here take some shots so God he had he
had a horn
that was from uh I don't know about Brad
actually acquired it also Brad had a
cold of Satan yes it was the horn of
Satan if you drink from it you get in
trouble
yeah and I remember tiny was just like
drinking prolifically from the Horn of
Satan yes yes yes and by the way Brad he
didn't need any extra help finding Satan
no but the funny things they're like so
we barely made it like two days later
the entire platoon is being cut out say
anybody see this and this guy whipping
out the genitals on the table in front
of two Lieutenant females it was like no
we didn't like okay so there's a full
investigation it's like who did that
there was there was not us that was not
us but but uh but yeah that was like
first thing the whole platoon had the
gun uh and and and and and and they were
suspect yeah yeah they knew who it was I
know who it was we know who it was but
you know there was like a
it was like
even though
those are so funny so they were just
laughing at our asses over the way it
happened that
um yeah
well that's what you get when you when
you hang out with people from other
military branches sometimes these things
happen
um all right next here
you go so we get down with that
deployment uh Good Times uh like pretty
like it was pretty cool we got to do so
we got to do other like little
vessels inside the Persian Gulf we track
those things down and board those things
so we were actually doing work which was
kind of nice because it was the 90s and
there wasn't much work to be done
yeah um yeah you get home from that
deployment and you immediately and a
bunch of guys immediately get reassigned
to Seal Team Four yeah well actually
where to sign even while on deployment
on the way back we we came back as a
13-4 so so that's uh so me Rob a couple
other guys few other guys but it wasn't
like not the big deal like my family was
already defining a part and I was all I
need to do is just grab my kid
click the bikes and move from one
building to another so there was an
entire move you know PCS move yeah I
mean you say you say in the book here
what was waiting for me when I got back
home though wasn't great my marriage had
fallen apart while I was overseas it's
no secret that life as a Navy SEAL put
serious strain on your personal life
family and marriage my life was no
different than my seagull teammates
most of our time is divided up with six
months or more of platoon work up than
six month deployments overseas there's
never really any time at home once the
divorce was Final I lost my home along
with my family I was financially broken
too without the structure and
distraction of being deployed I was
getting myself into a lot of trouble
back in Virginia Beach eventually I
ended up in a new platoon doing another
pre-deployment work up our deployment
was scheduled to Puerto Rico that was
our launch pad I REM I returned to the
only place I knew I could trust the
people I was with my fellow seals who
would like my family to me and whom I
knew better than my real brother that's
true yeah that's that's how it is in the
teams you know it you know these guys
you know the guys next to you better
than you know your family and if people
say that this is uh well this is not
good but I you know what at that time
uh that's all I had there was all the
only family I had and that was great you
know there was kind of compensate for my
you know my son my uh I hardly got to
know him uh during all these things so
we we are missing a lot and I didn't
understand how much I lost
how much I didn't see my son growing up
until eventually after the Navy I had my
children where I could actually observe
and observe them every day be with them
every day this is when I realized how
much time I lost with my son with my
first son and it still bothers me
often but yeah that's the way there's
life it is in the SEAL Teams yeah you
know when uh when you and I
when I left for Iraq when you and I were
in Iraq yeah when I left for Iraq on my
first deployment my son couldn't crawl
when I left when I got home he was
walking and then you go again on the
trip then everything you come back is
the guy the little baby you already do
more and more and more yeah so like for
me my son was always a baby even he was
big he was still baby because this is
how I remember him and it is not good
it's not good for our family but
sometimes you just cannot change things
you cannot be there when you need to be
there and uh and I also tell I tell I've
told many guys this over the years like
men have been leaving
for the entire existence of humanity men
used to go and hunt and they'd go on
hunting trips and uh then we were going
on sailing ships around the world then
we were going to fight Wars like this is
nothing new that we are doing and it's
not that you can get through it you can
you can get through it but it's gonna be
freaking hard and it's gonna take a toll
you know yeah um
but this is nor it's kind of normal
right that
if you were around in the freaking
1700s or 1800s your dad might be going
on a ship and might not be coming back
for a year and a half two years you know
that these things happen
yeah
they're going on deployments for three
years you know like that's the way it
goes
um but I can tell you like
I was talking to life the other day my
buddy Leif who well you know life and
yeah you know he he
he has kids now young kids and he he's
just like I don't know how you did this
because he's not in the mode of being in
a platoon going on deployment being in a
platoon going on that's so normal to us
it was so normal to me I I didn't
understand what it would be like to do
something yeah I didn't see any
difference yeah how different could that
be that's just that's the way the life
is yeah that's the way life is this way
me and all my friends this is all we do
we go on platoons we go on the plane
we're going to planes going deployment
that's what we do so everyone has kids
they're going on deployment they're like
goodbye kids we're going on a point yeah
uh and and like like what you're saying
life now looks and he's like man I don't
know how you just
we're able to just go on freaking six
month deployments another six month
deployment another six month deployment
and freaking to the wives like they're
they're they're having to hold down the
fort freaking minutes it's a rough tour
yeah my wife was you know at home with
three kids and just holding it down
right and just not ever asking me a damn
thing you know she didn't even barely
knew you know what I look like anymore
after a while she was just like yeah
where's my paycheck
um but it's hard you know and it's it
can be very hard
um
the family usually the one with that
pays the biggest toll because then uh it
does the the divorce ratio is just
incredible 90 because there is no way to
hold the marriage in in family when you
constantly go on and come back just for
a little and gone and gone and gone yeah
it's it's definitely very brutal uh for
families and
the the guys in the teams myself
included like if you have to choose
between
the teams and the family you choose the
family so you choose the teams you're
like the team you're like oh we got you
know your daughter's got a recital
tonight yeah cool but I've gotta go do
this training Mission yeah oh your your
son's got his first freaking wrestling
match yeah I've got a knight hit down
and then whatever and so that's just the
way it goes it's not how you can say
well you know I will skip this training
or I'm not going to go with you guys
because I have my my kid has something
to do that's that's something that uh we
know we accepted it yeah and uh I hope
maybe people understand and give us a
little bit of leeway that we are less
than perfect fathers and husbands when
it happens I mean I mean by not being
there where we need to be there but you
know this is the way uh because the
school teams and that's the some is that
sacrifice is needed because we need to
protect America and our citizens to live
safe and this is why you know that
sometimes what I like to do now is I go
sometime times on the street or to the
park I sit down I watch these people I
just look at them and they have like
careless that think nothing about the
war nothing about what's going on they
just in love you know there's a couple
going on and kissing and and talking
there's all their people couple walking
and and talking and it makes me feel so
good because it tells me that we do a
good job to protect these people that
they don't have to look over their
shoulders they don't have to look into
for being unsafe or being our country
being over
destroyed by somebody so so it makes me
feel really good you know I was just
like yes that's that's I was part of it
so part of that protective segment of
society that these people can leave and
don't have to worry about the war about
anything else and this is how it's
supposed to be yeah this is how Society
is supposed to leave that with without
fear for the war yeah and and even right
now with no war going on what we just
talked about there's
people in the military right now that
are missing everything with their family
because they're on deployment somewhere
there's no war going on but they're
still putting stress on their family
they're still missing their kids
birthdays they're still missing the
graduations that's what that's what
they're doing right now and there's no
war going on right now but that's what's
happening but there's no work going on
because these people are there exactly
including myself now in my family since
I'm no longer with military but we've
yeah we sympathize with these families
and with these guys yeah it is uh it is
definitely to to think about that bubble
of protection when you're at the park
watching these people and they don't
even think about it yeah and that makes
me feel good you know be like you're
cool yeah yeah I mean I really enjoy
that now going to the stores go to the
mall where people like really enjoy
their lives I say this is what we
provide that safety that so so they can
do that our citizens can because there's
violent people standing on and guarding
their lifestyle our lifestyle and and
the way the America is so it really
makes me feel good it's a good thing so
when when you were scheduled to go to
Puerto Rico when did September 11th
happen where were you uh I was in the
quarterback of Cl team too and this is
when uh actually I was working out I was
in the gym that was a civil team too
CLT 2 Seal Team Four I said no those I
was still Consulting two quarterback and
I still to gym I was we were working out
and somebody is coming out to the gym
and say hey just airplane run into the
into the building in New York so the car
was like yeah so what the 80 or
some just just just smoke everybody
thoughts more playing yeah and then say
that somebody else came in and say dude
this is a commercial airplane they just
crashed in the building so they was like
oh that's not good so then we all got
Quarterdeck and just watch what's
happening happening this first time is
building and then we see another that's
as it happens we see another plane
flying to it so there was like right
away that's not the accident we are the
news I will be deploying when you will
be will be kicking us how and so then
you go to you go to Puerto Rico
um on deployment
and um yeah on the East Coast nobody was
deploying it to the war there was West
Coast platoons deployed and
I remember
so you know like Team guys we're
aggressive we want to go to war
everybody like damn we nowhere I wish
we're on the west coast I wish you were
there in hours we could go and all of us
but then like in the three months into
deployment you know I'm being called by
Chief
and say hey uh
you have orders to go to Baghdad you'll
go to Iraq and you will help you know
the platons the seal patterns that are
there you start working with them and
coordinating the the our missions with
uh polish Special Forces grown and as I
didn't know what the ground was at the
time and uh so I packed my and uh
flew to back that so there was like in
the I think in the half deployment and
then then I'll send that and I have to
say it here too um as there's a chief
Baggett I can say his name I asked him
about it if I can so I owe this guy a
lot too I mean that was what I was all
kinds of Travels by the time you know it
tried to kill this guy try to do this
try to do that so um he was the chief
actually who's step in and say look
I'm going to help you and this is what's
going to happen and this and he actually
took me under his wings and he
straightened my life and and then he
sent me off to war so so yeah I mean
that was great I mean I always will be
grateful for him and he'll be leaving my
he'll always he'll be in my heart
especially that you know under his uh I
was antithesis leadership that he sent
me to war so yeah I was I was I was I
was happy
um you fly over there a civilian plane
you say from there I was taking the seal
compound Camp Posey where I quickly
acclimated and got to work for the for
those first three months in Iraq I
didn't hear from my commanders in Little
Creek once I figured they were busy so
chose not to bother them yeah yeah you
know you'll be here
easy enough so why would you buy the
real set of colleague somewhere that is
like then by the chest they might say
enough is enough because I supposed to
be there for three months only so
basically it would be six months
deployment then come back but three
months passed like nobody calls I say
Rhino like I'm not saying anything
sometimes saying hi Rob I'm still here
first I was saying just tell my command
I'm still here but after three months
like hey I'm still here just don't tell
anybody yeah
uh you say my job was to help coordinate
missions and facilitate communication
between SEAL Teams and polish Special
Forces is using my polish and English
language skills to do so my commanders
were wary about sending me on direct
action missions incorporating the Grom
assault element structure they were
worried about my safety I refused to
stay back and asked to be allowed to
join the ground assault during direct
action missions yes that's that was
normal you know there's like we don't
know these guys like I didn't know much
about Chrome and then our commanders
didn't know much either so now put me
under the command of foreign Force and
and risk you know we could die we could
be killed during these missions right so
they they were like they were very
protective of me
they didn't want me to participate in
assaults with the element I did not
understand very well didn't know but you
know when they go my way I just like
look I couldn't respect myself I cannot
just sit and watch it and not to be with
them so if I need to work with them I
need to be part of them and eventually
they did a couple missions that yeah
okay that's like go ahead and see in the
report was back and these guys are good
I mean these guys are the pros Pros yeah
yeah so like after that there was like
no issue whatsoever and you know we
blend so much that that sometimes it was
hard to tell who is who and that's quite
often I had those cars the fontrago is
there is our guy or this is a chrome guy
I said I don't even know myself they
look the same and then I said I can
cross it yeah that's a grump guy you
know or this the sour guy so yeah they
were good they were fast it's funny if
you think fast forward a couple years
and seals were out operating with random
freaking Iraqi soldiers that had Rusty
AK-47s and didn't speak English didn't
freaking know they're left from right
you know what I mean like yeah and here
we were worried about sending you with
them like a tear freaking one element of
awesome operators from Poland but at the
time we didn't know exactly much about
them so that's that's what what I came
in finally we started learning about
them and actually we we let a lot of
stuff from them and I brought a lot of
things to the teams that I learned from
these guys too so uh that's that's
what's like that was for me it was
impressive
um yeah some of these missions I think
one of our missions that everyone will
remember we we snatched those Syrian uh
uh uh terrorists from the hotel in
Fallujah when the Fallujah was evacuated
like nobody was going to follow it just
like they were just sending us to just
clean that spot or that spot yeah it was
the hotel yeah so that was like I
remember so so we're breaching like
every door is the hotel so we Bridge
every door so this is everywhere in the
end of and we gather them you know in
the in the in the in the uh the hallway
up there and the I think it was a third
floor and uh and then so every about the
grabs one of these terrorists since I
grabbed mine and that
didn't want to go I mean that was like
he was falling down every single time
every step we did he was trying to fall
down so you know I'm Still A Guy but
sometimes I fell with him too and and
the wishes are dirty in this dirty yeah
blood all over the floor so we come back
to the house I'm coming back in one of
our guys what's happening are you okay I
say yeah but this just
doesn't want to go he's resisting all he
can man he just laying on the floor I
had basically carry him out
it's like dude Dragon no this guy just
doesn't have a leg it's like what
this guy doesn't have a leg so I pick
his skirt you know his skirt is like
he doesn't have a leg so this is
why he was falling down he didn't want
to go I didn't understand Arabic if he
was saying something so that the guy
just like couldn't go I just didn't know
it so I would drag him down the stairs
falling down myself sometimes if I knew
it you know I would just grab him
another side and like hop around but I
didn't know it so we kept falling down
together and I was mad so I was I was
just using the dragon language sometimes
to get him back on the feet and and you
know using the Drago persuasion tools
and uh in a dragon translator to make
him go and that that worked but we got
tired and yeah he just didn't have a leg
unfortunately that was uh that was kind
of a crazy uh operation
um but you know this is the time also
that I developed the dragos accelerated
English course for terrorists so that
was very effective you know you just you
give me like five ten minutes with the
terrorists and sometimes even I'll Envy
the guys the way how well he learned
English from me he spoke with better
accents sometimes than me the terrorist
yeah so that's that was uh yes I was
going to patent it you say in the book
this is where I met Tage for the first
time it's another sale uh he was
attached to Seal Team five and already
been in Iraq for some time it we
immediately became good friends and we
still are today we were big and heavy
and because of our science we were often
designated as prisoner handlers to haul
terrorists from Targets this is where I
devised a kind of crash course in
English for terrorists otherwise known
as Drago's accelerated English course
for terrorists
and I applied this technique very
effectively my motto was give me 10
minutes with a terrorist who doesn't
speak English and by the end he'll come
out speaking better English than I do
like that's what's yes what happened
yeah and well we that that that work I
remember
we had the you know we worked with
different officers and so one one of the
ladies officers of uh the three-letter
agency she was uh
this guy just no English no English no
English so I was like Well ma'am it's
just like me and Paige just give us like
10 minutes and uh we kind of uh will
teach him English so you know what they
were talking about but she left and she
ten minutes can I come in and say yeah
he's pretty proficient in English so
when she started talking to him and
asking the questions this guy was like
me and Tate were amusing this guy
speaks better in English than I do now
even so yeah yeah it was very effective
it worked
um
um here's another one during another
mission this one to capture an Iraqi Air
Force General proven involvement in
various terrorist attacks our
intelligence indicated he was hiding in
a building with solid doors that would
be very difficult to breach a standard
compound a standard Mission as we
approached the house in the dark I
noticed the doors were strong but not
quite as thick as I anticipated
I had initially calibrated charges for a
stronger door I knew if I breached the
door per the original Intel the
explosives would do more damage than
expected and potentially kill anyone
inside familiar with the uncertainty of
urban Warfare I was prepared for the
situation and immediately replaced the
original breaching charge with a smaller
one that would get the job done I was
unaware that while I was while I was
breaching the door the target was
standing on the other side of the door
with his hand on the doorknob and his
ear against the door trying to listen to
what was happening outside he obviously
couldn't hear me because after I
detonated that smaller charge we found
the general standing in the doorway
holding the doorknob he didn't look
severely injured at first but he was
obviously Dazed and Confused by the
blast it got him on the ground I got him
on the ground and cuffed him with zip
ties but as I clinched the plastic
around his wrists I had a hard time
understanding why the general had three
hands on closer inspection I realized
the hand had been holding on to the
doorknob and had been split clean up the
middle in the dark it had the effect of
making feel like the guy had 15 fingers
and three hands yeah yeah luckily the
zip ties worked well as a tourniquet
yeah I thought that maybe I just killed
somebody there for a second it was like
there's three hands so what is the name
what is the other guy whose hand is that
and it was just just this guy yeah
definitely he was listening because he
was listening on other side so I gave
him an earful how do you say it in
English
so yeah he he he he was okay uh we
hauled him out of the target but yeah
that was actually around the funny
things you got all kinds of interesting
uh Mission post mission debriefs in here
you say during this time in Iraq Circa
2003 I devised new breaching charges I
advise a new breaching charge that
allowed us to explosively breach
obstacles with minimal fragmentation
this prevented injuries to
non-combatants innocent civilians who
often found themselves in the crossfire
the charge was safer to use for us as
well as it allowed for a smaller
standoff from the explosion and less
fragmentation this charge was based on a
principle that was different than this
standard breaching charge principles we
learned in preaching school this newly
divide breaching charge became widely
used in the SEAL Teams in breaching
operations throughout Iraq I also
started using different tactics from
those taught in breaching school I was
one of the proponents of those tactics
modifications that were eventually
accepted into the breaching curriculum
additionally I created a database
containing all the pertinent information
for each breach operation I consider
these safer breaching charges and
tactics my biggest contribution to the
SEAL Teams after I returned from this
deployment I was ordered to meet with
Tier 1 Seal Team breachers and brief
them on all this new information it was
a great honor yes that was the time that
we we did injured people to the bridge
on target very often or even more
and something has to be done because the
bridging the Explorer the the entry
method with explosives was very much
safer for us because the stunned people
inside and we're able actually to to
dominate the room dominate the the
target before they kind of came to their
senses so that was great but again the
the the old type of charges that we're
using we find out in Iraq I cannot go
into details here but were ineffective
the other bands of the you know the
Iraqi don't have Iraqis don't have a
standard doors so you can find the steel
doors in the same building that Center
of building and you can find also
plywood doors and the doors can open
both ways too so there's like there's no
standard like here in the United States
so it seems like all the Traders were
geared up to our standard to the
standard and that didn't work well
either bands of the walls of the door or
just did so much damage that injured
people inside and remember we were
actually dealing with
um we're dealing with with the
terrorists with the bandits that were
had no Scruples to put kids and children
in the front rooms so when most of the
time when we're breaching the doors
coming the doors we were we were
actually stepping the room full of
children and women and and these
terrorist bad guys behind them so that
was uh that was my concern and we had to
do something so these charges were like
I cannot go into details or the
different principles it allow us
basically Bridge from the feet from the
door and it was so much more expensive
he didn't care it didn't matter if it
was that there were metal door wooden
door or or whatever door they were we
were able to uh to to enter the target
Federal safely so the the the first
mission that I described the the first
pages that I described this charts if I
use our standard charges I would kill
myself with it most likely so uh so this
time knowing these charges knowing that
that the the targets the being so
familiar with Iraq and the their
building uh and they constructions of
their buildings doors it helped me to
just create this charge that it would
become like when you guys came in there
remember I came to Bahrain I brief you
on these two chapters a new way of of of
of
of doing this because the way we were
doing
till this time was very dangerous I mean
we had we had the guys we have we still
have guys without hands or fingers
because of the this type of methods that
uh I discarded and and we abandoned that
you know we started using the different
things big Improvement
um for sure
um you also say this it was while
working in Iraq as an nsw lead breacher
that I began to really notice the impact
of close proximity explosions from the
breaching charges I started to noticing
memory issues problems with my vision
and balance issues this didn't scare me
as much as it made me very aware of what
I was doing I made it a point to be
extremely focused during mission so I
wouldn't forget or mistake anything
after
so you're just eating freaking breaching
charges yeah but the regular basis and
uh some of our breaches I knew about our
guys like and the Polish guys they knew
that some problems that I have
but I forbidden say anything because
that would mean me being pulled out of
the theater and I didn't want to go back
I mean by this time I became so
customized I've been so for being so
long time in in combat there and doing
that stuff I just felt home and that was
like getting me out of the home
somewhere else and throwing me into a
known place you know this is something
that I think you had the same thing yeah
there had to be the the feeling that
eventually I'm so immersed into that
situation there in the combat that the
what happens at home the safe America
the great you know malls stores people
walking around kissing each other and
holding hands it became like a fairy
tale it becomes so unreal like now we
can think about some science fiction
things right so you you think about it
but it's like it's there it's like in
it's like in Vietnam movies when they
say oh you're going back to the world as
if it's another place yeah like it's
some other thing and we're not in the
world where this is something else yeah
for me that that world up there was a
fairy tale it became this way the the
home became dead and I feel needed up
there I feel like useful I felt I was
doing something for America so that's
for me was very important and and and
you almost forget that this is not
normal the normal life is there in
America but became like a fair like a
dream you know like a fairy tale
sometimes when I was going to sleep I
was thinking about it and I was thinking
like this is uh while falling asleep
like this is such a nice place up there
you know such a such a things like again
fairy tale yeah I mean the way you put
it in the book you say life in America
seemed distant and almost unreal the
real was here in Baghdad in combat and I
loved it yes that was that what that was
me this is why uh you know we we all let
us know no none of us there's no one
there's no seal that haven't been
injured this or the other way in Baghdad
including yourself and you know it
sometimes we don't tell it and I didn't
want to admit it for a long time but yes
that's eventually this didn't happen
right the way I was already having these
problems in Baghdad that I couldn't read
Because I read the paragraph and I
forgot what I read I didn't remember the
beginning of the paragraph so it didn't
make any sense for me I couldn't make
sense out of what I read and that's kind
of was already a little bit alarming to
me but I figured out that this is
because the lightning because you know
the tents were living the tents the
lights were like scars it was not really
good it was like always dim so yeah you
get used to it and I thought it's just
because of that yeah and I mean it's so
obvious now that we understand all the
TBI yeah we didn't know at the time no
and
um
you know when when I when I eventually
came out of Iraq
uh when I became uh so I got orders to
be a bridging instructor and by this
time I already knew that something is
wrong with me I couldn't an explosion
any and even shot a fire next to my head
it was causing me now being nauseated
and and losing balance so I I can't uh
Chief I can keep Passover Chief
Behringer and so he was he was in Iraq
with me with us and then uh so he was
the he was the detailer I said freaking
great guy he's freaking outstanding yes
rest in peace and I I asked him please
help me because I I this orders to be
breaching instructors will kill me I
just need to send me some or I don't
need to be around explosions and shots
so he it was hard to do it you know just
change the orders on the fly but
in a short time he changed my orders to
go to bats to be seal instructor and
that's that kind of saved me and but
this is when I started you have DBI
because when I came up there like every
two o'clock every time two o'clock in
the morning I was waking wide awake I
could sleep the bus dreaming the best
best starve and just wake up two o'clock
say why do I wake up no I have to
go back to sleep and then I couldn't
fall asleep so you know talking to to
you know what do you do just go to the
other guys right the team guys hey this
is what's happening to me like two
o'clock I'm way awake so we
think we've tried to figure out what the
is going on and the consensus was
that apartment is hunted there
must be a ghost up there and that's I
didn't know I was scared of ghosts I was
like that scared the out of me
I say I'm moving out so I was looking
for another apartment I couldn't find
because it was the uh I couldn't find it
because you know it was very expensive
that was a good apartment but I was
scared of that ghost so um so the I
wasn't reading for a long time just
going back at night by myself in this
apartment and facing the ghost but it
was not the ghost it was just brain
damage that and TBI which we didn't know
at the time yeah but you know the
problem with Team guys is too there's
like
my wife or somebody my neighbors telling
me I am up so what do you do you
talk to the guy hey you know my wife
tells me I'm up I'm I'm this you
know my neighbor yells and meet
some guy that am I up
no you're just like me no we're not
that you're not bad you're good you're
good well he's for example like I am
because he went to the same you
know he has the same issues same problem
so for him I look normal he looked
normal for me so I ask for Assurance
about myself with the guy so we both are
up I was like no we're good you
know so this goes and this is the
problem until today I think sometimes
with the guys like am I do I have a
problem to think to you do you have a
problem do you think no just like me but
they both have a problem because they
have both went through the same thing
right so there was like very educational
for me eventually landed that this is
TBI this is not the uh uh not not the
ghost it's not a ghost yeah it's your
your first your first deployment over
there was almost a year long yeah and um
you freaking come home and
you get to the airport there's no one to
pick you up and you know you oh you call
and you're like hey I'm Drago I just
came back from Iraq I need a ride
and the guy says dude we don't have
anyone in Iraq because you because that
team wasn't deployed around no there was
no West Coast no no East Coast deployed
we don't have anyone buddy in Iraq what
action is that anyway stop calling or
I'll call the police yeah yeah yeah
those because they didn't know well this
is how I came back from Iraq I would
stay there longer but you know when I
come for my night vision that was like
the guy was like
because my night vision broke out and
and like you guys didn't have enough I
mean there's like Dragon we can help you
but we cannot do that all the time so I
called up there and there's like where
are you at I'm like I'm in Iraq in
Baghdad but the the first the first
response was the new guy I think in the
Armory so he thought basically that the
guy calling from Baghdad from Iraq who
wants to send it he wants night vision
to send to Baghdad to Iraq and the guy
don't speak English so so so so so like
whatever so so like he was like cracking
jokes I said do you want a suicidal bomb
fest with it too maybe interestingly
because you know it was the suicidal
attacks at the time uh quite common and
uh
so I just told him like you
I'm going to kill you when I got up
there and getting MasterChef online so
Master Chief comes alive oh yeah Dragon
City to hear from you you know how is
everything going I said great uh where
are you at right now and in Baghdad oh
oh yeah yeah that's right how long have
you been there like a year almost here
in the on deployment
oh okay
how do I say let me get this online I
think you need to come back so so
without winning on my more time anymore
and they yeah they I was I was sent back
I went home and uh it's crazy you're
you're so you get home yeah and they
therefore they they didn't pick me up at
the airport too so my actually my my
first night after a year-long deployment
uh almost year-long deployment that I
spent in the IHOP I I hope and I don't
mind because I love IHOP I always love
the pumpkins they reminds me like my mom
used to make them and the cheese Blends
that's like my favorite cheese beans I
love it so when I show up up there this
guy in the airport said like hey you
know what can you uh doing some help
there's a few of guys came but these
guys were picked up by either their
wives or the command Vehicles so I said
no just help me carry to the car but the
truck is picking me up and and was
November so it was very cold and uh so I
went up there it's just like this
afternoons I just wait the track will
show up anytime and as I wait I fell
asleep because it was like I was
tired I didn't realize how tired I was
so I fell asleep and then I hear you
know this this light buzzing
above my head it's getting dark the
lights came up and they're a lot up
there next to the airport it is Saturday
so I think everything is shut down
there's no more flights so they shut the
airport down and I'm like going
hypothermia I have bones grenades and
bomb and and everything with me on the
curb sleeping like there's nobody there
to pick me up say what do I do with the
bombs so with the guns and all that
stuff so
I tried to knock on the door and I
didn't nobody shows up so I say
they left so I'm going to go and to get
inside to get the phone my phone is dead
it expires anyway it's been a year away
that's they shut my account
so
I picked this like concrete encasement
for the what you throw the the can
inside exactly heavy so there's a sway
in the wind so I picked it about to hit
the glass because I you know I I just
need to save my life now save myself
because I'm freezing and I'm I'm like
really crazy
I need I'm like I need my eye on the
phone I need the car I cannot even say
direct So eventually I didn't even know
that number my mind was so messed up I
didn't remember the phone numbers we get
here to find me the number to group two
the CL team was already somewhere else
and so I called the group two and this
is what you say like these guys like we
don't have anybody there off which
is good basically but they didn't say
off but they say like you know just
leave us alone but then I said like how
though I started using the lingo that
you know there's like get their
attention say oh dude is this okay hold
on one second and I can hear the shuffle
of the papers and whoever it was already
at the time say Drago I am so sorry we I
remember seeing the message somewhere
but we totally Overlook it overlooked it
we are sending track right now just hang
on there we are sorry and you know I
don't have a I understand that there was
the time when we changed how we do the
business I don't want to go into details
here but but so the the the team was
gone they were doing something else
there was a few guys left here and there
and uh there was nobody in the Seal team
at the time
and and and and so you know there's like
they have so much going on but
especially going to war that you know
things like that will happen who fall
through the cracks and uh so like it was
no big deal I think now I think it's
funny but that time I was really pissed
so so they came in and picked me up
and yeah yeah and then and then they
don't let you stay at the team oh yeah
because I have no place to go right
because I didn't have a family at the
time the girlfriend that I left
supposedly for three months only uh was
already met after six months but after a
year she finally said quit she just she
fired me so
um so I didn't have a place to go she
just told me like when you come back
just let me know I will put the track
your Jeep and your cruise box that's all
I had and your cruise box
on the parking lot you can key inside
you can pick it up and say okay but my I
couldn't call my phone was dead my uh
I didn't even remember her number
because my my brain was so messed up
and uh yeah so they they drove me to the
teams they took my guns everything and
now just by thinking I just snagged the
key from the quarter deck because we
didn't have people on quarterback by
this time so there was so I snagged the
key put my packet and and because then I
said well I'd like to run I will go eat
something or but so we work out the guy
the tech it was not the shield I have a
lot of respect for him he's a good guy I
likely like him so he shuts the door and
I said hey what's the code I need to get
back in he said dude now we cannot give
you the I don't give you the code it's
weekend and the ucls must not cannot
sleep anymore in the cages because
there's a bunch of us are usually
sleeping in the cages there's so many
seals without families having no home so
they they just like they they stay in
the cage they go sleep in the cage okay
just big and then we have it like
like three or four tracks parked in
front of the team four I find one that
worked so I drove myself I said I need
to go and get something to eat I'm
hungry
so I went to the bank it's like 25 or 30
dollars left I pulled whatever I could
twenty dollars what can you eat for
twenty dollars really not that much but
there's my favorite I hope so I say okay
now so I'm going to IHOPs I went to IHOP
up there and and got the coffee it got
the cheese beans I ate and just like
down on me how I'm home
I'm safe so I was like
the thing I remember I fell asleep and
it's like hey you okay
it was the the security guard like they
rent a cup type guy I said I'm okay
uh he says uh
I'm talking that can I stay here a
little bit longer because uh like I'm
I'm I'll buy some more food just to so I
can relax and rest a little bit
and I was like days ago you could just
woke me up I was like he looks at me
yeah
the kick you out did she I was
like like what is he what the
he's talking about but then I was like
oh yeah yeah she did he said okay you
can stay here but just don't don't cause
any problems just stay here as you need
and you know it's okay so I fellas back
asleep so my first night was in IHOP
welcome back to America damn well you
know things like that will happen from
time to time there was nothing
intentional yeah
uh
fast forward a little bit in the book I
couldn't find myself in Virginia Beach I
didn't have family there anymore when
the opportunity came to go back to Iraq
I was excited and jumped on the
opportunity yeah I was missing Iraq I
was missing combat I missed the work I
had been doing there I was told I could
join them for a couple weeks once again
and once again as act as a liaison with
the Grom I'd be helping them out since
the new team hadn't had any previous
experience working with Polish Special
Forces two weeks went by and I was
expecting the call from the command to
return to Virginia
it never came two weeks became four
weeks four weeks became four months
and my first extras long stint in Iraq
say the saying went no news from Drago's
good news so you just basically did it
again yeah and so that well
and and again the cow came not from me
but from my team so I dragged going to
come back well you need to join the
platoon we are deploying like very short
time and uh it's our time so you need to
come back and I went back and came back
again to Iraq with my serial platoon and
that's your sixth deployment to Baghdad
or to Iraq
um or I guess it's 2016 total and you
say by my last deployment of 2005 things
had changed considerably since I'd first
come to Iraq in 2003 in the wake of 9 11
the bureaucracy had intensified and the
war was now being fought largely by the
Army and Marines even our pre-raid
briefs when we received last minute
Intel reviewed and reviewed dossier's
maps and Recon photos had become longer
and longer this wasn't the old days of
maps on the walls and physical files
either everything was digital now we
called it Death by PowerPoint yeah it
seemed like we were briefing for the
sake of the brief in order to brief more
yep if that sounds confusing trust me it
was I still believe to this day that it
was an Army requirement that we were
being forced to adopt then the missions
became scarcer and we were no longer
assaulting targets every night actually
this this is what happened because the
The Briefing that that the mission
preparation took so long and it was by
the by the Army standard that by the
time we we complete the the preparations
the target was gone so we basically
we're hitting empty houses or didn't do
anything I remember uh I had uh oh sorry
no no so that was just just that yeah I
I mean just to go the other end of the
spectrum
um my commanding officer at Seal Team
seven like after we'd been there for a
little while he he came down to the camp
and talked to me and he goes hey
when I'm briefing up the chain of
command how much time do you need to
prepare for a mission like how much time
do you need we were quick and I said I
said well sir
15 minutes and he actually he thought I
was kidding and I was like he goes he
goes no but I mean like seriously I go
no 15 minutes we we've launched in 15
minutes I said I need the the location
of the Target and I need the frequency
of the conventional forces that are that
own that battle space and give me this
at calmly because we were so proficient
we did so many times that it does not
there is not really no-brainer most of
the time those missions were not as
complicated as as some people want to
believe and we did launch in 15 minutes
on a bunch of operations yes 15 minutes
load up the trucks there were times that
we could remember we came back from the
mission yeah say hey we have another
Target here so we are about to drop our
kit off and like oh let's keep up
let's go back we did one as a matter of
fact I remember when we came back I said
okay hey from now on when we roll out
put your actual put your military
uniform on because I said hey we're
launching in seven minutes and guys were
like I was looking at the turret Gunners
they were wearing like random clothes
and I was like all right that's not cool
bro we can't do that again take an extra
two minutes to put your actual military
uniform on yeah yeah sure it's all kinds
of them okay like Cardinals should still
with the cars that was funny but yeah
that happened because but they were so
fast we were so efficient and we did so
many times that we really could pull it
off but then we just kept slowing down
though this is not by the book this is
how we need to spend time on this and
then I find myself I was watching and
the girl was watching with better
Amusement they never did that they were
like watching what the is going on
Drago up there so we we first we we
breathe we we then we rehearse then we
rehearse again uh to the same thing
and then we breathe just so people can
listen to the brief and improve the
brief make the better brief and then we
go with the brief once there was a brief
to breathe and then it was listen to the
brief under a brief again there was
going to the to the army guys to to
approve the two Army commands so that
took us a long time and it was so bad
that I remember uh you were you you've
seen part of this debacle that there was
a two you another you need a ground unit
showed up working with Green Berets
great guys I have a lot of respect for
them but the the the the cycle was so
slow that these guys can really finally
pissed off and say like they came and
say hey we need to get us out from I
want to work with sales we want to I
want my unit to work with sales because
we don't do any missions there and it
takes so long time to plan
and that caused kind of a little bit
friction between us and Green Berets and
we had to explain to Graham that there's
not like it's not up to us we can't make
these decisions and they were upset they
were generally upset we want to go and
kill these bad guys and we can't because
that that breathing all this this
process goes so long and it's so precise
I'm not saying that this is wrong I'm
just saying that it just took so long
time that a lot of these targets got
away yeah and this is what bothers me
till today
this is something that people sometimes
ask me if I have any regrets from Iraq
I I do have one that bothers me that
that that it it somehow very often I
reflect on it as we didn't kill the
novel these bastards there's too many of
these bastards just got away and the
reason it bothers me is because if if we
did get maybe then one son of the
what some of our brothers would come
back later on they wouldn't be killed
but later on by the son of the so
that that weighs on me and even now
sometimes they are I sit down and like
almost every night I have these things
that I think every every son of the
bridge that got away that I wish I could
kill so I I think we all have this
almost like a guilt that we we maybe we
could do more so some of our brothers
would come home safely no doubt about it
you don't know yeah that's the only
regret I have
yeah yeah but you know what I think
about this like when I was yeah uh so
yeah I came back and I asked later to
to go to bands because every every shot
like from the gun around my head or
close my close proximity caused me to be
nauseated and and sometimes I will lose
the balance I was like
so yeah I mean that's nothing unusual
because quite a few of our guys suffer
from that
yeah so that's that's what um you know
you you go into this what you what you
were talking about earlier where um you
came back they gave you orders which was
smart they're thinking hey let's let
this guy go be a breaching instructor
because he's done hundreds and hundreds
of real world breaches he developed this
breaching protocol he developed
breaching charges like but then they
didn't know about the medical things you
were facing you called I was hiding it
for a while but yeah then eventually
I've confessed to him too yeah
something's wrong with me and luckily
Berger's is a freaking awesome guy who
was figured things out how to take care
of the guys and how to take care of you
and um so you end up going to buds what
job did you have it but were you a
second phase instruction
so yeah that was pretty cool I mean it
was funny I think that the most
difficult part for me was to answer like
the question how how would you describe
your work in skill teams what are SEAL
Teams you know and I have I I kind of
struggle to because you can talk about
these jobs about SEAL Teams forever so
make it sure that I said like you know
think about like government customer
service you know the the
but my customers were always wrong and I
got to kill them so this is something
that customers always wrong yeah you
know our customers were always wrong yes
they were so I think there was there
like they never bothered me after you
know like they laugh at it but they just
I didn't have to make those long answers
uh when you're at buds what would what
did you learn what did you see uh as a
buds instructor that was like new
knowledge to you obviously you learned
that everything is structured and
organized which you didn't know when
you're going through buds right that's
so the one of these out of this uh
explained all the structure the safety
mechanisms that are transparent to the
student but what I learned the most I
think what's struck me the most is that
I was extremely humbling experience to
me to go up there and see it and for me
when I was going through Bots as a
student was just kicking the balls King
in the ass
and just spit you out Ready For Real
Steel training right so when you go up
there as an instructor and you have to
dish out these punishments you have to
did do all this stuff
as this is almost like I couldn't
believe that it is possible to make
through it or almost thinking like these
people have balls I mean to go to this
and how can this kid this 20 years
19 years old 25 years old kid not quit
from after this you know most of them
quit but there was those guys who didn't
holy this is like new
found of respect and for these kids
these guys you just can't make them quit
you just cannot did you did you work any
hell weeks I did yeah sometimes because
I was second phase but I was assigned to
uh sometimes to support the Halloween
because the Halloween goes 24 7. there
is no break there's always Evolutions
going on the students don't sleep so
yeah I was supplementing sometimes these
guys I kind of wish I got to watch some
hell weeks or work some hell weeks
because I never did and Only Hell Week I
saw was mine yeah which I you know was
just like you're like what the hell is
going on it is incredible you know and
then you can see the the the the the at
the end of it these people like they
don't even sometimes know what's going
on around them they know what's going on
around them but they are unable to quit
even if they wanted to because their
brain is already set I'm going to make
it I'm going to go through it so some of
them have to be actually pulled out of
training if there are serious injuries
and there are such sometimes so this is
why those inspects actions are going on
this is why we don't allow uh people to
to injure themselves you know there are
some Who hide it who lie and those are
those people who get usually injured if
you are dishonest you do not follow the
instructions to report yourself injuries
if you don't if you hide from the doctor
staff you get injured and this is why we
have to be that's why the inspections
are the way they are every night you are
inspected and make sure that you are
still good to go but heroic is uh it's
just what it is it's not the most
difficult part of bats I think that the
second phase is very technical and most
of the people actually fell out uh and
the third phase is like real Halloween
steroids that's the reason the way I
experience that now at this point you
are finally kind of settling down a
little bit
um
you start to think about maybe you got
to find the other part of the American
dream here you know like yeah
um you you say with the help of some of
my seal Brothers I turned to online
dating service to try and find the woman
of my dreams yeah because I was trying
to find somebody in San Diego and
actually I can say the Joel brother at
peace respect uh so he was trying to
hook me up and and help me out find some
some girl about every time it came out
to it was like not good you know like
the guy don't speak English looks scary
and it looks
so they didn't know what exactly they
were looking for yeah and the clothes
you know like I never feel the new after
Iraq I spent so much time there wedding
just the Camis I didn't feel the need to
wear nice clothes and nice clothes for
me was jeans
and black T-shirt but when I wanted to
be fancy I wore black jeans and white
T-shirt or something like that and that
was it so finally Jones I do you you
don't find anybody like this you cannot
go like this and people and expect the
girls were far for you we're going
shopping so he took me to the store we
start buying stuff and and he's like the
things that I pick up he's like dude
this like 1970s don't wear that so he
picked the clothes for me and everything
and when we came back from the strip I'm
still grateful for him I thought there
is no girl able to resist me from then
on but you know what I think I already
burned myself out in San Diego so I
decided to go and find some I was
advised to go online and find somebody
online
that was disaster too for a long time
and then I can talk about I wrote about
in the book but eventually I might make
up to Rachel So eventually say uh you
you find a girl we emailed back and
forth a couple days I was totally
Charmed her name was Rachel she was
everything I was looking for and a woman
and a partner beautiful witty smart
successful in her own right she was much
younger than me which made me a little
nervous what if she thought I was too
old for her on the advice of my
teammates I'd taken a few years off my
real age for the dating site yeah yeah
and then I still barely fit her
preferred age range I found out later
because like I didn't know it but I was
like a month away from being cut off
even after I lie about my age so how
many years did you take off I think like
five
five or six maybe I don't remember four
five six a lot a lot that's really sick
but you know she was like way way
younger and I was like there is no way
she will she will you know want to date
me or see me and supposedly I look scary
at the time so and then you say I didn't
want to risk losing her so I asked some
of my sealed teammates to help me write
love letters too yeah yeah because you
know I still my English is not perfect
yes you can hear it until this day until
this day I'm more proficient speaking
with bullets than speaking with words so
yeah who could help me now my closest
family that was fellow sales so whoever
I could drive to and say can you help me
can you correct my grammar can you fix
this it's like Drago if you if you if
you write this you're gonna get she will
she will not want to talk to you you
don't speak like this ladies you know so
basically they were writing the love
letters for me and I was just you know
typing it and just send it to her she
liked it but you know there was only two
I could only pulled that shed off for so
long
So eventually you say I met Rachel in
person about two months later it felt
like an eternity she came to visit me in
San Diego I asked a fellow seal to come
with me an assistant bailing me out if
Rachel turned out before that fish from
the previous dating experiences so yeah
I had my swing body with me and
uh I had her picture and a flower the
flower I kept hidden in my Jeep just in
case I had to make a last-minute Escape
I had no reason to worry though my
teammate and I both recognized her she
came down and escalated at the San Diego
Airport holy Drago my buddy
exclaimed she's too young did you Rob
the Cradle or something how did you pull
that off I laughed and replied you guys
wrote The Love Letters I lied about my
age it worked my buddy threw up his
hands and laughing turned around to
leave whatever dude she's hot I'm out
now really nervous I approached the
escalator to wait for her near the
bottom when she walked up to me I was
scared out of my wits I extended my hand
to her stiff as a board from head to toe
and muttered High I'm Thomas Rachel
looked at me with a twinkle in her eye
and she replied breezily Thomas it's
nice to meet you but I didn't fly all
the way across the United States you say
that yeah give me a hug holy
oh damn oh I was in love yeah
oh at this time you say Rachel was
living in Ohio
um for a while you freaking were helping
her out like you know giving her sending
money out to her she wasn't even
changing the job at the same at the time
when they transitioned time so I figured
out like I just couldn't be I couldn't
be helpful you know and and kind of like
so she likes me more I said I I I would
do anything for her to love me so so I
was like you know like
I was worrying like I was doing
everything just too so so that included
giving up your apartment moving into the
cages like a freaking news
and then eventually you just got sick of
the cages so you you kicked a couple Bud
students out of their room and you moved
into one of the butts yeah
dog then he's one of those students and
we we connect with a connected back now
and wait who was it Jared Ogden
great officer great officer great guy so
much respect for him but even more
respect because you know like he was
living next door so in the morning I
brushed my teeth spit in the sink and
stuff and then I was running back again
inspecting his room and he's in the
bathroom just getting him in trouble
yeah I I I admire his restrained he
didn't he didn't know die me out or
anything he just like took as a man and
and yeah we are friends we are friends
still today and uh a lot of respect for
this guy as an officer but also as a
student
fast forward a little bit you say even
as my personal life began to fall into
place I struggled to wrap my head around
the fact that I would soon be leaving
the Navy Seals forever yeah I began
looking for jobs trying to think of
whatever career could possibly satisfy
me after years in the teams the problem
with the seal life is it's harder to get
out of than it is to get in I know that
sounds impossible given everything
you've read but you must understand how
much of your life the teams occupy and
for how long for years your seal
teammates are everything to you your
family your friends your co-workers you
eat sleep breathe and fight with them
day in and day out no one in the world
knows you better than those guys do not
only that but they also understand what
you've been through better than anyone
ever will
true totally true Rachel helped me a lot
with this process when I was put on
terminal leave meaning you were getting
ready to retire she helped me do
everything from typing up my resume to
teaching me how to negotiate job
officers job offers never accept the
first offer they give you she said
Rachel helped me post my resume online
for my job search and three days later I
received a call from a software
development firm they asked me some
basic screening questions and then
invited me to come in for an interview
on my way out Rachel it reiterated do
not accept the first offer they give you
she emphasized for me to come home we
would talk about it and then I would
negotiate for terms I wanted
naturally I said yes to the first offer
they gave you yeah Superstar listening
real closely for them I forgot to
mention this whole time and I was going
to mention we were talking about the
database that you built for the
breaching charges you're a computer guy
you're a computer nerd you know freaking
I remember this a team too you like new
computer languages and stuff like this
yeah yeah yeah so it says this how I got
that job but you know what with this yes
so what I did I was taking a picture of
every bridge in charge and the door the
target before and after it and also
notes what was what charge did I use the
the I don't want to go into details
there's new charges yeah so uh when so I
was told that I need to go and meet with
this tier one guys and uh and I went up
there and uh talked to them I gave them
all the information that I had so they
were very you know they said thank you I
hope it helped them a lot and uh and
yeah they were appreciative of that
stuff I was very very
um every charge the size the the
standoff that everything that need to be
that I was I was and you had enough
computer savvy to know how to make the
creatures so that's like something we
always talk I mean I always talk about
you you know punching people in the head
and blowing up but there's a whole
other side to you that like is it
computer programmer and how's knows how
to do all kinds of stuff like that so
you end up getting a software job
um yeah you say this the military
provides structure camaraderie and
stability to a lot of people who have
never experienced any of those things
before and it can be extremely difficult
to leave behind in combat I did not see
anything the Navy didn't prepare me to
see I did not do anything the Navy
didn't prepare me to do I don't have any
regrets for my actions in the war
there's nothing that ever bothered me
about the war on the other hand
traumatic brain injury is a different
story as a lead breacher I was exposed
to countless close proximity explosion
some of them cause bleeding from my nose
or ears it definitely had some effect on
my health and I did have trouble
sleeping as I transitioned to civilian
life
I'd wake up in the middle of the night
at two or three a.m in the past when
talking about with my fellow Navy Seals
the consensus was it was ghosts but the
more information that began to come
through about these problems the more I
began to realize the Damage Done during
my time in the military was still with
me every breach explosion shock wave and
concrete powder inhalation had left us
with varying degrees of physical trauma
this had affected things like my memory
balance and speech I carried a lot of
bad habits from my time in the seals for
quite a while probably some of the bad
habits from my earlier life too now that
I think about it Rachel who has always
been significantly more proper than me
had to tell me on multiple occasions not
to just spit out the first thought that
came to my head when somebody said
something stupid or not to beat up some
random guy on the street just because I
thought he looked at me funny sometimes
I felt like I was taking etiquette
classes yeah I'm I'm fully domesticated
now I know you use that term in here he
keeps saying she domesticated you well
the
yeah that guy but now you know I'm I'm
proper I'm I'm I'm I know the uh I'm a
good person yeah you know and I'm a good
husband I'm good father and I wasn't
neither one before but
from my perspective you are an awesome
person before because I know that no
matter what was going on I knew I could
count on you thank you that was what our
jobs were and it was a different I mean
it takes a different type of person so
do you have to
maybe shed some of that uh shed some of
that a little bit when you go and be
married and all this other stuff from me
so that's she's she's
basically what she did she uh she uh she
she fired Drago she fired dragons yeah
yeah
Drago is in the cage now
he's in The Lion King the Tiger cage or
whatever it is uh I just had to read
this one section it says my bud students
shared how much they valued my
perspective and what they learned from
me at the end of each phase students
were required to write a review of the
face and provide evaluations for all the
instructors one of my students commented
instructor Drago was so motivating I
can't imagine how much more motivated I
would have been if I understand
understood half of what he said that's
actually a real critique that's that's
the part I still have it I have those
good things at home uh some of them so
yeah that's
um you decide you're going to ask Rachel
to marry you you freaking taker than our
desert training facility uh because uh
you know like the divorce the the being
away that's the ruin you also
financially and uh I was trying to my
best to kind of impress her to you know
I was in love with her we were in love
with each other so finally asking to pop
the question about how do I do it I
start reading books about it go to
vacations know go to Cancun go to here
Hawaii is like I don't have the money I
don't even know how to do that so I
figured I'll just do what I know the
best I just I invite it to the range
make her shoot and I I asked to be to
marry me so me and my fellow Team guys
my team Brothers sales device they think
that we're gonna go and line up the gun
every type of gun in our inventory on
the Range where we train sales and we
invite her so he starts shooting from
gun to gun to gun to gun and the last
gun will have those Mark 48 will have
the when you leave the tray to load it
because I tell her she's load every can
so we put actually 2 48 so Mark 48 with
the Tracer so she can kind of get used
to it I think so she doesn't smash it
forgot my ring the one that I they ring
the like
secure up there so the first 48 was just
playing for 48 with the she loved
against the tray she was a good shooter
I can like make me feel like this yeah
yeah so uh so the second gun the last
gun on the line
so she went to her select she knew her
how to do it because she didn't the
first one she confidently opened the
tray and here's the hanging on the ring
there's the on the thread is a ring and
on the bolt it says marry me instead of
the ball up with a piece of paper or
marry me so she looked check the tears
in her eyes me too and she said yes and
there's actually I have a video of it oh
it was on the website of that actually
the video when I asked her to marry me
with the guns and I have a pictures that
I'll post online to
say yes pretty epic
um
fast forward a little bit Rachel and I
were married on August 18 2007 that also
happens to be the date of the Battle of
Thermopylae in 480 BC and we were
married in a small town that was named
after the Spartan King leonides yeah I
had been fascinated by the ancient Greek
and Roman history for years and these
coincidences felt like a confirmation of
our beautiful life ahead we have five
children together including three from
our previous marriages our older boys
are in their 20s Adam is happily married
and has a young daughter Blake is
starting College after serving honorably
as a U.S marine with deployments to
Afghanistan and Conor's loving life
while serving in the U.S Coast Guard our
two little teenagers from our marriage
are Grace the little lady of the house
and Dorian our future Warrior yeah
Gracie rules the house that's my my
little lady and uh yes she's she she's
the lady yes
I officially retired from the U.S Navy
Seals at the rank of petty officer first
class on June 31st 2011.
I am proud of the contributions I made
to the teams and thankful for the Great
Men I was able to serve with and learn
from
and you go on to say this
I love Poland
and sometimes I still get asked if I
would ever move back and every time I
say no I'm an American now I'm an
American by choice I'm fiercely proud of
my roots but America is where my heart
belongs where I live and America is
where I will die yes that's that's me
and you know I
this this book is freaking great
um
you you put so much stuff into
perspective and and here's another thing
it just I have seen what happens when a
totalitarian government takes control
and it's why I'm so grateful to be a
proud American citizen America is my
country and I consider myself blessed to
live here this is where I found the
seals who gave me a new life and a new
sense of purpose where else but America
can you show up with only a bag of
clothes barely able to speak English and
rise to the ranks of the world's
greatest fight is fighting force America
is where I Found Love A Renewed sense of
faith and I was able to build a family
and a life for them without ever having
to look over my shoulder
only in America there is no other
country in the world where you can come
and be whoever you are able to be
and and Live Safe great life and that's
the life I have in America I'm proud of
my America there is no hyphen in front
of this American here
just American yeah I want to call look
again get the book I just want to close
that with this one one little uh part
you say ultimately I believe the
American dream is about more than
material prosperity
it's about being able to live a safe
simple fulfilling life and having the
freedom and opportunity to pursue our
individual dreams regardless of what you
think or how you vote patriotism to me
means respecting one's neighbor and
loving one's family and being willing to
defend both
I fought against a totalitarian
government when I was younger doing so
taught me to be strong and to never lose
sight of what it is I'm defending
whether it's a person a flag or a place
every American can love something about
this country and fight to make it a
better home for everyone
for me at the end of the day I owe
everything to this country and the
people in it
and I wouldn't have it any other way
that's what uh I would like to use this
opportunity opportunity here to say
thank you to every American thank you to
America for my freedom
I can only live free
because of America and American people
so I would like to say thank you and you
know very often people say thank you for
your service thank you for what you have
done for America but purely understand
you cannot repay Freedom how can you so
there is so much more there's always
more you can do or you should do so I so
for me as I'll say like you don't say
thank you there's me who should say
thank you and who is saying thank you
for my freedom so I would like to say
thank you so much thank you for
everything thank you for allowing me to
be American be part of this great
country yeah that's freaking outstanding
and there's so much more in the book
like we didn't even touch on you've got
you got journals from people that you
knew when you were a political prisoner
you've got their journals in this book
you've got you mentioned this earlier
there's documents from the show trials
that that some of your friends uh went
up against and and they stood up to the
to the tyrannical tyrannical governments
um
it's it's just a freaking outstanding
it's outstanding document it's a
historical document it really is a
historical document that people are
going to be able to look back on
well so tell us what what you're up to
now you got connect Zing right yes so I
was heavily censored by Facebook
LinkedIn and matter of fact link that I
had to drag up and this might like a
third account every time I opened
something they shut me down and I lose
all the followers so uh and Twitter that
they kicked me out of it so I decide to
open my own social media and there's a
disconnect zinc.com and it is in the
book so this is something that
and I think that is we don't have
socialist fact Checkers uh you you know
there were no fact Checkers until the
truth started coming out and that's
that's what's triggered that that uh
censorship so there's no censorship here
we let people decide what they want to
uh read who they want to connect with
and and what they want to believe in and
what they want to post that's that's
their Forum there is no censorship so
that's that's I think is my other
contribution to free speech and free
America I think it's uh
yeah but so it's connect Zing
z-i-n-g.com is where you can find that
you also have the Navy
sealsfund.org yes and what that is
that's a five to charity to 501 C3
charity it's relief support and
education that's what you that's what
you all provide
um the the quote that you have is quiet
flexible and responsive and what it is
it's just a no red tape
action arm that can make stuff happen
when people need it yes and especially
nowadays when the wars are winding down
there's a lot of people from our
community coming injured and that they
are usually sometimes they are branded
as a troublemakers and when they ask for
help there is no help for them many
Charities turn them away because I well
you were Troublemaker we don't want you
here we don't we can help you
for for Navy Seals fund there is no such
distinctions you were 53-26 or officers
and SEAL Teams we will help you we'll
not we will not uh allow you to foul and
uh and this is another thing is there's
no paid position this the charity is run
by Navy Seals only and that we don't get
paid this is something that very was
very important to me that we do it
because it is the right thing to do not
because we get paid and uh there's a
group of great sales on our board of
directors and we are very quick we can
respond within an hour sometimes and
this is necessary because very often we
get a car you know with the sales as
they don't ask for help usually they try
to deal with it themselves we we don't
want to uh see being seen as vulnerable
or in trouble so so they don't ask for
help but we get a car like hey
so I ran out of option they're gonna
take they're gonna repossess or our
default on my mortgage and tomorrow I'll
be done with it I need help can we do
something and there's quite
a few times we had to step in within an
hour so foreclosure or something and pay
that bill and and put the guy back on
his feet because sometimes it is I'm at
least I don't know if you were but many
guys I know where and I was the
situation that I'm almost there I'm
almost got myself out on the on in the
clear but this last thing is going to
sink me I just need a little bit push to
get me over the hump and I'm good and I
have a job line number I have this and
this and we are there we we we gave that
push so the guy can get on his feet and
and and and another thanks to what is
important for Navy Seals fund is get
people out of this vicious cycle of
Contracting there's many guys they like
it and I understand it and I think I
would like it to myself but there's many
guys that are tired already they are
tired of War they are the combat
deployments but when they when they
retire they leave the Navy they don't
have sometimes much options the skills
as you know Navy Seals their skills our
skills are not easily translated into
civilian world I mean you could be great
Walmart Kmart guard or something like
this too unless you have other skills
that you acquire while in the teams and
a lot of Team guys are but there are
some that don't so we don't want to send
them uh so what they do say okay what
I'm going to do is I didn't find the job
this time so I will go Contracting for
six months and makes tons of money and
then I can back I will have a cushion
that I can find a job where there's
there's no longer these tons of money
available because the wars are winding
down the guy going to play on such
contract comes back with the money six
months later six months later there's no
money left and there's still no job so
what do you do what the guy is doing
well I just try one more time so just
then he tells his family his wife his
kids I'm going again I go one more time
my next time will be better and he goes
again on the on this contract comes back
it is not better so so we we are looking
for the way to break them out of the
Cycles those guys who want to get out
Navy Seals fine they're standing by and
and they're trying to help to get out of
it besides some of these guys are
already injured and they don't need to
go on this on these type of trips
anymore yeah for sure
um all this information can be found at
uh Drago ziran
dot com that's where it is uh your last
name is spelled
d-z-i-e-r-a-n their first name is
spelled Drago I guess
uh you are back somehow on social media
you're on Instagram you're on Twitter at
dragon dragon
yes um so you're on both those places
and this is what you got going on the
book freaking just came out it's just
it's it's outstanding
um does that get us up to present day do
we cover oh I know we didn't cover yes
your friend from uh from bone frog yes
bone frog Coffee Company yes bun for
coffee bone frog wines uh he is uh I I
would like to bring it up because it's a
great coffee this guy is he's there's a
seal business
great business and the coffee you will
like it you'll love it this is something
that uh
that's all I drink
I would like to bring it up and I would
like to uh encourage people to support
this Navy SEAL business is is great
again great coffee great uh and these
guys are supporting our Charities uh
they uh the bone frog coffee and
bumpering wines are supporting Navy
Seals fan they are always very active
within the vcl community they support
again Navy sealsfund.org and I would
like to encourage people to look into
their website and it is posted that the
Navy sealsfund.org as a as one of our
supporters and and uh and active
actively helping our community so this
guy that made this company Tim he's uh
he
is a team guy he's an ABC yes so he
retired I think he did what 25 years I
think something like that so and then he
you know he's one of these freaking
coffee junkies people that are super
into coffee like and so it's bone
frogcoffee.com
[Music]
um and uh I don't know if you want me to
say this or not but you were saying that
he donated so much money to you and your
charity that you had to be like hey dude
you you don't need to give us any more
money right now like we'll get money
from other people that's that's what
that's where where his mindset is at I
would want something yes because uh so
at this on our website uh
we want him to take care of himself
right now and his family because his uh
beloved wife
uh I think I can say about it because
this is officially on our website the
the support for his wife
has cancer and he's fighting with
everything he has to provide to his
family and save his his wife so please
go to the Navy sealsfun.org to our
support page and read about my teammate
who is fighting for his wife's life
right now with with and still trying to
provide for for his kids for his
children so
um again I have to be very careful how I
say it for the legal reasons I think but
this is the mind that we support we
actually had to ask him to
do not to to instead of the 1995 just
provide for his family for his for his
uh wife and we are standing by his side
so the Navy Seals fund is on his side we
try to help him but this business is is
the coffee is great this is something
that I drink every day and I was not the
coffee drinker until I ran into this
coffee so if you can maybe show it to uh
so once called bone frog blend the other
one's called frogman
yeah yeah my fragment is that my
favorite one that's your favorite
believe it or not
so let's support Tim let's support bone
frog bone frog bone frogcoffee.com
there you go
um also go to Navy sealsfun.org where
you can read a little bit more about
what we are fighting for right now for
his family there you go so so check
those things out and um Zach get us up
is that is that give us a present day I
think I think we're in a present day
okay
Carrie you got any questions I saw you
over there taking notes were you just
taking a a freaking admin notes or you
got something you got some to put
out actually what's up I I did have one
question for you Drago just because I'm
curious and and I definitely plan on
reading the book
um but in in in socialist State Poland
about what percentage of the the Polish
people would you say were bought into
what was happening with the socialist
government because it seems like with
you know uh people having rooms taken
away from them in an apartment building
to put somebody else there and uh food
scarcity it seems like you the the
people would look around and say
something here isn't right this doesn't
seem like it's working
um but I I'm not sure how how many the
what percentage of the people are bought
into this and and are believers and and
what percentage are kind of felt like
you and and you're kind of comrade very
a small percentage although if you
listen to official socialist propaganda
the press the the media the fake news
media that you would think that
everybody is for socialism there's only
few this per this uh uh uh they they
call it instructionists who oppose it
but you know people and Poland knew
about these murders after the second
world war where they were executing up
people opposing socialism the the the
apartments and stuff this has not the
the biggest deal there was just
inconvenience but we're talking about
the imprisonment the persecution of
opposition the the the presence after
the second world war people were being
sent out to Soviet Union to Siberia from
Poland so that was that was so pretty
much common knowledge that even strict
censorship falsified history and
destroyed monuments burned destroyed
books the history books uh uh
did not help to suppress the discontent
and the hate for socialism and communism
that the totalitarian oppressive systems
and actually the Polish Constitution I
think Article 13 I believe
says that it forbids
any party any type of organization which
whose ideology is based on totalitarian
system like socialism like the fastest
National Socialism or communism it is
illegal to promote this type of
ideologies in Poland now although now
there's they try to change that uh they
there's a lot of forces now financed by
sorrows and bankers who are trying to
dismantle pollen right now they try to
bring a lot of refugees in Poland they
try to build a hate of Paul's one
towards another they try to build this
French group or group with questionable
morality they try to push a man into
girls bathrooms so this is this is
something who is coming from overseas
from outside of Poland which is Poland
it is now under attack so they try to
they they try to defend themselves but
you know I think what happened here you
know the think the best the real life
teaches you a lot the girl the the girl
who was jailed in uh in Russian prison
she refused to stand up to uh to our
flag our Anthem and look how she changed
after she experienced how patriotic she
became after she returned from prison
after two years and become with a stand
up for for Anthem now she she I believe
she's patriotic but imagine how
patriotic I am after 20 years in this
type of prison and this is this is one
of the things that the other thing I
want to say is just how grateful I am
for the perspective that that you give
us in this book uh I think I A lot of
times lack that perspective uh and just
to be reminded of it is really powerful
so I'm super fortunate to you know I'm
thank God America got Drago and thank
God the SEAL Teams got Drago man
I want to say thank you because you
actually made my point this is the the
reason I wrote this book I want people
to read it and not and and Muse how bad
it is everybody knows how bad the
socialism communist mess I want people
to read and think how great America is I
want this book to be a prism a lens
where you see the good things about
America which we tend not to sometimes
notice I see people here or not maybe
some the younger generation not being
aware about the Great America and how
unique country in the world it is so
that's that's why you wrote this book
yeah that way people don't have to go to
a Russian prison in order to realize
that they should be uh very grateful for
the freedom that we have here in this
country and they can just go oh yeah
we're blessed to be here yes that's
that's what I would like to see people
to see my book well that's what it
delivers any Drago any closing thoughts
you got anything else for this time
around
I think the same thing for me it is
important we lost many guys in this war
many uh teammates but also other
military personnel and
they leave they're still alive in our
minds in our hearts so we this is how we
want to keep them alive and we must not
allow them to die again by fading from
our memories so we need to call their
names we need to be we need to remember
we need to remember them and we need to
pray for them and their families we are
the the
the
these families lost their protectors
we need to step in we must be their
protectors now so just just that thought
yes indeed
um well you know
as I read the book I know that
from the book years ago
before you even made it to America while
you were waiting in in West Germany to
get your to get your final flight over
here to America you made a pledge you
made a promise you made a pledge to be
the best American citizen that you
possibly could be and uh I want to tell
you without a doubt you achieved that
goal and I think you've gone above and
beyond that pledge you know from working
as a janitor to a parts picker to a
mechanic to a parachute expert and then
when our country went to war what did
you do you went and volunteered to fight
and you served
with a distinction
as a seal
on multiple combat deployments
and it was an honor to serve alongside
you then and it's an honor to always be
able to call you brother and likewise
it is a great honor to be called
American and I this is something that I
cherish the most
and it was honored to share with you
another my fellow seals and I would say
thank you for
for allowing me to come to this country
and live as a free man and that thank
you is for every American every every
person here in America
I would say thank you I will never
forget that well thanks for your
perspective and thanks for being an
American thanks brother
and with that
Thomas Drago Zaron has left the building
not much I mean damn
what a freaking story huh talked about
getting better man
that guy
so Socialist Communist Poland prison
prison
yeah walks up to the Embassy
what's up
yep you know what I
failed to talk to him about first of all
I kind of went into like he's kind of a
mutant obviously like he's 63 years old
right how does he look uh I mean I would
guess like early 50s I I'd probably say
around late like I'd probably say early
50s really yeah I think he looks like
he's 33. he looks like yeah he looks
young and he's freaking jacked he's Jack
and uh and he's he was a really I hinted
to it like he was a when you'd see him
like fighting you'd be like yep he's
he's a good athlete explosive he has
explosive and like I trained with him
you know so you could feel like oh yeah
he's really explosive and he would learn
really quickly uh but he's just a just a
stud but what was I going to say about
this oh just a beast yeah a beast oh
what I didn't what I didn't talk to him
too much about like how did he prepare
for buds I think he just I think his
life was preparation for butts and his
genetics are preparation for buds
because uh
yeah he he was putting that he was
putting those MMA pieces together early
on too when he was talking about the the
boxing fundamentals then the karate the
Taekwondo stuff is getting that little
mix and then take him to the streets
yeah taking it to the streets uh but
what a what a what a great dude and you
know a big freaking heart you know like
just a big heart wants to help people
out so
awesome oh so I was lucky to be able to
work with him and I work with him a lot
man like you know we did a lot of Ops
you know it's freaking legit so uh like
I said man what a freaking awesome dude
so there you go
um I think we need to take advantage of
our freedom here
and we do that by getting after it by
getting better so we're getting better
Jocko feel jockle fuel chocolate
fuel.com go get yourself some go get
yourself I'm right now fueled up on Jaco
by the way it's like 10 o'clock at night
right now we just recorded for however I
don't even know how long it was five
four four and a half five hours or
something like that something like that
but guess what here I am
do I sound amped you sound does I'm
still freaking fired up I'm kind of
fired up because of Drago yeah I'm also
fired up because I got my girl up in me
so get yourself an actual clean energy
drink get yourself some some Mulk get
yourself some of that 30 grams of
protein hitter you know what my combo is
now Mulk cookie 14 grams of protein and
a Mulk 30 grams right there you're good
44 G's of the protein machine coming at
you that's us that's a
that is a gratifying thing to do in your
life like you know what it's like let's
say
your you know your timeline whatever you
need you need protein you already Jack
steel maybe you did squats maybe you did
snatches I don't know what you did but
you know you need some protein boom you
get that milk cookie and then you get
that milk
RTD hitter and and you do it in 37
seconds you get them both down yeah I
think the actual time is 44 grams of
protein in 44 seconds one gram per
second uh jockoffool.com get yourself
joint Warfare get yourself to get
yourself that freaking Time Warner to
get in there get in there on that um
jockofuel.com you can get it all vitamin
shop you can get it G and c I just had
someone text me just got it at GNC yo
we're in there we're at Wawa right now
people were hassling Wawa the other day
because on Twitter some people are like
yo I just went to I just went to Wawa
they had a one can bottom right corner
I'm like yup I said hey let let Wawa
know
you want your go and people were getting
fired up but who knows you know we're up
against some some billion dollar literal
billion dollar uh
conglomerates there of all the people
though we got the people right you know
we've got Rebellion we got solidarity we
got solidarity a Jocko fuel uh Vitamin
Shoppe GNC aphes just found out people
been asking just found out we're gonna
be going into the Navy exchanges the NEX
boy and look I know all you young
Troopers out there I know all you Young
Marines all young Sailors are out there
I know you go to the NEX I know you
don't go to the damn Commissary because
you're like yo I'm not doing that so we
got in there we got into the NEX well I
don't know it'll be the next next few
months it'll be in there uh Dash doors
in Maryland Wakefern ShopRite HEB
HEB killing it everyone in Texas thank
you thank you for supporting America
thank you for supporting yourself that's
what you're doing you're supporting this
podcast by the way this podcast is
fueled by Jocko fuel
Meyer in the midwest Harris Teeter
in the game Lifetime Fitness Shields and
and we got small gyms Jiu Jitsu gyms
CrossFit Gyms we got you covered email
JF sales at jockofuel.com if you want to
get it in your in your facility
that's what we got going on so
jockofuel.com check out originusa just
came out with the RTX line Roll Train
execute clothing to wear while you're
getting after it
that's what it is the quick dry the the
anti-smell what's the anti-smel called
anti-microbial anti-micro we got it
going on and you know what
it's American made
it's made by freedom
it's made by Freedom you heard you heard
Drago talking about it
communism socialism government
controlled well guess what China is
guess where your shirts from
your guess where your shorts are from
they're from freaking China
you are keeping someone imprisoned
when you buy their so don't do it
buy American
buy freedom
support National Security
originusa.com go get it hunt gear Jiu
Jitsu gear Jiu Jitsu geez rash guards
boots just Goku originusa.com that's
what we got going on we also got Jocko
store.com look at you look at you coming
in on cue like Echo look at you over
there and I'm feeling that seat bro I
said it right there guys we don't even
need Echo Charles around these parts
anymore huh is that what's going on
jacostore.com we got rash guards
t-shirts your discipline equals Freedom
represent on the path look at you bro
like
EC's not needed is he he's just filling
it in hey everyone he sees in Hawaii
before you freak out he's on vacation
you know because he needs a break he'd
been under a lot of stress he's been
working hard EC just you know you've
been going around the clock over here
cruising so that's why K dog's here but
apparently he's stepping up to the plate
he was ready dude he's freaking getting
in there
getting in there we got trucker hats
hoodies beanies um we've got Warrior
Kids soap from Irish Oaks Ranch uh we
got the Jocko soap on there the
throwback steakly the throwback what
stay clean son oh stay clean boy stay
clean uh sherlocker as well don't forget
about the shirt Locker that's where
that's where the what is Echo call the
the creative designs yes sir
so check that out subscribe to the
podcast subscribe to
subscribe to Jocko underground
jackunderground.com that's where look
you can get we could we we don't control
the platform
unless you're listening to us on Jocko
underground.com which you might be we
don't control the platform they can shut
us down tomorrow the Communists could
take over
that could happen but if it does happen
you'd be right there on the Underground
we're there we will be still we'll be
like Radio free America on the
Underground that's where we're gonna be
eight dollars and 18 cents a month if
you want to join the revolution the
resistance come and get it
if you can't afford 8.80 well don't
worry we got you email assistance at
underground.com and we got you we got a
YouTube channel subscribe to that
subscribe to
origin USA YouTube channel subscribe to
Jocko fuel YouTube channel subscribe to
Echelon front YouTube we got a bunch of
YouTube channels
uh psychological warfare go and buy that
if you need to hear me talk more or
revisit that if you haven't listened to
psychological warfare in a minute go
back it's a good one to get into go back
please go back uh it's like uh uh
Flipside canvas Dakota Meyer bunch of
books number one book The Pledge to
America by Thomas Drago Drago zeron
check that one out
freaking great book and then I read a
bunch of books too final spin leadership
strategy tactics Field Manual you guys
know the deal look get your kids a book
get your kids Warrior one two three four
and five get your kids Mikey and the
dragons get your kids about face by
Colonel David hackworth because they
need it they need it boy all right uh
extreme ownership dichotomy leadership
it's all in there Echelon front we have
a leadership consultancy we solve
problems through leadership go to
ashlandfront.com for details we got the
Dallas
muster October 18th through 20th we got
the next Battlefield is August 8th
through 10th I think there's a couple
seats left a couple slots left it's that
Little Bighorn you want to see where it
went down you want to walk the
battlefield you want to study the
terrain and the leadership and the
personalities come and get it we'll be
up there also we have the assembly
which is the for it's a women's event
run by Jamie Cochran the CEO at Echelon
front September 14th through 16th in
Phoenix Arizona go check that out we
also have online training
because we can't get to the whole world
but we're trying and the way we're
trying is through online training
extreme ownership.com learn
the Jujitsu of leadership
learn the magic of leadership
learn the Maneuvers the skills the
tenets learn how to lead it's not
natural it's not a natural gift
it's something you have to learn
extreme ownership.com we will teach you
you can also come on there and just ask
me questions you can come on there and
take some courses whatever you want to
do just get in there new uh new course
out on the academy right now which one
is it uh relationships with yourself and
Dave Burke good deal Dave good deal Dave
yeah relationships are everything
relationships or everything it's some of
the things that you do to build
relationships are counterintuitive you
might not be doing what you think you're
doing
so get in there take that take that
relationships course believe me you
build good relationships with other
people
if you build good relationships with the
people you work with if you build good
relationships with you the people in
your family if you build good
relationships with the people that you
interact with in the world
the car mechanic the plumber the teacher
the college professor the doctor
the boss the subordinate the peer if you
form good relationships with these
people your entire life is going to be
better and their entire life is going to
be better so don't you but you don't
necessarily know how to do this
check it out extreme ownership.com to
learn how to build relationships learn
how to lead if you want to help service
members active and retired you want to
help their gold star families
you want to help
just service members in general you want
to help people that need it
go to Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's got
a charity organization it's a great
organization
uh it's at America's Mighty Warriors dot
org and
if you want to donate if you want to get
involved you can go and look at what she
does to provide
one of the huge parts of what she does
is provide medical treatment for people
that need it that's outside the realm of
what the VA provides
it's outstanding I've seen it completely
a 180 turn around my friends lives
so check that one out also heroes and
horses dot org Micah Fink
he takes veterans up into the wilderness
so they can find themselves again
and it's extremely powerful
and when he's not doing that he's like
single-handedly
uh hunting down mountain lions with
slingshots that he made out of Rawhide
he's just getting it that there you go
if you want to connect with us on the
interwebs
connect to Drago Drago's at he's he's
got a website dragozron.com
he's on social media
he's on his social media which is
connect Zing he's also on Instagram and
Twitter at Drago zeron
Carrie is at Carrie Helton Carrie
underscore Helton he didn't get that
carry Hilton he wasn't quick enough it's
all good I'm at jockey Williams just
watch out on any of those watch out for
the algorithm don't forget about bone
fraud bone frog coffee bone
frogcoffee.com go and give that a check
out
we got a we got a team guy
we got a seal that is
making an awesome coffee for you and
he's helping out veterans and he's uh
trying to take care of his family right
now in a big way trying to take care of
his wife so go and check that out if you
can and uh thanks to all the military
personnel around the world
thank you for our freedom
that you've given us
for centuries thank you
for standing up and holding the line
thanks to our allies
throughout the course of history that
have supported us in the fight for
freedom
special recognition for the the Polish
Armed Forces including the Grom who had
my back over and over again
over in Iraq who took care of Drago
we thank you for standing with us in the
fight to preserve freedom and also
thanks to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service all of you First
Responders thank you for your sacrifice
to keep us safe here at home and
everyone else out there
isn't it crazy
to think
about what people have to suffer through
and how easy it is to take things for
granted things like running water
things like being able to travel freely
things like a bed things like food
things like
music and art and speech and thought
being free
being able to do what we want that's
freedom
how often do we take it for granted too
often
how often do we forget the price that's
been paid too often how often do we
ignore the opportunities that freedom
presents
too often
so remember
from Drago's story and he's one of the
lucky ones by the way he's one of the
ones that only went to prison
he wasn't murdered he wasn't buried in
an unmarked grave how many thousands and
tens of thousands were he's one of the
lucky ones that was able to escape but
we have to remember that our freedom is
not free and that it is fragile and that
we have to cherish it and protect it and
we have to take advantage of the
opportunities we get from freedom and
it's a travesty if we don't do that
so
go use your freedom go live go breathe
go build and create and speak and think
and relish
relish this freedom
and that's all we've got
and until next time this is Carrie and
Jocko
out